COULD I. CAN'T EVEN COUNT ON
THESE NOTES. NO ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA WE'RE GONNA DO A QUICK
RESTART HERE GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU
ALL AND WELCOME TO SUBCOMMITTEE
THREE ON CLIMATE CRISIS
RESOURCES ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION- AS HAS BECOME
CUSTOMARY I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
READ SOME DIRECTIONS REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP INSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. TODAY
WE ARE HERE AND ROOM FOR THIRTY
SEVEN IN THE CAPITAL HAVING A
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING. OF COURSE IN THIS ROOM
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW
MEMBERS A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF
STAFF AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF
THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO THAT WE
CAN MAINTAIN SIXTY THE SPACING.
THERE ARE ALSO FOR STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE
HERE TODAY TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WILL RESTATE TO- THESE
SAID- ITEMS LATER ON WHEN
PUBLIC COMMENT BEGINS BUT IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK THEY WILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND ALL
ASKED HIM TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE- WE DO ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC GUIDE ANYONE. SPEAKING
AT THE MICROPHONE RESPECT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND PLEASE
DO NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU WILL HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT IS DONE- OR WITH
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT IS DONE OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT BUT PLEASE
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
THE PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA AND
THE L. A. O. R. APPEARING
REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. THERE WILL BE NO
VOTE IN THE COMMITTEE TODAY. WE
ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE END OF THE HEARING BOTH IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD ALSO BE ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING
OVER THE INTERNET. BUT THAT
PHONE NUMBER IS PUBLIC TOLL
FREE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
AGAIN THE PHONE NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS. PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2099 AND
A FRIENDLY STAFF MEMBER WILL
ASSIST YOU. AGAIN THAT PHONE
NUMBER IS NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE NINE-
BUT FIRST YOU SHOULD BE TRYING
TO CALL IN ON THE TOLL FREE
NUMBER. THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. WE DO ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING-
PLEASE SEND YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO BUDGET SUB THREE
THAT'S NUMERAL THREE BUDGET SB
THREE AT ASM DOT CA DOT GOV. WE
HAVE FIVE ITEMS TODAY ON THE
NON PRESENTATION CALENDAR AND
TWELVE ITEMS TO BE OUGHT TO BE
HEARD. OF COURSE WILL TAKE
MEMBER QUESTIONS WE'LL DO THAT
AFTER EACH ISSUE WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT. ON ALL TWELVE ITEMS TO
BE HEARD. AT THE END OF THE
HEARING- WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING AFTER ALL ITEMS HAVE
BEEN HEARD. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A- AN ITEM OUT OF ORDER TODAY
AND BEGIN WITH ISSUE EIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
EXTENSION OF THE REAL ID
RESOURCES AND OPERATIONAL
IMPROVEMENTS. AND THEN AFTER A
WE WILL RETURN TO THE REGULAR
ORDER OF THE AGENDA. OUR
PANELISTS TODAY ON- ISSUE EIGHT
ARE THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
MISTER STEVE GORDON. LEE SCOTT
THE CHIEF BUDGET OFFICER FROM
THE DMV. MATTHEW MACEDO FINANCE
BUDGET ANALYST FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
EUNICE ROW FISCAL AND POLICY
ANALYST WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND. DO WE
HAVE OUR PANEL. AVAILABLE AND
READY TO GO. THIRTY CHAIR.
GREAT LOCAL HAD RESTARTED IT'S
GOOD TO HEAR FROM YOU TODAY
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU SO
GOOD MORNING SIR- EXCUSE ME I'M
SORRY- FORGIVE ME FOR
INTERRUPTING YOU- I HAVE AND-
SOMETHING I NEED TO TAKE CARE
OF AT TEN AM- AND- SO AT TEN A
I'M GOING TO QUIETLY GET UP AND
LEAVE BUT MS RIVAS- IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO. LEAD THE MEETING
UNTIL I RETURN. THANK YOU-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY SO I GOT
MY CHECK MANY NUMBERS AGAINST
MY NAME IS LI P. OUT
SOMETHING'S GOT ON THE CHIEF
BUDGET OFFICER FOR DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES AND WITH ME
TODAY AS OUR DIRECTOR STEVE
GORDON. TOPIC THANK YOU FOR THE
DOCTOR DRESSED COMMITTED STATE
OF THE MARKET DOES HAVE ONE
ISSUE THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE FOR
DISCUSSION ON THE AGENDA I LIKE
TO PROVIDE A QUICK OVERVIEW. OF
THE ISSUE AND THEN THE DIRECTOR
I WILL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE SO WE'RE
GONNA START WITH RELY THE
OPERATIONAL IMPROVEMENTS CAN BE
IS REQUESTING TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN POINT SEVEN PERMANENT
POSITIONS AT A HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX MILLION OF FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
INCLUDING ONE TIME AND ONGOING
FUNDING AS PART OF THE
EXTENSION OF RELATED RESOURCES.
AN OPERATION PREVENTS BASICALLY.
THIS IS OUR- FOR RE. TO THE
APARTMENT. OF THE- BAN. EVERY
LIFE YAK. WHICH REQUIRES THAT
THE- PERCENT OF. COMPLIANT FIVE
LICENSE OR ID CARD. TO BOARD AN
AIRPLANE I AM INTERESTED CARE
PRODUCTS. BEGINNING OCTOBER ONE
TWENTY ONE. CURRENTLY IN ORDER
TO OBTAIN A REAL ID YOU ARE
REQUIRED TO VISIT A FIELD
OFFICE. THE REQUESTED RESOURCES
WILL CONTINUE FUNDING ROUGHLY
ONE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE EXISTING TYPE
POSITIONS INCLUDING PEP HIRES.
BERMAN INTERMENT EMPLOYEES.
OVERTIME ABERTURA HIRED A NEW
PINS TO ADDRESS THE SHORT TERM
INCREASE IN WORKLOAD.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE REALIZE THE
IMPLEMENTATION. THIS WILL ALSO
ASSIST IN KEEPING MY TIMES LIKE.
A COUPLE LEVELS. IT IS A TEST
FOR ABOUT EIGHT OF NEARLY
TWENTY MILLION CAL. WANT TO
RECEIVE A FEDERALLY COMPLIANT
REAL ID CARD BY THE END OF
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. THAT'S SOMETHING
IMPORTATION OF THE REAL ID ACT
IN JANUARY OF EIGHTEEN TO GET
THE HAS ISSUED NEARLY NINE AND
A HALF MILLION WHO DIED A READ
REAL ID CARDS. ABBOTT THE
EXPECTED COMPLIANCE DATE OF
OCTOBER ONE TWENTY ONE. BMB IS
PREPARING FOR PROXIMITY SIXTEEN
MILLION RELATED CARD HOLDERS BY
THE END OF THE STATE. AN
ADDITIONAL TEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION BILL IDEA HAWK
CARDHOLDERS- IS ANTICIPATED BY
THE END OF FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. I DO WANT TO
NOTE THAT THIS LAST MINUTE- AT
DISSOCIATE UPON YOUR REQUEST
DOES TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
CURRENT PUBLIC RESTRICTIONS
RELATED TO SOCIAL DISTANCING.
OUR POTENTIAL CHANGES IN
CUSTOMER BEHAVIOR IN RESPONSE
TO THE VACCINE ROLLOUTS. AND
THE LIFTING OF RESTRICTIONS AS
THINGS. MOVE BACK THE QUOTE
UNQUOTE NORMAL. AS A RESPONSE
THE- DO YOU DID YOU IS- FUNDING
EVERY. OF THAT I. TWENTY B. C.
P. TO BEGIN EXPAND. THE
ALTERNATIVE SIR CHANNELS.
PROVIDE BECAUSE OTHER. TO
COMPLETE THIRTEEN BUSINESS
WITHOUT HAPPY TO COME TO A- A
PUBLIC FIELD OFFICE. SOME OF
THESE OPTIONS INCLUDE EXPANDING
THE INTERNET TRANSACTION
AVAILABILITY. OF VIRTUAL FIELD
OFFICE TRANSACTIONS AND
UTILIZING THE ROBOTICS
PROCESSING AUTOMATION. TO
COMPLETE THEIR TRANSACTIONS
WITHOUT AN IN PERSON VISIT.
FOUGHT ONE ANOTHER THIS REPORT
ALSO INCLUDES RESOURCES TO FIND
A COMMUNICATION CAMPAIGN TO
ENSURE CUSTOMERS ARE AWARE OF
THE AVAILABLE SERVICE
ALTERNATIVES. BANK CUSTOMER
SERVICE IMPROVEMENTS SUCH AS
THE REAL ID. AUTOMATED
DOCUMENT- VERIFICATION PROJECT.
AT A RANGE OF ONLINE CHAT
SERVICES TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO
GIVE. THE SERVICE OUTSIDE THE
FIELD OFFICE. I THIS REQUIRES
ALL. ADDRESSES THE ONGOING NEED
FOR FUN FOR AWP IMPROVEMENTS
THE KIND OF THE SITE PART OF.
OTHER WERE MADE WITH THE COULD
BY- SAY THAT'S THE OFFICES.
ALSO VALUATIONS AND THE
GOVERNOR TRACK TEAM THAT WAS
DONE IN. TWENTY EIGHT. RECHNET
REC RECORD. TO IMPROVE THE BE
PROUD AND HAVE TO FILL OFFICE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE. FUNDING
FOR THIS WAS ORIGINALLY
APPROVED IN NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET ACT AS OF THIS WEEK HE
WAS PARTICULAR LIMITED TERM
PARENT. AND THE SUBSEQUENT
REQUESTED TO CONTINUE THE
ONGOING FUNDING. TO CONTINUE
WITH INITIATIVES AND EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO GET THE
SERVICES. INSIDE AND OUTSIDE
THE FIELD OFFICE. THE PROPOSAL
BUT OPERATE PURPOSE SUCH AS
INCREASE. OVERSIGHT TRAINING
SELF SERVICE KIOSKS AND OFFICE
OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS STOPPING. IT
ALSO INCLUDES FUNDING FOR MUCH
NEEDED IT PROJECTS SUCH AS-
REPLACEMENT AND OUTDATED
UNRELIABLE TERMINALS SERVERS
CIRCUITS AND OTHER INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY RESOURCES. NECESSARY
TO SUPPORT THE NEW ONLINE
SERVICES. SO IT'S B. C. PEOPLE
THE VAST. A NUMBER OF AREAS BUT
WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ABOUT THE
RELY THE IMPLEMENTATION. AND
THE BASS NUMBER PREVENT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS INITIATED TO
IMPROVE THE SERVICE. I THANK
YOU CHECK. THANK YOU WHAT WE
ARE PROCEED WITH OUR NEXT TO
SPEAKER WE HAVE- ANYONE ELSE
FROM- DMV IF NOT- LET'S MOVE ON
TO- LA ON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I THINK READY FOR LA LA CHAIR.
IN MOURNING AT THIS IS UNITS
ROW AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. BEFORE ARE
COMMON SPECIFIC TO THAT REAL ID
PROPOSAL- COMMITTEE STAFF HAVE
ACCESS TO QUICKLY SUMMARIZE
CURRENT CONDITION OF THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT AND- ADD IF
THAT IS OKAY YES I'LL PROCEED
WITH THAT AND THEN- LEVINE TO
CONSPIRE TO BECOMING A REALITY
PROPOSAL. YES THAT'LL BE FINE
THANK YOU. EIGHT OKAY SO MOTOR
VEHICLE. AND SUPPORTS THE IN
THE- FOURTH MAN AS LOGICAL. THE
OPERATION REGISTRATION VEHICLES
USED ON PUBLIC ROADS AND
HIGHWAYS AS WELL AS MITIGATION
OF ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS-
VEHICLE EMISSIONS. THE NBA
RECEIVE MOST OF ITS REVENUE
FROM VEHICLE REGISTRATION FEES
AND THE NBA IT'S EXPECTED TO
RECEIVE A TOTAL OF FOUR POINT
THREE BILLION IN REVENUES IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY Q. WITH
NICKEL REGISTRATION FEES
ACCOUNTING FOR IT THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION OR ABOUT EIGHTY
FOUR PERCENT. OF THEIR OPINIONS.
YEAH THE ADDRESS FROM LICENSE
FEES AS WELL AS- OTHER
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES. THE NBA
PRIMARY PROVIDES FOR THREE
STATE DEPARTMENTS THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES IN
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
FUNDING SUPPORT STAFF
COMPENSATION DEPARTMENT
OPERATIONS AND CAPITAL
EXPENSES. FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO A TOTAL OF FOUR POINT ONE
BILLION IS EXPECTED TO BE SPENT
FROM THE MBA MOSTLY SPORTS EACH
PM PM PM. I'M OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS- THE NBA HAD
PERIODICALLY FAITH RIGHT SEVEN
POP AND SEE AND FOR EXAMPLE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THE
ADMINISTRATION PROJECT THAT THE
NBA WOULD BECOME INSOLVENT BY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SO IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
THE LEGISLATURE MADE SEVERAL
CHANGES TO REDUCE EXPENDITURES
AND TRANSFERS AND ACCOUNT- AS
PART OF THE NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET PACKAGE- INCLUDING-
FUNDING EACH P. AREA OFFICE
REPLACEMENT. ME THREATEN YOU
FIND. FIFTEEN THIRTY AND TIME
CAN BE EXPENDITURES TO THE
GENERAL FIND AT THE LANCASTER
AND I'M CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS. BILLING SUPPLEMENTAL
PENSION PAYMENTS TO THE GENERAL
FINANCIAL SPENDING TRANSFERRED
ONTO THE GENERAL FUND. IN THE
FOLLOWING YEAR AT. THE
LEGISLATURE TOOK ADDITIONAL
COST CONTROL MEASURES BUDGET
REDUCTION THE EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION COSTS INCLUDING AN
H. P. AT ANTI IN THE EMPLOYEES
AND THE LAYING FROM CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS DUE TO THE
ECONOMIC DESTRUCTION BROUGHT ON
BY THE PANDEMIC. AND DESPITE
CRACKS IN. PROJECTS THE ACCOUNT
CONTINUES TO BE FISCALLY
CONSTRAINED IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF BUT YEARS THAT SIGNED THE
PROJECTED TO HAVE ONLY HAVE
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION OR
ABOUT 2% OF THE FUND REVENUES
AND FUND BALANCE. AND OF EACH
YEAR- AND BY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE TO FUNDED PROJECTED TO GET
EXPERIENCE OPERATIONAL
SHORTFALL- WHEN EXPENDITURES
ARE EX THE EXPECTATIVAS REVENUE
FROM TRANSFERRED FIVE HUNDRED
SIXTY MILLION LEAVING THAT FIND
THEMSELVES AND- OF COURSE IF
ACTUAL REVENUE AND EXPENSE.
DIFFERENTLY FROM THE PRODUCTION
THAT IT'S POSSIBLE TO FIND
COULD BECOME INVOLVED EVEN
EARLIER- IT'S A MAJOR COST
DRIVERS IN THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS INCLUDE EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION BECAUSE I AND THE
PROPOSED ENGINE AT THE REAL ID
OPERATIONAL GROUP EVERY
THURSDAY. FOR THE DMV AND THE
ON GOING ON THE M. B. I. T.
PROJECT AND I'M THE DMV ANTI H.
P. A. CAPITAL. PROJECTS AND-
ALTHOUGH THE FINAL REMAINS. AS
BUDGET YEAR AND THEN COUPLE OF
YEARS TO FIND FISCALLY
CONSTRAINED. AND THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD KEEP AT THAT
FRANKEN MISSION IN MIND AS THEY
CONSIDER PROPOSALS FUNDED FROM
THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT AND
PARTICULARLY A PROPOSAL
THANKFULLY ONGOING COMMITMENT
FROM THE FIND. I'M AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ON THE- AND THEN
D. IF I'M CONDITION- IF NOT I
CAN AT PROCEED OUR COMMON. IN
ABUNDANCE REALIZED IN
OPERATIONAL IMPROVEMENTS
SPECIFIC TO FOOTBALL BUT WHAT
IF YOU GO AHEAD WILL DO A
QUESTIONS. AT THE END OF ALL
THE PRESENTATIONS. SIX EIGHT
THANK YOU. OKAY THERE ARE FOR
THE REAL ID AND- ON CHRISTMAS
SUPPOSED WI FI OUT OF THE. FOR
THE OPERATION ON. I AM
CUSTOMERS AND I. T. IMPROVE
IT'S REASONABLE AND IF WITH THE
AND THAT YOU'LL BE THAT
EVALUATIONS OF THE DEPART.
INDEPENDENT SAID THAT THE
ADDITIONAL RETORTED HOW HAD
POSITIVE AND ON DEPARTMENT
OPERATE. HOWEVER WE FIND THAT
THE PART ESTIMATE OF THE TEMP
FIELDS OFFICE STAFF REQUIRED
AND THE ABILITY ACOSTA
ADDRESSING REAL ID WORKLOAD ARE
HIGHLY DEPENDENT ON SEVERAL
FACTORS SOME OF WHICH ARE
FAIRLY UNCERTAIN. THE FACTORS
INCLUDE POTENTIAL FEDERAL
REGULATORY CHANGE AS CHANGES IN
CUSTOMER BEHAVIOR IN A
PANDEMIC- AND LONGER TERM
CUSTOMER PREFERENCES. FOR
ONLINE SERVICES. WE RECOMMEND
IT LET'S APPROVED PROVISION
ANTHONY FOR SERVICE OPERATIONS
IN I CAME. TOTALING ABOUT
ELEVEN MILLION AND HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE ACTIVISION'S IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY Q. AND WE
FIND THAT THESE POSITIONS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH ASSESSMENT OF
THE DEPARTMENT'S PREVIOUS
OPERATION OFFICER COMING AND
WILL ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO
MAINTAIN THE PROGRESS. MADE TO
DATE- AND WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVEDONLY
BUDGET YEAR POSITIONS AND
FUNDING FOR REAL ID OF WORKLOAD
AND GIVEN THE WORKLOAD
UNCERTAINTY WE RECOMMEND ONLY
APPROVING A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE POINT ONE MILLION AND THE
FOURTEEN NINETY THREE POSITIONS
FOR REAL ID WORK BUT IN TWENTY
ONE ST. AND THIS WAY THE
LEGISLATURE COULD PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OR BECAUSE I
REQUIRED TO COME BACK NEXT YEAR
WITH A NEW FUNDING PROPOSAL
WHICH COULD BE. INFORMED BY
ANOTHER YEAR OF DATA ON
CUSTOMER BEHAVIOR AND POSSIBLE.
FEDERAL ACTION. AND THAT IS ALL
ABOUT COMMON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DO WE HAVE COMMENTS FROM-
THE A DEPARTMENT FINANCE. YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SMACK IN THE STUDIO WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
REGARDING THE MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCOUNT. I'LL JUST ADD THAT-
THE MINISTRATIONS CONSTANTLY
MONITORING THIS FUND BOB WE
HAVE WORKED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO KEEP. THE FUND
BALANCE AT. ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION- AND WE'VE DONE THAT
FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS- AS
NOTED BY THE LA OF. IT
PROJECTEDTO BECOME INSOLVENT
AND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE BUT
WE WILL CONTINUE TO SEARCH FOR
SOLUTIONS AND MONITOR THAT AS
WE APPROACH THAT FIGURE- IN
REGARDS TO BE REAL ID AND
OPERATIONAL IMPROVEMENTS-
RECOMMENDATION BY THE L. A. O.
I AGREE THAT THERE IS
UNCERTAINTY REGARDING. THE LADY
ESPECIALLY IN A PANDEMIC AND
THE PERIPHERAL REGULATIONS
HOWEVER. WE KNOW THAT THE
DEMAND STILL EXISTS. IF PEOPLE
START TRAVELING AGAIN YEAH.
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO GET A
REAL ID- ENDED NINE RELATED
RESOURCES AFTER TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO WILL LIMIT THE
VISIBILITY TO PLAN FOR
PROCESSING REAL IDEAS IN THE
OUT YEARS. I NOTE THAT
SHOULDN'T JUST BE NEEDED- IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE OR SOME
OF THOSE OUT YEARS SIMILAR TO
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET- THE BUDGET
WILL CONTAIN LIKELY LANGUAGE
THAT ALLOWS US TO ADJUST WITH
NOTIFICATION- UNTIL LEGISLATURE.
IN REGARDS TO PROVIDING ONLY
THE FOUR TO NINETY THREE
PREPOSITIONS- REQUESTED TO
PROCESS REAL IDEAS AND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO- I WOULD. BOB
THAT THAT THAT WOULD HINDER
DMV'S ABILITY TO. PROVIDE LIVE
CHAT POSITIONS- RIGHT NOW
CUSTOMERS CAN LOG IN DMV'S
WEBSITE AND CHAT WITH A LIVE-
INDIVIDUAL THAT CAN HELP THEM
WITH OTHER TRANSACTIONS BESIDES
REAL ID THAT HELPS KEEP PEOPLE
OUT OF THE FIELD OFFICE WHICH
REDUCES WAIT TIMES AND WE ALL.
WANT TO REDUCE WAIT TIMES AT
THE END BEACON PROCESS MORRELL
ID'S- IT ALSO KIND OF REDUCES.
THE INVISIBILITY TO ME KIND OF
THE- AUDIT REQUIREMENTS OR AUTO
SUGGESTIONS FROM- SAY AND
BECAUSE OF OUR GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCIES. TRACK
TEAM- KIND OF A RECORD. ON THAT-
DMV NEEDED TO. HAVE A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE MANAGEMENT OVER
ITS FIELD OFFICES AND PART OF
THE- SIXTEEN SIXTEEN POSITIONS
SIXTEEN HUNDRED POSITIONS- WAS
PROVIDING POSITIONS THAT HELPED.
WITH THAT SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE
LEGISLATURE TO APPROVE ALL
SIXTEEN HUNDRED- TEMPERED
DITIONS. SO I WONDER IF ONE OF
YOU COULD- I EDUCATE US AS TO
HOW MANY PEOPLE ACTUALLY
RECEIVED A REAL IDEA AT THIS
POINT AND TO- HOW MANY THE DMV
ANTICIPATES. UP WILL BE ISSUED
BETWEEN NOW AND OCTOBER. GOOD
DEBT CHAIRMAN BLOOM THIS IS US
STEVE GORDON DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT MOTOR
VEHICLES I'LL TAKE THAT THE
QUESTION I WORDS JUST UNDER TEN
MILLION UNIQUE REAL IDEAS TODAY
WE EXPECT WE NOW ON OCTOBER
FIRST TO DO WE SHOULD OTHER SIX
MILLION REAL ID'S. SO I THINK
THAT'S THE ANSWER TO QUESTION
ANOTHER SIX MILLION- AND WE
EXPECT THAT TO BE KIND OF BACK
END LOADED BECAUSE OF CODE
RESTRICTIONS AS STUFF AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER SO WE'RE
GONNA SEE MORE OF THOSE LATER
IN THE IN THE CALENDAR YEAR
THEN SOONER. AND DIRECTOR
GORDON IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU OUT
THE TWO- ARE YOU THINK THAT THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE IDENTIFIED
IN THE BCP. OF WILL ALLOW YOU
TO ACHIEVE THAT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS SIX MILLION- IN REAL
ID'S- BETWEEN NOW AND OCTOBER
AND THEN- WHAT IS THE
ANTICIPATED. NEED BEYOND. YEAH
DO SERVE AS A AS THE GOT MADE
THAT DO IT. A PEOPLE TO COULD
TO SEEK REAL IDEAS AFTER THE
DEADLINE WITHOUT A BE NOW BE
THE NEW FEDERAL STOP FEDERAL
AFTER OCTOBER FIRST. SO WE'RE
STILL GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER TEN
MILLION CALIFORNIA'S AFTER THE
OCTOBER FIRST DEADLINE THAT ARE
STILL GOING TO BE NEEDING TO.
CONVERT AND TODAY BASED ON
CURRENT LAW DHS I REQUIREMENTS.
THAT REQUIRES AN IN OFFICE
VISIT. A SELL OUT I DO BELIEVE
THAT THIS. RESOURCES ARE ARE
HELPFUL TO HAS TO BE ABLE TO BE
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE IN AND
SERVING THESE CUSTOMERS. AND AS
THAT LEASE GOT MENTIONED THAT
WE'VE DONE A NUMBER OF
IMPROVEMENTS SINCE WE LAST
SPOKE. ABOUT THINGS THAT WILL
SHORTEN THE IN OFFICE TIME
ESPECIALLY NOW DURING COVERED
WE WANT TO MINIMIZE THE AMOUNT
OF TIME PEOPLE ARE ARE PRESENT.
BUT WE'VE ALSO STREAMLINED. THE
PROCESS SO THE PEOPLE ARE MORE
EFFECTIVE SO WHEN THEY COME IN
THE OFFICE- OVER BEFORE I
STARTED THIS JOB OVER EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AGO HE'S TAKE ABOUT
TWENTY MINUTES FOR A REAL ID
TRANSACTION. AND NOW WE'RE DOWN
TO SUB TEN SO WE'RE CONTINUE TO
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS AS THE BERMAN
FINANCES MENTIONED. EVER
CONTINUE TO STREAMLINE OUR
OPERATION BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S
GOOD FOR CALIFORNIANS AND IT'S
GOOD FOR US AS WELL. TO
MINIMIZE THE NUMBER OF
RESOURCES IN TOUCH POINTS WE
HAPPEN THE PROCESS SO. YES I
THINK WE GOT THE RESOURCES ARE.
REQUIRED HOPE THERE WILL BE-
WHERE I THINK WE HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT WE ARE
SPENDING THE WELL AND MAKING
SURE THAT IN FACT YOU CAN PROVE
THE PROCESS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THAT DOES SOUND
LIKE A GREAT IMPROVEMENT IN
TERMS OF- A STREAMLINING CUT
THE PROCESS- DOES THERE REMAIN
AN ISSUE WITH RESPECT TO A- HI
PROVIDING THE PUBLIC PROVIDING
DOCUMENTATION. IN ORDER. TO
FACILITATE REAL ID.
UNFORTUNATELY THEY WERE. THAT
SIR I. DO WE DO REQUIRE ARE
THERE FOR- WELL NOT BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND OUR JOB
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE- OUR-
IT'S ME THE- THINGS. AS A LEASE
GOT MENTIONED THAT WE HAVE SOME
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS ARE USED.
ABOUT HALF OF OUR CSES TODAY
THAT COULD PRE VALIDATE THOSE
DOCUMENTS TO THE CUSTOMER KNOWS
BEFORE THEY COME IN. THAT THEY
ARE PREPARED. AND HAVE THE
RIGHT DOCUMENTS- READY FOR
PRESENTATION. OUR OUR GOAL IS
TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE THAT
PERCENTAGE OVER TIME THROUGH
MESSAGING AND CAMPAIGNS. AND
INCENTIVES TO GET PEOPLE IN A
DIFFERENT SPOT IN LINE- BUT YES
THE REQUIREMENTS SAID TO GET A
REAL ID ARE ARE. SIGNIFICANT
THAT NEED TO BE ABLE TO PRODUCE
DOCUMENTS BIRTH CERTIFICATES.
PASSPORTS AND SO ON MANY PEOPLE
HAVE THOSE BUT NOT EVERYBODY
HAS THAT READILY AVAILABLE.
THERE IS A BEEN THERE HAS BEEN
A CHANGE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THREE WOULD REDUCE THE NEED FOR
A PHYSICAL SOCIAL SECURITY
CARD. IN A NINE DIGIT SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER. SO THAT'S
GOING TO STREAMLINE THINGS SOON
BECAUSE MANY OF US JUST DON'T
HAVE THAT DATA AND MANY OF US
HAVE. THAT DATA MASK ON OUR ON
OUR- YELP WELL. PACED UP AND SO
ON SO IT WAS VERY HARD FOR
PEOPLE TO YOU. TO PRESENT AT
THAT WERE STARTING TO IMPLEMENT
THAT NOW THAT'LL CONTINUE TO
MAKE THE- IN OFFICE AS STEP
MUCH MORE. EFFICIENT I'M NOT
SAYING I'M A PACK RAT BUT- THE-
FOR SOME REASON I STILL HAVE MY
ORIGINAL SOCIAL SECURITY CARD.
THE HOBBIT. PROBABLY SOMETHING
NO NEEDS TO KNOW- WHAT IS THE A
CAN YOU APPLY THOSE TO- AHEAD
OF TIME AND IF SO WHAT'S THE
PROCESS FOR DOING THAT. YEAH SO
THAT YOU ACTUALLY CAN DO THAT
SO THERE'S REALLY TWO STEP
TODAY WE'RE DOING A PASSWORD
ERE IMPROVING THAT PROCESS NOW
TO TIGHTEN THOSE CONNECTIONS A
ONE PART IS FILLING OUT. THE
ONLINE APPLICATION WE
AFFECTIONATELY REFER TO AS THE
EDL FORTY FOUR THAT'S THE FORM
FORTY FOUR FOR A DRIVER'S
LICENSE THAT IS ESSENTIALLY
YOUR APPLICATION IN THE
APPLICATION THERE'S A MOTOR
VOTER STEP IN SO THERE'S SOME
FORM THAT HAS TO BE AT THE- END
OF THAT PROCESS. WE WE DIDN'T
SWITCH YOU OVER TO UPLOADING
DOCUMENTS IT WILL ASK YOU WHICH
DOCUMENTS YOU HAVE WILL BILL
THE CHECKLIST FOR YOU AND THEY
WILL ASK YOU TO DETERMINE HOW
YOU WANT TO UPLOAD THOSE
DOCUMENTS IT COULD BE FROM
FILES YOU'VE STORED LOW FUNNY
COMPUTER. OF COURSE YOU CAN DO
IT ON A MOBILE DEVICE AS WELL.
AS AS YOUR WHERE WE'VE DONE A
NUMBER OF IMPROVEMENTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A MOBILE
FIRST STRATEGIES SO EVERYTHING
THAT ALMOST EVERYTHING HE DID
AT THE DMV YES STARTS WITH THE
ABILITY TO DO IT FROM THE
MOBILE DEVICE IN REAL TIME AND
IN FACT- AS YOU VISIT YOUR
LOCAL OFFICE SORRY VISIT ANY
OFFICE. YOU'LL FIND THAT EVEN
OUR OUR TRIAGE REPRESENTATIVES
IN THE OFFICE WILL ADVISE
CUSTOMERS ABOUT HOW THE DOCTORS
TO GO AHEAD AND TAKE A PHOTO OF
HIM RIGHT THEN AND THERE START
THE JOURNEY SO WE CAN PRE
VALIDATE THEM AND SAVE THEM
TIME WHEN THEY GET TO THE
WINDOW SO HE COULD DO A FROM.
AT ANY TIME FROM DESKTOP FROM A
MOBILE DEVICE HI IT'S FAIRLY
GOOD COVERAGE I THINK VERY VERY
GOOD COVERAGE ACROSS THE STATE
USING THOSE TWO TECHNOLOGIES
THANK YOU I HOPE THAT- THAT
APPROACH TO TECHNOLOGY IS-
BECOME SHARED BROADLY- THROUGH
MANY AGENCIES BECAUSE- RIGHT
NOW IT'S- CLIP WE NOT BUT
BADLY. HIT MEMBERS SO. ARE
THERE ANY. OTHER QUESTIONS. I'M
SEEING NOT. SO WILL- THANK YOU
ALL FOR. YOUR THIS. MORNING
AND- WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON- WELL
WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA MOVE
BACKWARDS IN THE AGENDA MOVE
TO- ITEM SIX AND I'M GONNA TAKE
A SHORT BREAK. MS RIVAS WILL
TAKE OVER. YEAH. I CAN SAY.
START SORRY OF ITEMS ZERO
MISSION VEHICLE PROPOSAL WE
HAVE- THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OF THE ENERGY
RESOURCES CONSERVATION AND
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD-
AND THE L. A. O. N. AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT WE'LL
START WITH OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION. THANK YOU
AND GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
PATTY MONAGHAN AND THE LEAD
COMMISSIONER FOR TRANSPORTATION
AT THE ENERGY COMMISSION- AND
IT IS A PLEASURE TO BE HERE TO
TALK ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AS IT RELATES TO THEIR
MISSION VEHICLE FOR THAT IS
THAT THE ELECTRICAL. SPEAKING
TO ON THE- BOTH THE COMMISSION
AND BE A RESOURCE FOR. OF THE
WORLD OF THE ENERGY. AND THEIR
ARE COMPLEMENTARY INSTINCTS
WHEN IT COMES TO YOUR QUESTION
CALLS. YOU SEE IT'S ONLY FOR IN.
AND A BE WILL BE FOR A VEHICLE.
OUR AGENCIES ARE CLOSELY. WHICH
THIS A PUBLIC UTILITY
COMMISSION AND OTHER THINGS
AGENCIES TO SUPPORT TELEPHONE
CALL UNDER TRANCE OTHER CRIME
AND ENERGY GOALS. THE LAST YEAR
IN THE WAY OF DEVASTATING.
CAUSED IN PART BY WARMER. THE
STATUS QUO THAT SET THE STAGE
ON A CLEAR PATH. H. AND
TRANSPORTATION. IN ORDER TO THE
GOAL THAT HUNDRED PER OF NEW
PATH VEHICLES WILL BE MISSION
BY TWENTY FIVE. YEP SELFISH
GOALS FOR POWER VEHICLES
ADEQUATE. FOR THE INTERMISSION
THE NEXT FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
YEARS. I WOULD. BOTH THE CHILD
AND OPPORTUNITIES TO ACHIEVE
THESE AMBITIOUS TARGETS AND THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF
PRIORITIZING. AT THE EAST OUT.
I'M EXCITED THAT GOVERNORS
GOALS REALLY BUILD ON WHAT
WE'RE SEEING HAPPENING AT THE
GLOBAL LEVEL. SEVENTEEN
COUNTRIES HAVE COMMITTED 21100%
ELECTRIC VEHICLE FUTURE. IN
JANUARY THE GOVERNOR OF
MASSACHUSETTS FOLLOW BETTER
NUISANCE LEAD AND SET THE SAME
TARGET OF HAVING A 100% OF NEW
PASSENGER VEHICLE SALES. IN
EUROVISION BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE. AND. THREE THE GREETING
CARE ALL FALL SUIT IN JANUARY
GENERAL MOTORS BECAME THE FIRST
AMERICAN CARMAKER TO SET THE
GOAL CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS
ELECTRIC VEHICLE BUT THIRTY
THEN FORWARD ANNOUNCED YEAH IT
WAS A LOT ALL THE PASSAGE OF
THE- AND COMMERCIAL VEHICLE. IN
THE E. U. I TRY THIRTY TO THE
MOVE THE BAR UP IN THE YEAR WE
OFFER HER SIMILAR TO ON
ELECTRIC FROM VOLVO B. A CAR
MAKE. SO THAT'S A REALLY
STARTING TO THE MAIN. TODAY ARE
FORTY SIX DIFFERENT MODELS OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE AVAILABLE AND
MANY MORE ARE THE WAY. EARLY
NEXT YEAR IS BRAINTREE WE AND
ELECTED NOT MODEL AND IT
SIGNATURE FORD F. ONE FIFTY TWO
WHICH IS THE BEST SELLING CAR
IN. AND ACCORDING TO FORD THIS
IS AND HAVE THE BEST HORSE
POWER THE BEST WORK AND THE
BEST SIX CELEBRATION OF ANY OF
ITS F. ONE FIFTY. SO YOU'RE
YOU'RE EVEN GONNA BE ABLE TO
CHART OUR TOOLS FROM THAT SO
IT'S NOT LIKE YOU'RE
COMPROMISING ON ON VEHICLE
PERFORMANCE YOU'RE ACTUALLY.
GETTING BETTER PERFORMANCE WITH
THIS VEHICLE. AND WHEN IT COMES
TO THEIR MISSION TRANSFER.
AUTHORITY IT IS THE MISSION.
THAT THE WERE OUR NUMBER ONE
EXT LAST YEAR THERE'S THIRTY
FOUR IS THAT MANUFACTURED THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY DECORATED
COMPANY AND OVER SEVENTY
THOUSAND JOBS IN THE STATE. IN
THE SECTOR. NOW THE FOCUS ON
THE PROPOSED BUDGET. SO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET WILL
HELP THE STATE SCALE UP THEIR
MISSION TRANSPORTATION AND
OVERCOME KEY BARRIERS TO
COMMERCIALIZING THEIR MISSION
VEHICLE. SYSTEMICALLY THE
BUDGET PROPOSES TO EXTEND THE
ABA PROGRAM WHICH IS SET TO
EXPIRE AT THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. PROVIDE ABOUT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
INCENTIVES FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. GRANTS THE CVC
BONDING AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO
FRONT LOAD A BILLION DOLLARS OF
INVESTMENT IN ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THAT'S BOTH FOR BATTERY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. AND I'D LIKE
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SEEKING
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION
AUTHORITY. ONLY FOR FUNDING TO
BUILD OUT THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
TRINITY ENERGY COMMISSION MY
AGENCIES CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. SO THIS DOESN'T APPLY
TO ANY OF THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
MANAGED BY THE- BEFORE SUPPORT.
I REQUEST FOR CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY IS
BEING MADE TO MINIMIZE THE COST
OF BORROWING BY GETTING THE
BEST INTEREST RATES ON BONDS.
LET ME TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT IS INCLUDED IN THE EIGHTY
EIGHT PROGRAMS- IT BASICALLY
FUNDS FLAGSHIP PROGRAM AT THE
END RESOURCES BOARD AND THE
NATIONAL TALK ABOUT BOTH OF
THEM. SO I THINK EVERY SOURCES
BOARD EIGHTY EIGHT FUNDS THREE
PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS ON
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY CLEANER
VEHICLES. FIRST IS THE CARL
MOYER PROGRAM IT PROVIDES ABOUT
THIRTY MILLION OUT OF THE
PROGRAM'S TOTAL BUDGET OF ABOUT
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR. TO REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM
DIESEL POWERED VEHICLES. THIS
PROGRAM IS AN- BY ERROR
DISTRICT AND SUPPORTS LOCAL
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE AIR QUALITY.
SECOND IS THE AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES ABOUT THREE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR PER
VEHICLE PURCHASE INCENTIVES
WITH A FOCUS ON CUTTING HARMFUL
POLLUTION. AND LAST IS THE
ENHANCED FLEET MODERNIZATION
PROGRAM WHICH HELPS LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS RETIRE ENTRAPPED
HIGHER POLLUTING VEHICLES AND
GET ACCESS TO CLEANER ONES. AB
EIGHT PROVIDES AIR B. AND THE
BUREAU OF AUTOMATED AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR ABOUT THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. THIRTY ENERGY
COMMISSION EIGHTY EIGHT FUNDS
FOR CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES ABOUT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR FOR GRANTS THAT HELP THE
STATE. DIVERSIFIES
TRANSPORTATION FUEL CHOICES
BEYOND OIL. NOW I HAVE A LITTLE
BIT DEEPER INTO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET PRIORITIES- THE
APPOINT SENATE BEEN BILLED OUT
IN OBSERVATION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO WHY INVEST
IN VEHICLE INCENTIVES NOW. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR CLEAN CARTS FOR ALL WHICH
ALLOWS LOWER INCOME FAMILIES TO
SCRAP AN OLDER VEHICLE AND
REPLACE IT WITH A ZERO OR NEAR
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE. THE
BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES THREE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION FOR
CARDS ANY VEHICLE INCENTIVE
PROJECT. WHICH PROVIDES GRANTS
TO REPLACE YOU FOR THE A FULL.
MISSION THE ACROSS. SO THESE
GRANT PROGRAMS PROVIDE EARLY
EMISSION REDUCTIONS BEFORE
REGULATIONS ARE ESTABLISHED
THAT MANDATE THE SWITCH TO
ELECTRIC. THE PROGRAMS ARE ALSO
CRITICAL CARE DISTRICTS WHICH
ARE REALLY LIKE TURNING OVER
EVERY ROCK TO MEET PAYMENT
DEADLINES. WHY IS THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO WE NEED
THEIR MISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
CONVENIENT AND UBIQUITOUS
ACROSS THE STATE WE ALSO NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE HALF OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS WHO BRENT FEEL
COMFORTABLE BUYING AND THEIR
MISSION VEHICLE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A CONVENIENT PLACE TO
REFUEL IT. WITHOUT INVESTMENT
NOW WE ARE NOT GOING TO NEED
THE STATE'S TARGET FOR THEIR
MISSION CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THE
CURRENT GOAL IS TO HAVE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND CHARGERS
TO SUPPORT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ELECTRIC VEHICLES WE
ARE WELL ON OUR WAY TO BEATING
THAT ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
ELECTRIC VEHICLE TARGETS. WE
LOOK AT DATA- PUBLIC DATA ON
INVESTMENTS BY UTILITIES
PRESIDENCIES- AND- OUR
INVESTMENTS GOVERNMENT
INVESTMENT. AND WE ESTIMATE
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABOUT SIXTY
THOUSAND CHARGERS SHORT OF THAT
TARGET. WE'RE ALSO TWENTY ONE
STATION SHORT OF THE STATE'S
GOAL OF HAVING TWO HUNDRED
HYDROGEN PUBLIC HYDROGEN
STATIONS BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
AND WE'RE ALSO GOING TO NEED TO
SIGNIFICANTLY RAMP UP OUR TO
MEET OUR TARGETS FOR TWENTY
THIRTY AND BEYOND- AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY SEVEN REQUIRES ARE
AT MY AGENCY GUARANTEE
COMMISSION CAN DO IT NOW SINCE
THE TWENTY THIRTY CHARGING ME.
EVERY PUBLISHED A DRAFT
ANALYSIS THAT FOUND- THAT.
BASED ON THEIR DEBATE OVER
GONNA NEED ABOUT EIGHT BILLION
THAT. AND TO SUPPORT THEM ONE
THE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
CHARTER SO WE NEED TO GO FROM
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CHARGERS IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
THE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION IN
TWENTY THIRTY THAT. SAID THAT
THE STEEP RAMP UP. I WANT ALSO
EMPHASIZED THAT WHY WE'RE DOING
IT. AND IT'S REALLY AROUND WHAT
ARE IMPORTANT GOALS IMPROVING
PUBLIC HEALTH. CUTTING CLIMATE
POLLUTION. ADVANCING ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND JOB CREATION AND
PROMOTING EQUITY. ON THE HEALTH
SIDE. IF THE PRICE ALL OF YOU
BUT TRANSPORTATION IS. A MAJOR
SOURCE ARGUABLY OUR NUMBER ONE
SOURCE OF HARMFUL AIR POLLUTION-
IT'S SORT OF OVER 70% OF SMOG
FORMING NOT AT 95% OF TOXIC
DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER. THIS
IS REALLY- IMPACTING
COMMUNITIES WHO LIVE NEAR THE
COURT MARCH. ON THE CLIMATE SO-
IT'S THE FOURTH ATTACK OF OUR
GREENHOUSE WHEN YOU'RE CAN
PERMISSION FROM THE FOR OF THE
FUEL IT'S- AND UNLIKE THE REST
WHICH BEEN CUT IN HALF OVER THE
PAST DECADE. THE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS PRETENTIOUS YOU'RE
ACTUALLY TRENDING UP. ON THE ON
THE ECONOMY SIDE THERE'S A REAL
OPPORTUNITY IN THE NEAR TERM TO
BUILD OUT THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
AND AT THE ECONOMIC STIMULUS
THAT'S GOING TO HELP SUPPORT
RECOVERY. EITHER SHOVEL READY
PROJECT THEY'RE GONNA PUT
CALIFORNIANS TO WORK BUILDING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE NEED
FOR THE FUTURE. AND IT'S ALSO A
STIMULUS EVERY DOLLAR OF
INVESTMENT LEADS TO ANOTHER
DOLLAR THIRTY OF PRIVATE
INVESTMENT. AND THIS INVESTMENT
IS SENDING A SIGNAL THAT
COMPANIES CAN BANK ON. ON THE
EQUITY SIDE- WE ARE WE'VE DONE
ANALYSIS OF. WHAT THE WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS ARE FOR CHARGER
DISK DISTRIBUTION BASED ON SB
ONE THOUSAND REQUIREMENTS. AND
WE'RE FINDING THAT WHILE TARGET
DISTRIBUTION BROADLY FOLLOWS
EASY DEPLOYMENT WE NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB ENSURING BOROUGH NOT
UNITY AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. HAVE ACCESS TO
CONVENIENT CHARGING. WE ALSO
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA WHO LIVE IN MUMBAI
DWELLINGS HAVE BEEN ACCESS TO
CHARGING. SO TO SUMMARIZE THEIR
MISSION VEHICLES ARE THE
FUTURE. NOT TO THINK CALIFORNIA
THE GLOBAL. THE INVESTMENTS
THAT ARE PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WILL HELP
OVERCOME ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BARRIERS TO WIDESPREAD
COMMERCIALIZATION OF THEIR
MISSION VEHICLES THE LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE. I NOTHING NOW
WILL PROVIDE MARKET CERTAINTY
AND ENCOURAGE THE FICTIONAL
INVESTMENT BY INDUSTRY HERE IN
OUR HOME STATE. SUPPORTING GOOD
JOBS. FOR MORE EQUITABLE ACCESS
MAKE SURE EVERYONE. I'M JOINED
BY COLLEAGUES FROM THE ENERGY
COMMISSION RESEARCH REPORT AND
IT'S PART OF FINANCE TO FIND
YOUR QUESTIONS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE COMP. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER. OF WE
WILL- HAVE TO SAVE THE
QUESTIONS FOR THE END AFTER ALL
THE PANELISTS HAVE. HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK- NEXT. DO
WE HAVE SOMEONE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
BUT WE DO HAVE STRUCTURE
CALPERS YOUR RESEARCH BEFORE
BUT I SPOKE ON BEHALF OF BOTH
AGENTS OKAY I THINK THERE-
THEY'RE READY FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS ABOUT THE PORTION OKAY
GREAT- SO THEN WE MOVE ON TO-
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE L. A. L.
GOOD MORNING. COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF ROSS BROWN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
I'M GOING TO PROVIDE COME SOME
OF HIGH LEVEL- ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION IN
RESPONSE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS IN THESE AREAS-
BEFORE I. JUMP INTO SOME OF
THOSE COMMENTS I DO WANT TO
MENTION. WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
ANALYSES- RELATED TO THESE
ISSUES THAT ARE CLOSE TO OUR
WEBSITE OPEFULLY AVAILABLE TO
YOU ALREADY. WON SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO THAT AB AIDS THAT
SECURITIZATION PROPOSAL AND ONE
RELATED TO THAT CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PACKAGE AND SO I'M
NOT GONNA GO THROUGH. ALL THE
DETAILS ON THOSE YOU'RE DONE
THE ACT OF A NICE JOB OF
SUMMARIZING OF OUR- MAJOR
COMMENTS IN THOSE AREAS AND
THAT- COMMISSIONER ON AN
ALREADY- DID A GOOD JOB OF THIS.
THIS ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL. I
WANT TO DO IS REALLY FOCUS ON-
SOME OF KIND OF BIG ISSUES FOR
LOTUS CAN. THAT WE THINK THE
PROPOSED REYES- AND- KIND OF
STEP BACK IN THINKING ABOUT
THAT ISSUES AROUND HOW THE
STATE THAT YOU ITS CLIMB
AMERICA. GOAL AND PER-
REDUCTION FROM MOBILE SOURCE.
AND SO WE DIRECTOR ALLEGED
REALLY CAN THESE PROPOSALS I
PART OF THAT BROADER. CONTEXT
YOUR SENSE OF AB EIGHT THESE
WERE MAKES THEIR SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF. CHANGES BOTH IN KIND
GOALS THAT THE STATE A STAB IN
TERMS GREENHOUSE AND LOCAL AIR.
REDUCTION THE GOVERNOR. NEW JOB
GOAL THERE'S ALSO BEEN A LOT OF
NEW POLICIES AND CHANGES IN
REVENUE SOURCES AND SO WE DO
THIS IS A GOOD OPPORTUNITY. TO
EVALUATE THE STATE'S OVERALL
STRATEGY IN THIS AREA-
INCLUDING YOU KNOW WHAT
POLICIES FUNDING SOURCES AND
PROGRAM SHOULD BE ADOPTED TO
ACHIEVE OUR SOMEBODY'S. TERM
GOALS ARE KNOW FREE EXAMPLE THE-
THE BEST MIX OF REGULATIONS
INCENTIVES. WILD WEATHER THE
CURRENT MIX OF PROGRAM
ACHIEVING CLIMATE FOR ALL GOALS
BECAUSE EFFECTIVE WHAT'S OUT
ABOUT AND A MOMENT. AND IT
DISTRIBUTES OF COSTS BENEFITS.
SO AS YOU KIND OF THE-
CONSIDERING THOSE. BIG PICTURE
QUESTION. WE WANTED TO RAISE A
FEW. FOR QUESTIONS OF THANK
ABOUT- FIRST IS- WHAT'S THE
BEST SOURCE OF FOR THE
INCENTIVE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
DOES WANT ADOPT WHAT'S THE BEST
SOURCE OF. I'M YOU CAN SEE ON
YOUR- ON TWELVE- THERE IS A-
I'M NOT GOING TO GO THROUGH
THAT TAPE AND BUT IT REALLY
DOES. I TRIED TO SOME- THAT THE
SENATE PROGRAMS THAT STATE HAS
NOT. TRYING TO ENTER WERE IN
MOBILE SOURCING. AND AREN'T YOU
CAN NEARLY TWO POINT AND FUN
FOR VARIETY OF THE PRO. AND IN
PARTICULAR YOU CAN SEE THERE'S
A SEVERAL DIFFERENT FUNDING TO
THAT ARE USED FOR THE PROGRAM.
INCLUDING AND TRADE BEEN A
CAPITA REVENUE. A RATE FUNDED-
MONEY TO COME WITH THE- LOW
CARBON FUELS. AS WELL AS THE
EIGHT- RELATED VEHICLE TO SO
THINKING ABOUT KIND OF WHAT'S
THE BUT BASS MIX OF FUNDING
SOURCES THESE PRO. I DO THINK
COMES TODAY EIGHT EXTENT
PROPOSED THAT THE RELATED FEES
ARE REASONABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR SOME OF THESE
PROGRAM- BECAUSE THERE IS A
NEXUS BETWEEN THAT SORT OF. IN
THAT ACTIVITIES THAT ARE BEING.
ABOUT ARE OTHER OF WHAT
CONTENTS. INCLUDING BUT THE
REAL BURDEN ON THANK OF THE- OF
THE YOUNG SORTS OF IMAGE
OPERATING FIFTY. BETWEEN HEAVY
DUTY AND LIGHT DUTY VEICLE-
INDEX SOME OF THOSE DAYS TO
INFLATION. AREN'T ANY STEP IN A
LITTLE BIT MORE IT'S JUST DON'T
MIX OF FUNDING THAT YOU- ONE
EXAMPLE I THINK ANY WHEN I LIE
AS THE USER I. O. U. WE HAVE
WHICH COULD HAVE. IMPACTS ON
BOTH ELECTRICITY CONSUMERS BUT
ALSO HAS IMPLICATIONS ARE
POTENTIALLY FOR THE STATE'S
GREENHOUSE GAS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS AS HI
ELECTRICITY RATES CAN PRESENT A
BARRIER TO. SWITCHING TO
ELECTRIFICATION OF VEHICLES
AND- I HAVE CLIENTS THAT SO
JUST KIND OF THINKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT WHAT IS THE BEST
MIX OF FUNDING SOURCES FOR
THESE PROGRAMS WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. SECOND WHICH PROGRAM
SHOULD BE FUNDED ONCE YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED WHICH- FUNDING
SOURCE YOU'D LIKE TO USE.
IDEALLY THIS DECISION WOULD BE
INFORMED BY- GOOD INFORMATION
ESTIMATES ABOUT THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THAT REDUCE MOBILE
SOURCE EMISSIONS- UNFORTUNATELY
THERE'S- AT THIS POINT- SOME OF
THAT INFORMATION IS A LITTLE
BIT LACKING WE HAVE GOTTEN.
SOME INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT TRIES TO
ESTIMATE THE COST EFFECTIVENESS
OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS IN THIS
AREA- I THINK THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE IS REALLY TRYING TO
KIND OF PUT THAT INFORMATION
TOGETHER IN A WAY THAT. ALLOWS
THE LEGISLATURE TO KIND OF
COMPARE ACROSS PROGRAMS- IT
HASN'T REALLY BEEN PRESENTED.
TO US IN THAT WAY YET AND SO
WE'RE WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO TRY
TO. GATHER AND ORGANIZE
INFORMATION THAT HELPS- ENOUGH
INFORM YOUR DECISIONS ABOUT
WHICH PROGRAMS ARE LIKELY TO
ACHIEVE A SIMILAR A QUALITY
CLIMATE GOALS MOST COST
EFFECTIVELY- IN THE ABSENCE OF
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION SOME
OF THE KEY CONSIDERATIONS WE
THANK OUR- WHEN THINKING ABOUT
WHERE TO ALLOCATE YOUR FUNDING
ARE. A LIGHT DUTY VERSUS HEAVY
DUTY- AND CUT YOU KNOW HOW TO
PRIORITIZE THOSE. OUT ONE I
THINK YOU DESERVE INFORMATION
LIKE IT'D BE A COAST- IN THE
MOBILE SOURCE WORLD TEND TO BE
A LARGER SOURCE OF- GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS WERE AS HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES. ARE A LARGER
SOURCE OF LOCAL AIR POLLUTANTS
AND SO SOME OF YOUR DECISIONS
AROUND PRIORITIZATION. MIGHT
DEPEND ON KIND OF HOW YOU
PRIORITIZE CLIMATE VERSUS AIR
QUALITY GOALS IN PART. ON
ANOTHER ISSUE IS JUST KIND OF
HOW YOU- BALANCE OF TRADE OFF
BETWEEN NEAR TERM AND LONG
TERM- INITIAL REDUCTIONS- YOU
KNOW- TO POINT AND KIND OF
EXISTING COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGIES. IS LIKELY TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS MORE COST
EFFECTIVELY IN THE NEAR TERM
BUT- I FUNDING PILOTS AND
DEMONSTRATIONS CAN CAN RELATE
FOR HERE YOUR LONG TERM
BENEFITS THAT YOU'RE PROMOTING
TECHNOLOGIES THAT THAT CAN BE
USED. TO ACHIEVE SOME OF THEIR-
MORE LONG TERM GOALS. AND THEN
I CAN THAT THE ONE OTHER ISSUE
THAT IS FOR. RELEVANT TO THIS
PROPOSAL AND THEY GOT PART. IS
HOW MUCH OF. ON IF THE GOAL IS-
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE AND FROM
ZERO VEHICLES HOW MUCH TO FOCUS
ON INCREASE. VERSUS VEHICLE
INCENTIVE AND SO. BASED ON OUR
REVIEW OF THE LETTER WE GET
THERE IS- IF THAT'S THE GOAL
THAT THERE'S AN ARGUMENT FOR
BOTH OF THOSE PIECES. OF
SUPPORT FOR BOTH INFRASTRUCTURE
AND- VEHICLE REBATES. ARE WE DO
THINK THAT THERE'S A STRONG
ARGUMENT THAT THERE'S LIMITED
FUNDING TO- GET SOME
PRIORITIZATION FOR.
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE'S SOME
RESEARCH THAT SUGGESTS YOU KNOW
IT'S AN ADDITIONAL DOLLAR FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE- COULD HAVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE BENEFIT THAN-
FOR VEHICLE REBATES HOWEVER.
THAT SAME RESEARCH ALSO SAYS
THAT BOTH ARE IMPORTANT AND
THERE'S THERE ARE COMPLEMENTARY
IN SOME WAYS AND SO TRYING TO
FIND THAT RIGHT BALANCE IT WILL
BE. ONE OF THE KEY ISSUES AND
CHALLENGES. FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
FINALLY OUT TRYING TO WRAP UP
MY- COMMENTS HERE I DO JUST
WANT TO MAKE A- VERY. MEANT OF
WE HAD SOME COMMENTS
RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND JUST
PROPOSAL TO. ACCELERATE SOME OF
THE CONTRACTS PROTECTION
FUNDING THROUGH THE ISSUE OF-
REVENUE BONDS AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION- JUST PICNIC SHE HAD
A BASIC- CONSIDERATION AND
TRADE OFF HERE IS WHETHER THAT.
NEAR TERM INCREASING FUNDING
THAT YOU WOULD GET CONNECTION
IN THE BOND IT'S WORTH- WHICH
WOULD BE UP TO A BILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE- THE
REDUCTION IN FUNDING IN AND OUT
YEARS AS MOST OF THE COIN
TRANSPORTATION MONEY WOULD BE
GOING TO. PAY OFF DEBT SERVICE
FROM THOSE BONDS AND SO- YOU
MIGHT WANT TO EXPLORE WHAT THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION SORT WHAT
THEIR EXPECTATIONS ARE ABOUT
LONG TERM FUNDING NEEDS AND HOW
THOSE MEN NEED TO BE IN THAT.
IF THIS PROPOSAL WERE TO BE TO
BE ADOPTED. AND THE FINAL
ISSUE- WHICH IS MAYBE A LITTLE
BIT MORE TECHNICAL BUT WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FROM A
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT IS THE
LEVEL OF. AUTHORITY PROVIDED TO
THE ADMINISTRATION- IN
PARTICULAR THE- ONE IT SHOWS
THE- LEVEL OF CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY FOR.
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM WE DO THINK IT'S
REASONABLE TO PROVIDE
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION
AUTHORITY FOR THE- THE PIECE OF
FUNDING THAT'S NEEDED TO PAY
THE DEBT SERVICE ON THE BONDS
AT THAT PROPOSAL IS ADOPTED.
HOWEVER WE DON'T. THINK THAT
NECESSARILY ALL OF THE
CONTRACTS PROTECTION FUNDING
WOULD NEED TO BE CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED IN ORDER TO DO
THAT- YEP AND PROVIDING SOME OF
THAT CONTINUOUS. APPROPRIATION
AUTHORITY WOULD HELP REDUCE THE
BORROWING COSTS BUT WE DON'T
THINK ALL THAT NEEDS TO. TO BE
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED. AND
CIRCLING AND LIMITING THAT TO
WHATEVER IS NEEDED WHAT HEALTH
INSURER I'M GOING LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OVER THE REST OF THE
MONEY THAT ISN'T. NEEDED TO PAY
OUT THE DEBT SERVICE ON THE
BONDS. SO HAPPY TO EXPLORE THAT
ISSUE WITH WITH YOU IN YOUR
STOP AND ANSWER QUESTIONS GOING
FORWARD- I WILL IN MY COMMENTS
THERE AND OF COURSE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY. ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER BROWN. OF DO
WE HAVE ANYONE FROM. OF FINANCE.
THAT ONE TO ADD. ME COMMENTS.
PUBLIC WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ADD AT THIS BUT- HERE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YEAH. OKAY
THANK YOU. OF SEE I'M DO ANY
MEMBERS HAVE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS MISS FRIEDMAN. THANK
YOU A FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO.
REALLY REALLY THANK GOVERNOR
NEWSMAN THE MINISTRATION FOR
THIS EXTREMELY BOLD ACTION THAT
THEY'RE TAKING TO. SERIOUSLY
INVEST IN A CLEAN CAR FUTURE-
IT IS. IT IS OF A VISIONARY
APPROACH AND ONE THAT IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO KNOW A
LOT OF THE- CLEAN ENERGY AND
SORT OF A- ENVIRONMENTAL
ACTIVISTS FOCUS A LOT ON OIL
PRODUCTION- HERE AND AROUND THE
WORLD BUT- YOU KNOW I WOULD
CONTEND THAT UNLESS WE- PUT
SERIOUS EFFORT INTO REDUCING
THE DEMAND. FOR FOSSIL FUELS-
THOSE EFFORTS ARE ARE GOING TO
FALL FLAT IF WE CONTINUE TO
PURCHASE AND USE A GASOLINE
POWERED AUTOMOBILE SO THIS IS A
HUGE HUGE. A STEP AND SOMETHING
THAT WILL REVERBERATE THROUGH
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY IF NOT THE
WORLD I WE KNOW THAT THAT
ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN A ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES ARE OUR
FUTURE AND THE CALIFORNIA IS
REALLY. I THINK A OF TAKING THE
LEAD IN A WORLDWIDE ON ON THIS
AND SO I'M REALLY PROUD TO SEE
THIS HAPPEN IN MY STATE AND BE
PART OF THE CONVERSATION. I
WOULD BE REMISS HOWEVER IF I
DIDN'T TAKE JUST A MINUTE TO
PUT A PLUG IN WELL I HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATION- HOPEFULLY ON
THE ON THE PHONE HERE AT LEAST
ONE OF THEM TO REMIND EVERYONE
THAT WHILE INVESTMENT IN CLEAN
VEHICLES IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND I'M THRILLED TO
SEE THE STAFF WE ALSO CAN'T
REMEMBER THAT GETTING PEOPLE.
OUT OF SINGLE OCCUPANCY
AUTOMOBILES ALSO HAS TO BE A
PRIORITY BECAUSE IT'S NOT
SUSTAINABLE TO FORCE EVERYBODY
IN OUR COMMUNITY ALWAYS TO
DRIVE EVERYWHERE IT HAS A HUGE
IMPACT ON OUR ABILITY TO USE
LAND SYSTEMICALLY ON OUR
ABILITY TO BUILD HOUSING. ON
TRAFFIC CONGESTION QUALITY OF
LIFE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
EVERYTHING ELSE IN WALLS OF
YOUR IMPORTANT THEY DON'T
ADDRESS ANY OF THOSE ISSUES SO
AT THE SAME TIME THAT WE INVEST
IN CLEAN CARS WE ALSO CAN'T
STOP INVESTING AND WE NEED TO.
INCREASE ARE INVESTING IN WELL
AS WELL IN MASS TRANSIT AND
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION AN ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION SO I. JUST WANT
TO PUT THAT OUT THERE THAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING. HOPE TO SEE IN
THE FUTURE EQUAL. OF
INVESTMENTS AND COMMITMENTS. TO
THOSE SORTS OF MODALITIES AND I
WOULD SAY FOR OUR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. THE BEST WAY THAT
WE CAN. SUPPORT THEM IS BY
GIVING THEM THOSE KINDS OF
MOBILITY OPTIONS. BECAUSE
WHETHER IT'S AS EVER GASOLINE
POWERED VEHICLE IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE TO MAINTAIN AN
AUTOMOBILE CALIFORNIA TO PAY
THE INSURANCE AND EVERYTHING
ELSE- AND FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE.
FORCED TO COMMUTE LONG
DISTANCES THE TIME THAT IT
TAKES TO DO THAT COMMUTE IS
ALSO A HUGE IMPACT ON PEOPLE'S
QUALITY OF LIFE SO- INVESTING
IN. DIFFERENT MOBILITY OPTIONS
THAT ARE. INEXPENSIVE AND
CONVENIENT MORE CONVENIENT FOR
PEOPLE SHOULD ALSO BE A HUGE
GOAL. I WITHOUT SAID I DO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS I'M NOT REALLY
SURE WHO THEY'RE FOR SO I'LL
JUST ASK THEM AND WHOEVER WANTS
TO TRY TO ANSWER FINE. A FIRST
UP WITH REGARD AND I APOLOGIZE
IF THESE WERE ANSWERED
SOMEWHERE IN THIS VERY LONG
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION THAT WAS
JUST GIVEN TO US- BUT IN
REGARDS TO THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OUTLINED ITS
PLAN TO SPEND THE FIRST FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. AT THE
PROPOSED FUND OF ONE BILLION IN
SECURITIZED REVENUE ONE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS WHAT IS THE PLAN TO
SPEND THE ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
WHAT KIND OF INVESTMENTS DOES
THE ADMINISTRATION WANT TO
PRIORITIZE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION- WELL AND I WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO MAP OUT HOW WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT BOTH. THE FULL
BILLION DOLLARS IN INVESTMENT
SO. THE FIRST FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED IN
ON THE NEAR TERM THE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE YEAH. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT AT
LEAST ONE POINT FIVE MILLION. I
SHOULD BE ABLE BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE WE I MEAN I. EVERY PERSON
FORGET TALK MORE ABOUT THIS BUT
I THINK YOU KNOW THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY THAT WE'RE GOING TO
EXCEED THAT TARGET WILL NEED.
MORE OF THAT INFRASTRUCTURE-
BUT WHAT WE ARE NOW FOR THE- AB
TWENTY ONE SEVEN THAT ANALYZE
WHAT THE MANTRA NEEDS TO MEET
TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY THIRTY.
GOALS AND WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS
THAT THERE'S A GAP SO WE NEED
ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
CHARGERS. AT ABOUT TWENTY ONE
ADDITIONAL HYDROGEN STATIONS TO
MEET OUR GOALS FOR TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. AND WE ARE PLAN IS
TO SPEND THAT FOR FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION FILLING THAT GAP. SO
BIG FOCUS ON- THREE MILLION ON
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN TWO
HUNDRED MILLION TO SKI MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY STATE. THAT'S A
PLACE WHERE- EITHER THE AIR
QUALITY IMPACTS ARE SO
PROFOUND. IN A COMMUNITIES BY
GOODMAN MOVEMENT CORRIDORS THAT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PRIORITIZING. THOSE INVESTMENTS
AS WELL. IF WE NEED A SECOND
FIVE MILLION FAR THINKING IS
THAT WOULD REALLY FOR. IN ON-
RAMPING UP TOWARDS OUR TWENTY
THIRTY TARGET. AND OUR BOARD
REALLY TO. THE MARKET. WE WANT
TO THE STRATEGIC INVESTMENTS ON
THE PUBLIC DOLLARS SITES. THAT
LEAD TO A BIG INFLUX OF PRIVATE
SECTOR. INVESTMENTS SO OUR GOAL
IS OVER TIME TO REDUCE THE
PUBLIC SHARE OF HER CHARGER.
INVESTMENTS AND GET TO A POINT
WHERE THE MARKET IS SELF
SUSTAINING. THANK YOU JUST TO
DRILL DOWN INTO THAT FOR A
SECOND SO THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR LIGHT DUTY
INFRASTRUCTURE- TO MEET THAT
GOAL OF THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CHARGERS. I'M
WONDERING IF YOU HAVE A
BREAKDOWN OF EXACTLY HOW MUCH
FUNDING YOU NEED TO CLOSE THAT
GAP. WELL OUR ASSESSMENT IS
THAT WE CAN CLOSE THE GAP WITH
THAT. THREE HUNDRED MILLION.
OKAY GREAT- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL HAS FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE MILLION FROM THE G. G. R.
AFTER ERA BEES. LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS AND UP
TO A BILLION FROM THE CDC'S
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE. I'M
WONDERING HOW YOU. MAXIMIZE
THOSE PROGRAMS SO THEY WORK
TOGETHER WELL. THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION ONCE I START AND- THE
FOLKS IN EVERY FOR SUPPORT THEY
WANT AND SALAS THE PREVIOUS
STEP AND- SO WE ARE- WE'RE THAT
WE ARE LOOKING AT THESE AS-
COMPLEMENTARY AND WHERE WE CAN
WE ARE PARTNERING DIRECTLY. SO
THAT FROM THE VIEWPOINT OF THE
GRANT GEE THEY DON'T ACTUALLY
IT'S- THEY DON'T SEE THAT
THERE'S TO BE CONFUSED I THINK-
I'M JUST APPLYING FOR A GRANT
THAT WE GIVE ME MY TRUCK AND
WOULD GIVE ME MY
INFRASTRUCTURE- SO WE'RE WE'RE-
INTENTIONALLY PARTNERING. ON
SPECIFIC- GRAHAM PROGRAMS. AND
THEN THERE ARE SOME PLANS WERE
JUST OTHER MAKE SENSE PARTNER
WHERE WE WILL HAVE INDIVIDUAL
INVESTMENTS HAPPENING YOU KNOW
JUST ON THE OTHER SIDE ARE TO
FUNNY. SIDE BUT OUR GOAL IS TO
MAKE THIS AS SEAMLESS AS
POSSIBLE. FOR THE GRANT SHE
COMMUNITY TO NOT FEEL LIKE-
THIS IS A CDC GRANT ALL THE
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS AS AN
AIR BE GRANT WITH ALL THESE
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS WE
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS. LIKE AS EASY AS
POSSIBLE. BOB FOR. FOR FOLKS TO
GET GRANTS ON. BOTH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE VEHICLE
SIDE. GREAT THAT'S GOOD TO KNOW
THAT- THAT YOU'VE ALREADY
THOUGHT ABOUT THIS IN THAT
YOU'RE- KIND OF BLENDING THIS
TOGETHER FOR THE END USER SO
THAT IS MORE SEAMLESS. I JUST A
FEW MORE QUESTIONS. SOME PEOPLE
COULD ARGUE THAT THE SMOG
ABATEMENT FEE IN THE VEHICLE
REGISTRATION FEES ARE
REGRESSIVE FEES. AND I'M
WONDERING HOW WE CAN ENSURE
THAT THE BENEFIT OF THE FEES
CAN BE SPENT TO BENEFIT LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS- YOU KNOW
WITH HAVING A CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED PROGRAMS FROM CAP
AND TRADE. LIMITS OUR ABILITY
IN THE LEGISLATURE TO REALLY DO
OVERSIGHT AND TO REFORM ANY OF
THE PROGRAMS. AND I'M
WONDERING- HOW. WE CAN. STILL
HAVE THAT OVERSIGHT AND STILL.
YOU KNOW ENSURE THAT THE
PROGRAMS ARE EFFICIENT THAT
THEY'RE EXACTLY WHAT WE WANT TO
BE WITHOUT THEM BEING
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED IF
THERE'S A WAY THAT WE CAN. KIND
OF MAKE THAT HAPPEN STILL. WELL
THE CAN APPROPRIATIONS SO WE
CAN FRONT LOAD- INVESTMENT IN
THEIR MISSION CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE- SO I YOU KNOW
THAT'S- IT JUST IMPORTANT FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO. SHOW THE
WORLD THAT WE ARE COMMITTED AND
THAT WE ARE. OVERCOMING WHAT I
WOULD ARGUE IS THE BIGGEST
BARRIER TO THE
COMMERCIALIZATION INTERMISSION
VEHICLES- AND- BUT THERE ARE
OVERSIGHT TOOL TO MAYBE I COULD
SPEND JUST A FEW MINUTES.
TALKING ABOUT WHAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS IN STATUTE- THE CLINTON
PROTECTION PROGRAM YOU KNOW HOW
TO PRETTY SPECIFIC.
REQUIREMENTS IN STATUTE ALREADY
EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT. AND ONE OF
THEM IS WE HAVE AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT'S VERY DIVERSE
WE PUBLISH ANNUAL INVESTMENT
PLANS AND WE GIVE THEM TO THE
LEGISLATURE IT AND- ABBOTT UP
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
LEGISLATURE ABOUT THOSE.
PRIORITIES ALSO- SEVERAL PIECE
OF LEGISLATION AND REFER TO
THEM AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. REQUIRES US TO DO AN
ASSESSMENT A CHARGER. NEEDS FOR
US THREE TWENTY THIRTY AND
RECTIFYING BEYOND TWENTY
THIRTY- AND THAT'S THAT'S
NUMBER TO THE EVERY TWO YEARS.
TO SET US UP ARE WE ON TRACK.
WHAT MISSING. AND GIVE US A NOT
TO FINE TUNE OUR- AND MAYBE.
YOU KNOW THEM AT AT WE FIND
MARKETS ARE TO EXCEL. OF THE
PRIVATE MARKET TO TAKE OVER-
THERE'S ALSO AT THE THOUSAND
WHICH REQUIRES US TO LOOK AT
EQUITY DISTRIBUTION CHARTER AND
WE'RE USING THAT THAT'S- OUR-
THE WERE WERE YOU. SOME OF THE-
OVERSIGHT THAT BUDGET. HAS
REQUIRED US TO DO. TO BE OF TO
REFER. AND RETOOL. AND IMPROVE
OUR OUR INVESTMENTS DO YOU
THINK THAT THAT IS ENOUGH-
OVERSIGHT TO. MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE BEING RESPONSIVE TO
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES. SO AS
THE CHARGING NEEDS CHANGE AS
THE VEHICLES CHANGE WILL THAT
GIVE THE ALLOW US TO BE NIMBLE
ENOUGH. TO ADJUST IF YOU KNOW
KIND OF THE BETAMAX OF THE
CHARGING YOU KNOW MOVES OVER
ATTACK. THE TAPE DECK OF THE
CHARGING OR- THE CD ROM OF THE
CHARGING. US SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO IT WE DON'T END UP
WITH OBSOLETE. INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE PAID FOR. TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. REPORTER NEEDS TWENTY.
KIDS YEAH UP AT SCHOOL ABILITY-
YOU KNOW WE ARE READ OUT TO
INDUSTRY WERE REALLY TRYING TO
MAKE SURE AND INDUSTRY ONCE
AGAIN NOBODY WANTS TRANSIT
INVESTMENTS HERE THIS IS BAD
FOR EVERYBODY- WE'RE NOT
FUNDING THE FULL COST OF THE
CHARGES TODAY. AND WE PLAN TO
FIND LESS AND LESS OVER TIME.
TO THE PRIVATE INDUSTRY HAS A
STAKE IN MAKING SURE THAT WE
GET THIS RIGHT. WE WILL.
DEFINITELY YOU KNOW AND YOU'RE
RIGHT THIS IS A VERY DYNAMIC
TIME AND YOU DON'T LOOK BACK
FIVE YEARS YOU THINK OH MY GOSH
I CAN'T BELIEVE HOW MUCH HAS
CHANGED IN JUST FIVE YEARS. AT
SOMEBODY'S IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SPACE FOR.
TWENTY FIVE MY GOSH. TWENTY
FOUR HERE I GOTTA SAY I. FEEL
LIKE I'VE NEVER BEEN YOU KNOW.
SO EXCITED BY THE POSSIBILITY
OF THEIR MISSION VEHICLE
TRANSPORTATION. AND NOW OUR BIG
HURDLE YOU KNOW WE'RE SEEING
THE VEHICLE. PRICES ARE COMING
DOWN THERE'S A LOT OF EVIDENCE
THAT IN THE NEXT TWO TO FIVE
YEARS EV'S WILL BE CHEAPER BUT
HIGH. NOT JUST OPERATE EARLY
CHEAPER OPERATE YOU COULD SAVE
YOU KNOW ELEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
YEAR. ON REDUCED- FUEL AND
MAINTENANCE COSTS BUT- CHEAPER
TO BUY SO NOW THE BIG-
INSTRUCTIONS IT IS A DYNAMIC
ENVIRONMENT I DO BELIEVE THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN
ANALYSIS- GETS A- GREAT A GREAT
TOOL TO BE ABLE TO TRACK
PROGRESS THE NATURE OF WORK
TAYLOR I'M BASS THAT'S- WHAT
THE MARKET. I THINK YOUR POINT
ABOUT PARTNERING WITH PRIVATE
INDUSTRY AND LETTING THEM HELP
TO DRIVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
DECISIONS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
ONE BECAUSE THEY WILL BE
INVESTING IN. THERE THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE A BETTER IDEA OF
WHAT'S NEXT. THEN WE WILL
CERTAINLY- ARE WE GONNA GET
EIGHT- DRAFT OF HOW THE
SECURITIZED FUNDS ARE GONNA BE
USED FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT WE WILL
BE PROVIDED. OKAY BACK. SIX ARE
YOU THINK ABOUT HOW MAYBE DO AT
THE PART ABOUT YOU HAVE A SENSE
OF I AM. I MEAN I CAN FIND ARE
YOU THINKING WHAT OF DETAIL
TERMS OF THE- USE OF THE FUNDS
OF YOU KNOW NOT GRAN BUT I
THINK BE GOOD TO AN UNDER. YOU
KNOW KIND OF WHAT PLANNING ON
DOING OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS
I'M JUST THAT OUT THERE THAT
THAT WOULD BE. THAT BE OF
INTEREST TO ME I INTO. TO MAYBE
TO THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU AND
THEN LASTLY I'M- WE'LL START
GOING. OF OUR TOPIC THAT. OKAY
GO BACK TO THE GOVERNOR. IN
JUST. EIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE GIVE YOU THE INFORMATION
THAT YOU NEED. AND THEN LASTLY
I'M JUST CIRCLE BACK TO WHAT I
SAID IN THE BEGINNING. WHICH IS
THAT I DO THINK THAT WE SHOULD
CENTER. THEIR ABILITY TO REDUCE
VMT THAT YOU KNOW THIS ALL IT I
DON'T WANT TO UNDERESTIMATE HOW
IMPORTANT. INVESTMENT IN THOSE
ABS IS AND IT'S HUGELY
IMPORTANT AGAIN I AM. YOU KNOW
I COMPLEMENT THE GOVERNOR IN IN
BEING A VISIONARY IN THIS AND
REALLY PUTTING. OUR MONEY
BEHIND THOSE GOALS I THINK THAT
THAT'S A HUGE. HUGE STEP THAT I
COULDN'T BE HAPPIER ABOUT. AND
AT THE SAME TIME WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO REDUCE VMT BECAUSE
THE- IMPACT. OF THESE LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLES- EVEN IF THERE'S
ABS IS STILL HUGE AND
UNACCEPTABLE AND A HUGE BURDEN
ON OUR COMMUNITIES- AND- DINNER
AND- INTERPRETING SAYS SO MANY.
OF OUR IMPORTANT GOALS BUILDING
HOUSING REDUCING CONGESTION
INCREASING HEALTH QUALITY OF
LIFE. ROAD SAFETY- SO. I HOPE
THAT YOU TAKE BACK. TO THE
GOVERNOR. YOU KNOW THAT WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO WE NEED TO UP
OUR INVESTMENTS IN TRANSIT. WE
NEED TO UP OUR INVESTMENTS IN.
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION- WE NEED
TO DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO DO NOT
FORGET THAT. BE IT THAT
REDUCING B. M. T. IS. STILL GOT
TO BE OUR OVERRIDING GOAL SO. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON THAT AT ALL. OR JUST
TAKE THAT BACK BUT I WOULD LOVE
TO MAYBE IF YOU CAN COMMENTED
HOW. THAT FITS IN WITH THOSE
THAT PROGRAM. ALL THE- FOLKS
FROM THE AREA FIRST OF. TO COME
ON THAT. MY THEIR- THEIR AREA.
JERRY I THINK IT'S MUCH SO MY
NAME TO NEVER ON THE OF THE
MALL SOURCE. AT THE RESOURCE
BOARD- SO APPS. EVERYTHING
YOU'RE SAYING WITH RESPECT TO
BE IN RHETORIC IN ABILITY SOME
POINT FOR COMMUNITIES- I WILL
FLAG AND I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE
OF SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE WHICH
CARP HELPS OVERSEE TO HELP
BRING CLOSER THAT CONNECTION
BETWEEN TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AND HOUSING. THAT'S DONE AT THE
MPO LEVEL BUT THERE'S ALSO SOME
PIECES OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET THAT I THINK IT
MIGHT BE PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED AND JUST KIND OF
CARING HEARING WHERE YOU'RE
INTERESTED READERS ARE. SO WITH
RESPECT TO THE EQUITY PROGRAM
CUTS THAT ARE PROPOSED TO BE
FOUNDED ON UNDER THE EQUITY
THAN- AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- I WILL FLAG THAT AND
THAT EQUITY BEEN DOES INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE- CAR SCRAP REPLACE
PROGRAMS BUT ALSO INCLUDES
OTHER EQUITY PROJECTS LIKE CAR
SHARING ANOTHER MOBILITY
OPTIONS TO HELP DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. GET ACCESS TO ZERO
EMISSION MOBILITY NOT
NECESSARILY IN THE FORM OF AN
INDIVIDUALLY OWNED VEHICLE BUT
IN OTHER FORMS AS WELL ALSO ADD
THAT OUR HEAVY DUTY PROGRAMS
ALSO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR ZERO
EMISSION TRANSIT BUSES- AND SO
THAT WOULD BE HOUSED. UNDER
THAT HEAVY DUTY. THANKS I THINK
THAT WHAT WE HAPP OVER TE LAST
FEW YEARS WITH. THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR EMISSIONS
AND KEEP CONTINUING TO
INCREASE. SHOWS THAT THERE ARE
WEAKNESSES IN SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE THAT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
SOMETHING THAT I'M WORKING ON A
NEW OTHERS ARE AS WELL. AND WE
NEED TO REALLY FOCUS ON A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN FOR MASS
TRANSIT. FOR LOOKING AT NOT
JUST HOUSING OR TRANSPORTATION
BUT- FINDING WAYS TO GET GIVE
PEOPLE EVERYTHING THEY NEED TO
LIVE WITHIN WALKABLE AND
BIKEABLE DISTANCE REALLY.
THINKING AGAIN ABOUT HOW WE
MOVE AROUND OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND WE NEED TO PUT THE FUNDING
BEHIND THOSE GOALS. DESERVE BUT
WORK IS CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT M.
AS A LOT OF OTHER WORK TO DO
BECAUSE WHAT THE PATH RIGHT NOW
IS NOT SUSTAINABLE EVEN IF
EVERY CARD TOMORROW TURNED HIS
ABS. IT'S STILL NOT A
SUSTAINABLE- PATH SO I'LL DO
I'LL JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT AND
THANKS AGAIN FOR YOUR WORK AND-
THANKS FOR ANSWERING ALL MY
QUESTIONS. I THANK YOU MS RIVAS
FOR FILLING IN FOR ME WE HAVE-
MISTER SMITH FOLLOWED BY A
MISTER BENNETT AND THEN THE
THREE OF US IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU MIGHT ONE OF MY BIGGEST
CONCERNS IS ONE OF THE
EXTENSION OF THE TAX THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE SUNSET IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AND EXTENDING IT
TO TWENTY TWENTY FOUR OR TWENTY
FORTY SIX. BUT MY CONCERN IS IN
A RURAL COMMUNITY THAT I
REPRESENT. WE MIGHT NOT BE ABLE
TO HAVE A CHARGING STATION ON
EVERY CORNER HOW LONG IT TAKES
TO CHARGE. SO HOW ARE THEY
GOING TO BE DISTRIBUTED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE ONE OF MY
FIRST QUESTIONS. THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND- I REFERENCE OF
STUDY THAT WE HAD DONE SB ONE
THOUSAND THAT LOOK AT THE
EQUITY IMPLICATIONS OF OUR
CHARGER DISTRIBUTION AS YOU
KNOW WE DID FIND THAT WE NEED
TO DO A BETTER JOB. IN RURAL
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND GETTING MORE CHARGER
ACCESS- I REFER TO MY IN MY
OPENING PRESENTATION TO THE
FORD F. ONE FIFTY THAT'S GOING
TO BE COMING OUT IN THE LECTURE
VERSION AND- THIS IS WHERE YOU
KNOW AT. AT LEAST MORE WE SEE
MORE DIVERSE THAT THE VEHICLES
IN THE ELECTRIC. SPACE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE OKAY.
CAN GET ACCESS TO THOSE
VEHICLES AND CAN AND CAN.
CONVENIENTLY REVEALED. SO I
THINK GOING FORWARD IT'S GOING
TO BE. EVER MORE IMPORTANT THAT
IN- OF WORLD COMMUNITIES. IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY THAT WE MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUIT THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY. DO YOU
HAVE A MAP OF CALIFORNIA WHERE
THEIR SUGGESTION TO GO AND
CURRENTLY. THAT I COULD GET.
YES WE CAN SHARE THE SB ONE
THOUSAND REPORT WITH YOU WHICH
HAS STAYED ON THE GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRIBUTION. AND WHAT IS THE
ERROR MESSAGE THAT A MESSAGE
LEFT ESTIMATED AMOUNT OF
FUNDING NEEDED TO ACHIEVE THE
GOVERNOR'S ZERO ELECTRIC
VEHICLE GOALS. HAPPY TO THIRD-
RESPOND ALTHOUGH I THINK THE
CARBON OF FINANCE MAY BE BETTER
SUITED. BUT I THINK ANYBODY CAN
DEPARTMENT FINAL STRIKE THE
FOR. YOU KNOW I THINK THIS
MARTIN ROGAN FROM FINANCE- THE-
YEAH I THINK THAT THE
COMMISSIONERS RT TALKED ABOUT
BOTH THE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
GOALS IN THE TWENTY THIRTY
GOALS. AND THAT THAT- WHAT WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING IS TO- BY
EXTENDING THE REVENUES AND-
BODY AGAINST THEM- THREE
BILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS THOSE
GOALS- WHICH IS- A MINUTE I
THANK GOD. THE APPROACH THAT
THE COMMISSIONER AND ENERGY
COMMISSION CAN AND COULD TALK A
LITTLE MORE ABOUT HOW THEY GET
THERE BUT I THINK WE'VE ALREADY
TALKED THROUGH ABOUT HOW THIS
GETSAS MOST OF THE WAY THERE
BUT- BUT THIS IS- THIS IS THIS
IS PART OF THE WAY IN THE
OTHER. THE OTHER ASPECT OF THIS
IS THE PARTNERING WITH INDUSTRY
AND THEN PARTNERING WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR- TO ALSO PROVIDE
THE FUNDING THAT HELPS US MAKE
MEET THOSE TARGETS FOR WE'RE
NOT SURE WHAT THE FUNDING. IS
GOING TO BE IN THE FUTURE AND
HOW MUCH IS GOING TO COST THE
TAXPAYERS A CALIFORNIA. WHAT WE
KNOW THE WORK THAT. MISSION
EXTEND QUESTION. WE KNOW THE
WORK OUR PROPOSAL IS TO- TO
PROVIDE A THIRTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN BONDS- AND I. TAKE
THE ESTIMATE- THE ESTIMATED
COST OF THAT IS AROUND THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS- OVER THE LIFE OF THE
BONDS. HAVE ANOTHER FOLLOW UP
QUESTION IN REGARD TO THE
BONDS. IF THE DISTRICT
SECURITISATION PIECE OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS FOR ONE BILLION IN
BONDS. OVER THIRTY YEARS WHAT'S
THE DEBT SERVICE GOING TO BE ON
THOSE BONDS. THAT WOULD BE THE
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION.
AND THAT THAT THAT THE
STUDENTS- ASSUMES THAT WE GET
THE CONTINUES PREPARATION TO
MAKE SURE WE PAY THATBECAUSE
THAT- THE THREE FIFTY MILLION
IS ASSOCIATED WITH CERTAIN-
RESEARCH CERTAIN MEASUREMENT OF
RISK IN THE BOND INDUSTRY. AND-
SHOWS THAT- COULD USE
PREPARATION HELPS BRING THAT
AMOUNT DOWN TO THE THREE FIFTY
LEVEL. THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR OF THIRTY YEARS OF
A ONE BILLION DOLLAR BOND IS.
YES CORRECT. THAT'S ALL. THANK
YOU MISTER BENNETT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF. CHERVIL MY
OVERALL QUESTIONS DEAL WITH
OVERSIGHT THAT THIS IS A THE
MASSIVE PROGRAM AND THE THERE
ARE MANY ASPECTS AND GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF TIME WE HAVE HERE
DURING THIS HEARING I A- WE'LL
JUST FOCUS ON THIS ONE ASPECT
OF IT OVERALL- HAS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REV FRIEDMAN JUST
POINTED OUT THIS IS AN EXCITING
EFFORT- AND ONE THAT- CERTAINLY
I THINK CITIZENS TO CALIFORNIA
REALLY WELCOME. I WOULD LIKE TO
CONTRAST TO SERVE PROGRAM AND
THE CONTINUOUS FUNDING ASPECTS
OF IT WITH THE- CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM THAT'S OUT THERE AS WE
LOOK AT THIS FROM OVERSIGHT. I
THINK OVERALL THE LEGISLATURE'S
EXPRESSING GROWING INTEREST IN
MAKING SURE WE ACT EXERCISE
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AND SO MY CONCERN
WAS THE CONTINUOUS FUNDING
ASPECT OF THIS IS IT
SIGNIFICANTLY DECREASES. OF THE
ABILITY OF THE LEGISLATURE- TO
EXERCISE ITS OVERSIGHT
FUNCTION- WITH- THIS PROGRAM
NOW I'VE REALIZED THAT THERE'S
LESS OF AN ISSUE HERE BECAUSE
IF YOU TAKE THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM- THERE IS AN INHERENT
TO PUSH- BY SIGNIFICANT FORCES
TO NOT. HAVE THE ALLOWANCES BE
REDUCED TO- TO SORT OF TAKE
ACTUALLY TO HAVE MORE LOUNGES
OUT THERE WHEREAS WITH THIS
PROGRAM I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
FIND INDUSTRIES GOING TO BE
ENCOURAGING US TO. TO MAKE THE
INVESTMENTS BUT THERE STILL IS
A NEED I THINK WE'VE SEEN AFTER
SO MANY OTHER ISSUES- THERE
STILL IS A NEED FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE APPROPRIATE
OVERSIGHT HERE- BECAUSE WE'VE
SEEN WITH OTHER PROGRAMS. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS WE DON'T
WANT TO HAVE- YOU KNOW
SOMETHING SOMETHING SHOW UP AND
FIND THAT THERE IS A
INAPPROPRIATE INFLUENCED BY
SOME PEOPLE BECAUSE THESE ARE-
WORK WE'RE GOING TO. BE
PARTNERING WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR- TO DECIDE THESE
INVESTMENT LOCATIONS X.
SENTARA- SO I'M INTERESTED IN
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THE
LEGISLATURE KEEPS APPROPRIATE
OVERSIGHT- OF THE FINANCIAL
SIDE OF THIS AND USES THE
INCENTIVE OF THAT OVERSIGHT TO
MAKE SURE THE PROGRAM IS
IMPLEMENTED- APPROPRIATELY- SO
AS WE- AS WE HEARD THIS IS A
DYNAMIC AREA THINGS ARE
CHANGING- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION- X. AND-
OF FUNDS THAT ARE. WAY THAT
DISK- WITH THE LEGISLATURE'S
VIEW IN TERMS OF THE SAME
CHANGING SO MY QUESTION- AFTER
SAYING ALL THIS IS- COULD YOU
IDENTIFY- AND COME BACK COULD
DO MINISTRATION COME BACK WITH-
A BREAK DOWN THE L. A. O. IS
SUGGESTING. OF BREAKING THIS
INTO A FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR- INVESTMENT AND THEN A
SECOND FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT- SO THAT WE
HAVE LESS INTEREST COST UP
FRONT BUT ALSO GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. TO CHECK IT TOO
TO RE EXAMINE THE PROGRAM WERE
GOING HOW THE FUNDS ARE BEING
EXPANDED I WOULD LIKE TO SEE AN
ADVANTAGE AND DISADVANTAGE SORT
OF SHE- AS I KNOW THERE ARE
SOME DISADVANTAGES OF THAT AND
BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME ADVANTAGES TO THAT- THAT
WOULD BE. HELPFUL FOR ME I
WOULD ALSO BE. BENEFIT FROM
UNDERSTANDING MORE HOW THE
PARTNERSHIPS WILL GO IN TERMS
OF THE EKITI PARTNERSHIPS WITH
PRIVATE INDUSTRY. FOR THE ISSUE
THESE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS TO WHAT EXTENT
WILL- THE PUBLIC'S TAXPAYER
DOLLARS ACTUALLY- CREATE A- UP
A PUBLIC BENEFIT THAT'S NOT
JUST GOING O BE SOMETHING THAT
WHOEVER WE PARTNER WITH FOR THE
PRIVATE- INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT. DAY GAME- BUT WE
HAVE SOME OTHER REQUIREMENTS IN
THERE I DON'T UNDERSTAND YOU
KNOW WILL ELECTRICITY RATES
SHOULD BE- SUBSIDIZED IN ANYWAY
FOR EXAMPLE FOR LOW INCOME
PEOPLE. I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
THAT INFORMATION IF IT'S
POSSIBLE AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THE FINAL THING I WOULD JUST
OFFER I'D LIKE YOU TO-
CONSIDER. IS THAT THE MIX
BETWEEN. WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT
ARE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
COULD SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGE OVER
THE NEXT TEN YEARS. AND TO
CERTAINLY ELECTRICITY IS GOING
TO BE A BIG PART OF IT BUT
WHAT'S THE PROPER MIX BETWEEN
HYDROGEN. AND ELECTRIC VEHICLES
ARE IS HYDROGEN ONLY GOING TO
BE- FOR HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES- IS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN
THAT'S LIKE TO UNDERSTAND WHERE
THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOW. IN
WHAT KIND OF- HOW NIMBLE THE
ADMINISTRATION THINKS WE NEED
TO BE FOR ADJUSTMENTS IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL ARE. THE THIRD STATUS SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS YOU REYES AND
THEN IF I MISSED SOMETHING
PLEASE LET ME KNOW- SO I THINK
YOU KNOW ON THE- ON THE NEXT
BETWEEN- WHAT THAT VEHICLE.
FLEET COULD LOOK LIKE GOING
FORWARD I MEAN THERE ARE CLEAR
SIGNAL. GLOBALLY THAT
INVESTMENT IN BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES IS THAT IS OCCURRING
AND IT'S RAPID. BATTERY PRICES
ARE HAVE GOT 90% OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS AND THEIR- YOU KNOW
THIS IS HAPPENING NOT JUST IN
THE U. S. BUT IN CHINA AND EACH
YEAR IN INDIA. SO THIS IS I
THINK A STOPPABLE AT THIS POINT
IN TERMS OF. THAT KIND OF
WRITING ON THE WALL THAT. AT
LEAST ON THE BATTERY FIVE OR
MAKING A LOT OF PROGRESS ON THE
FINANCIAL SIDE I HAVE A LONG
CLOAK. ESPECIALLY IN THE MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY SPACE. WHERE I
DON'T THINK BATTERIES- CAN MEET
ALL THE NEEDS AND THE DUTY
CYCLE. OF THE FACTORY FEELING
OF HYDROGEN THERE THERE'S JUST
A LOT OF BENEFITS IT'S NOT TIME
SENSITIVE INJURED I THINK.
THERE'S SOME SOME REAL
BENEFITS- ON ON HYDROGEN SIDE
AND IS THIS THE SPECIALLY I
THINK IT'S AN ISSUE ON THE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY FIVE.
AGAIN WE'RE STARTING INCREASED
INVESTMENT WERE NOTICING IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE INVESTMENTS
THAT WE'RE MAKING ON THE
FIELDING SIDE. THAT- THAT THE
PUBLIC SHARE IS DECREASING AND
THE PRIVATE SHARE IS INCREASING
INCRETIN FACTOR EVEN SEEING
SOME HYDROGEN STATIONS BEING
FULLY- FUNDED BY THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. SO THERE'S GOOD SIGNS
ON THE HYDROGEN AND FUEL CELL
SIDE AS WELL- WHAT THE NEXT
WILL BE YOU KNOW. WE DO
INDETERMINABLE. WE DO NEED TO
LIKE. ACT TO BE ABOUT. FOR
WHERE MARKET. AND WHAT ARE
INVEST IS EASY TO SUPPORT THAT
GROWING MARKET. YEAH ARE YOU
FOR. GOING BIG NOW. IS THAT.
THEIR MISSION VEHICLE IMPISH IF
A BARRIER TO BE. A TO BUY-
ANOTHER TO SEE IF. AND WHEN I
SAY ELECTRIC IF YOU THE BATTERY
OR FUEL CELL AFTER THEY'RE BOTH
UP FOR THE TECH. AND SO
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE USING THE
ANALYTICAL. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS US THE ISSUE
HAS- IT'S OF THE VALUE. EVERY
OTHER YEAR WHERE'S THE MARKET-
GOING IN TERMS OF- YOU KNOW OUR
OUR- OUR THEIR MISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND REALLY.
RETOOLING ARE INVESTMENTS.
BASED ON THAT INFORMATION- ON
THE YOU KNOW THE PROPOSAL THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS MADE REALLY
FOR IN A EQUITY WHICH IS A I
REALLY TO ONE EMPHASIZE YOUR
TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW LIKE
RATES LOW INCOME PEOPLE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THANK CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE HALF OF PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA BRENT. 30% WITHIN
MULTI FAMILY DWELLINGS IT'S NOT
CONVENIENT TO BY INTERMISSION
VEHICLE YOU'RE AFRAID YOU YOU
CAN'T DO IT AND YOU CAN'T
REFILL YOUR VEHICLE- THE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS FROM HAVING
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE LARGE
BILL SO YOU KNOW TERM OR
BETWEEN ELEVEN TO ELEVEN
HUNDRED TO SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER YEAR ARE THE
SAVINGS FROM REDUCED FUEL COSTS
WHAT COULD BE CHEAPER THAN
GASOLINE. AND REDUCE
MAINTENANCE COSTS SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT LOW INCOME
FAMILIES CAN BENEFIT FROM THE
LOWER LIFE CYCLE CSTS THE
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLE AND TO
DO THAT WE NEED INFRASTRUCTURE
WE KNOW A LOT OF INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WE NEED IT NOW SO THERE'S
THIS. THAT'S THE REASON WE'RE
GOING BIG WITH THIS BILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL IT'S SO THAT WE
CAN OVERCOME THIS MAJOR
BARRIERS TO DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY BENEFITS. AND
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE A LOW
INCOME FAMILY. IF I COULD FOR
UP UP WITH A HI LIZ CAREFULLY-
TWO YEAR AND- EARLIER- FROM OF
TO THE FROM SAN MEMBER FOR. A
SORT OF OVER. AND IT AND THE AS
A LIST DOLLARS THEY THEY WERE
ALL WERE PRO. AND THEY WERE ALL-
HEALTHY- OVERSIGHT ACTIVE. BUT
I FELT A LITTLE BIT LIKE WHEN I
LISTEN TO SOME A. R. B. THINGS
THERE THERE WAS A REPORT A. R.
B. HAD TO GIVE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THEY AND THEY
DID GIVE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE BUT WHEN THE
REPORTS SAID THEY WEREN'T GOING
TO BE MAKING ANY MODIFICATIONS
IT WAS LIKE EVERYTHING FELL
FLAT BECAUSE- OF THEY WERE
GOING TO BE CHANGING HOW THEY
WERE OPERATING SO WHILE THOSE
ARE. CERTAINLY APPROPRIATE I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO HAVE THAT SENSE OF- HEY WE
WANT TO WE WANT TO HAVE A VOICE
IN MODIFYING OR CHANGING THIS
PROGRAM AS IT GOES FORWARD SO-
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE- THAT
YOU HAVE SOME AND HOPE THAT WE
COULD FIND SOME WAYS TO HAVE
MORE. AND MORE APPROPRIATE ONES
AS WE GO FORWARD. THE AS YOU
ALSO MENTIONED ABOUT- YOU KNOW
THE MIX AND THE CHARGING I WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT. ONE OF MY
CONCERNS HERE IS IT TAKES
THIRTY MINUTES RIGHT NOW IN
TERMS OF THE CHARGING- YOU
COULD HAVE THAT'S THIRTY
MINUTES A IN TERMS OF TRAVEL
TIME. TO WAIT. BUT IF YOU PULL
INTO A PLACE AND THERE ARE
ALREADY OTHER PEOPLE THAT'S
THIRTY MINUTES AFTER YOU GET
PLUGGED IN AND- SO I THINK WE
HAVE A HUGE. WE HAVE A HUGE
HURDLE TO OVERCOME TO HAVE
PEOPLE FEEL CONFIDENT THAT-
ELECTRIC VEHICLES- BY
THEMSELVES. ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE
CHARGING FAST ENOUGH AND SO I
HOPE WE REALLY SHOULD PAY A LOT
OF ATTENTION TO. HOW DO WE
HANDLE MULTIPLE AUTOMOBILES
PULLING INTO A CHARGING AREA
AND ALL HOPING TO GET CHARGE
QUICKLY AND BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
ON THEIR JOURNEY. SO WE CAN
WORK ON THAT AND CERTAINLY
HYBRID IS ONE OF THE WAYS THAT-
WE CAN HAVE THAT AT CEMEX THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I AM LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES I AM PLEASED TO SEE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
COMMITTING- TO DECREASE
EMISSIONS FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR OF AS A
JOINT AUTHORS OF AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE LED BY SSEMBLY
MEMBER RAY YES- I WANT TO
DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
RELATED TO. OF THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM I THINK
THIS PROGRAM HAS TREMENDOUS
VALUE AND I HOPE WERE ABLE TO
HAVE- A DISCUSSION ON UPDATES
TO THIS PROGRAM OF YEAH I THINK
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS IN
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY POLLUTION- SO THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE ARE. THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WOULD
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATE ABA
REVENUE BUT IT DOESN'T CONTAIN
ANY PROGRAM CHANGES TO THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM IS
THE ADMINISTRATION OPEN TO
CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM. WHAT
RIGHT NOW THE PROGRAM FOCUSES
ON DIVERSIFYING OUR-
TRANSPORTATION FUELS BEYONCE
SIX BILLION AND- THAT YOU KNOW
THE LANGUAGE IS VERY SPECIFIC
IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW WE CAN'T
PICK WINNERS AND WE NEED TO
FIND THE DIVERSITY OF DIFFERENT
ALTERNATIVES TO PETROLEUM WHAT
WE'VE TRIED TO DO THROUGH OUR
ANNUAL INVESTMENTS AND WITH
OUR- ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT WE
RECENTLY REFRESHED ACTUALLY TO
HAVE A GREATER FOCUS ON EQUITY
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION NOT CONCERNED- WE
YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING
MORE IN A IN RECENT YEARS ON
HERE MISSION MOBILITY- SO I YOU
KNOW I LEAVE IT TO THE
LEGISLATURE REALLY TO DECIDE
WHAT WHAT LANGUAGE IS
APPROPRIATE IF ANYTHING RIGHT
NOW WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR A
STRICT- EXTENSION OF THE
DEADLINE. OKAY I'M IS THE PLAN
TO MAKE THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
EXCLUSIVELY AS ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM.
SO WHAT WHAT WE FIND IS IT
THROUGH THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM IS NOT
JUST THEIR MISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT ALSO. FUEL
PRODUCTION WILL PARTNERSHIP
PRODUCTION WE FIND- SOME
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT WE
PROVIDE WE HAVE IN THE PAST
PROVIDED LOANS FOR MANUFACTURED
NOT LONG BUT START GRANTS FOR
MANUFACTURED EUROVISION VEHICLE
THAT FACTORED IN THE STATE SO-
WE FIND A VARIETY OF OTHER.
INVESTMENTS RELATED TO FUEL
PRODUCTION AND- TO THEIR
MISSION GICLEE ENACTED SENSE
INFRASTRUCTURE FADHLI- WE HAVE
OVER TIME BECOME MUCH MORE
FOCUSED JUST ON THE- IF YOU'LL
FIND. BILLION WITH THAT
PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE WITH THE
RESOURCES BOARD DAY FUND
VEHICLES WE FIND THAT FUELS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO WHILE
HISTORICALLY WE DID TO OUR
FUNDING IN VEHICLES WE WITH
WITH ZERO THOSE OUT THAT FOR US
THAT THERE'S NO MORE CLEAR
BETWEEN WALLS OF WHAT THE ERROR
HE DOES WHAT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION DOT. OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- I HAVE A COUPLE AND
THEN I THINK CHARACTER- SOME
QUESTIONS TO ASK- I THINK IT'S
A NOTEWORTHY IN THE PROPOSED
THAT- IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY- THERE WAS
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN- A CV R. P.
FUNDING FOR LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES
AND THEIR REBATES AND THERE'S-
A ZERO IN THIS BUDGET- AS- OF.
IS THAT- THE INTENTION TO-
SIMPLY AND THIS PROGRAM OR IS
THERE A REPLACEMENT PROGRAM
THAT'S BEING CONSIDERED. HI
LIZZY YOU'RE A PART OF THANK
YOU SO MUCH I'VE FOR THE BEST
AND WE DO KNOW THAT- THEY
MINISTRATION KNOWLEDGES THAT
THE SENIOR P. PROGRAM HAS
HELPED SUPPORT CONSUMERS
PURCHASE OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES BUT THERE ARE ALSO. SO
EXISTING PROGRAMS IN PLACE THAT
PROVIDE REBATES FOR PASSENGERS
ADS ON AS YOUR WHERE TO SPEND
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE AGENDA OF
THE CLEAN FILLER WORDS PROGRAM
PROVIDES A FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLAR AND ON AND ON THE
VEHICLE AND INCENTIVES. AND WE
ARE ALSO FIRST COMMITTED TO RE
EVALUATING AS WE DO EVERY YEAR
THE EXPENDITURE PLAN. FOR CAP
AND TRADE FOR ME REPRESENT. I
SORRY I DIDN'T THAT LAST PART.
CERTAINLY AND AS HAS BEEN OUR
PREVIOUS PRACTICE WE WILL
EVALUATE IT CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURES ENDS WITH MORNING
FOR ME SHANE WOULD BE VERY
OPTION PROCEEDS IT'S AND WILL
BE BRING FORTH AND UPDATED CAP
AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN MAY
REVISION I SEE- SO YOU ARE-
OPEN TO CONSIDERING FUNDING CVR
P. BUT- POTENTIALLY. THROUGH
CAP AND TRADE. I CAN'T COMMENT
ON SPECIFICS AT THIS TIME OF
WHAT WE MAY BE OPEN TO BACK WE
WILL BE REVISITING AFTER. WELL
OKAY THAT LEAVES ME THINKING
THAT- MAYBE THIS IS JUST AN
EFFORT TO PERMANENTLY TERMINATE
THE- PROGRAM AND I'D APPRECIATE
SOME CLARITY ON THAT- AS- YOU
YOURSELF JUST SAID IT'S A- VERY
POPULAR PROGRAM- AND- AS YOUR
ANSWERING BECAUSE- THAT
QUESTION PERHAPS YOU CAN- LET
ME KNOW IF YOU FOR A- HOW IT.
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION THE
VIEWPOINT OF MANUFACTURERS WHO
ARE CHARGED WITH SELLING THESE
VEHICLES WE WANT THEM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN SELLING AND
LEASING- ZEV VEHICLES WHAT IS
THEIR PERSPECTIVE AS IT'S BEEN
EXPRESSED TO YOU. THAT SORRY
I'M NOT SURE I CAN SPEAK TO
THAT QUESTION PERHAPS MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD MEDIA OF MY TIME IS
GENERAL FOR WHOEVER CAN ANSWER.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF
THE NEIGHBOR JUST AGAIN FROM
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
YES YOU'RE CERTAINLY CORRECT-
THAT HISTORICALLY CTRP HAS
PLAYED AN IMPORTANT ROLE AS A
COMPLEMENT TO OUR REGULATIONS
WHICH- REQUIRE MANUFACTURERS TO
BRING ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES TO
MARKET. US EASIER P. AND OTHER
VEHICLES THAT ARE PROGRAMS THAT
HELPS THEN ON THE CONSUMER SIDE
HELPING TO FACILITATE AND- AND
HELP CONSUMERS MAKE THAT CHOICE.
M. DOUG OF THE MANUFACTURERS
ARE HARDLY ON THE SIDELINES ON
THIS BECAUSE WE ARE REQUIRING
THEM TO UP A PROVIDE THESE
VEHICLES. HAVE YOU CONSULTED
WITH THE INDUSTRY AND WHAT IS
THEIR PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT
APPEARS TO BE AN EFFORT TO
TERMINATE THE CVR P. PROGRAM.
I'M SURE HEARING- VERY SIMILAR
THINGS TO YOU ARE OF COURSE- I
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET-
BUT OF COURSE WE DO HEAR FROM
MANUFACTURERS OF BOTH THE LIGHT
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY SPACE. OF
COURSE THAT THAT INCENTIVES
PLAYED IMPORTANT ROLES A
COMPLIMENT TO GET EARLY
REDUCTIONS TO MEET OUR
REGULATIONS SO WHILE WHILE I
HAVE YOU- I THINK A OR B. AS
THE RIGHT. TO AGENCY TO ANSWER
THIS QUESTION- WE HAVE TO.
MAJOR FUELING SOURCES FOR THE
VEHICLES WE HAVE A LECTURE
VEHICLES WITH HYDROGEN-
HYDROGEN BY COMPARISON TO. A
LECTURE GOOD OF VEHICLES IS
STILL AN INDUSTRY THAT'S IN ITS
INFANCY AND THE TECHNOLOGY IS
MOVING FORWARD- AND IN SOME
WAYS DRAMATICALLY BUT BUT- I
THINK STILL SOMEWHAT BEHIND IN
TERMS OF ITS MATURATION COMPARE
TO- OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES- WE'VE
PROVIDED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
INCENTIVES AND BENEFITS AND-
FUNDING. FOR THE ELECTRIC SIDE
BUT COMPARATIVELY I'M NOT
SAYING IT'S A SMALL AMOUNT OF
MONEY BUT COMPARATIVELY LITTLE-
FOR HYDROGEN AND I NOTE IN- OF
THE PROPOSED BUDGET- IT SEEMS
TO BE A MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT
TO IN TERMS OF. OF THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT IS BUDGET-
FUELING CUT HYDROGEN FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE- IS IN A PLACE
WHERE IT NEEDS TO CATCH UP JUST
LIKE WITH- OF LECTURE CUT. A
FUELING STATIONS WE NEED- MORE
UBIQUITOUS SET UP FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR HYDROGEN AND
THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF WORK
BEING DONE TO- ADVANCED
HYDROGEN SO THAT IT IS IN FACT
A- THE- THE HYDROGEN ITSELF IS
SUSTAINABLY PRODUCED- SO WHY
THESE ARE THE TWO MAJOR
BARRIERS I THINK- IN TERMS OF
MOVING THAT TECHNOLOGY FORWARD
WHY IS THERE NO INCREASE- THIS
YEAR- IN- THE HYDROGEN SECTOR-
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE COMPARE IT
TO WHAT IS PROPOSED. FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ILET ME- I WOULD
RESPOND TO THAT QUESTION A
CHARGER. SO THE EVERY PERSON
BOARD AT ITS MORE ON THE
VEHICLES WERE MORE THAT IN AND
SITE SO LET ME TO TALK ABOUT
SOME OF THE- WAYS WERE.
HYDROGEN RIGHT NOW. THE AB
EIGHT REQUIRE US START- YOU
KNOW THAN TWENTY. OF THE FUNDS
TOWARDS A PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE UP TO
HUNDRED STATIONS ARE WE'RE
ACTUALLY IN OUR- OUR OUR PLAN
IS TO GO. BEYOND A HUNDRED
STATION AND WE'RE- WITH THAT
STATED THAT WE ARE FUNDING AND
WHAT'S FUNDED BY PRIVATE
INDUSTRY WE'RE EXPECTING A
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE STATIONS
WILL BE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE-
AND- THEN THOSE STATIONS WILL
FUND WILL SUPPORT AT LEAST A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PROBABLY
CLOSER TO TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
SHALL SELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IN ST IT
IS EXPECTING ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND FUEL CELL VEHICLE SO
WE SHOULD HAVE A INFRASTRUCTURE
TO FAR EXCEED WHAT THE-
MANUFACTURERS SAY IT'S GOING TO
BE AVAILABLE ON THE FUEL PUMP
SIDE ON BY TO THE VEHICLES. IN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. WE ARE
USING OUR FIVE TO SIT BOTH-
ZERO CARBON HYDROGEN PRODUCTION.
AND TO SOME MEDIUM AND HEAVY.
STILL SOME ALSO- THEY SAID
BEFORE THAT A FACTOR I THINK
YOU KNOW. WE REALLY NEED. A
BATTERY LIFE FOR AND FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC THE TO- TO HELP US.
ACHIEVE OUR GOAL. ARE FULLY
ELECT THAT SET. SO FROM AMERICA
FIRST AND I THINK YOU POINTED
OUT FROM SO IT WE FEEL IT CAN
BE. THERE'S A LOT OF THE DAMAGE
TIGER- AND WE ARE SUPPORTING
WITH OUR FUNDS BOTH. JUST
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. HEARD OF THE
THANK YOU MISTER TEN. THANK ME
TO CHURCH A COUPLE- THAN ANY OF
IN THE FIVE. FROM THE MYSTERY
COULD ANSWER I. GOING BACK- TO
THE- AGENDA- THE DOCUMENT I
THINK OF INFORMATION FROM THE-
RESOURCES BOARD- WE GO THAT
TRANSPORTATION IS 40% OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN
THAT PASSENGER VEHICLES ARE
ABOUT. 80% OF THAT
TRANSPORTATION'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS SO WHY FIVE JUST
GOING BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
QUESTION WHY WAS THERE NO
FUNDING FOR THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROGRAM AND THE PROPOSAL.
YOUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCING
AND THANK YOU HAVE A QUESTION
WE DO UNDERSTAND THE
LEGISLATURE. IN THIS PROGRAM
WHAT ARE THE EXPENDITURE PLAN
INCLUDES FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
FOR CLEAN VEHICLE PROGRAMS THAT
FOCUS ON LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND REDUCING AIR
POLLUTION FROM HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES SO THAT IS WHERE.
BASED ON THE LIMITED FUNDING
THAT WE HAVE THAT IS WHERE WE
HAVE PROPOSED TO ALLOCATE.
THESE DOLLARS. SO THAT THERE IS
THERE IS A DECISION MAKE. TO
MOVE THE MONEY FROM C. B. R. P.
AND OTHER PEOPLE CAN YOU TELL
ME WHAT OTHER PROPOSALS WHERE
WHERE THE MONEY'S GETTING MOVED
TO. CERTAINLY SO WE DO NOT VIEW
THIS DOES THAT NECESSARILY
MOVING BUT- WE HAVE NOT MADE A
DOLLAR THIRTY PLUS BUT YOU JUST
SAID YOU SAID LIMITED DOLLARS.
THROUGH THE PROPRIOCEPTIVE FROM
YEARS PAST AND NOW THERE'S A
REAL. GOOD MOVIE OF
APPROPRIATIONS O DOLLARS HAVE
BEEN MOVED SO. THAT'S WHAT YOU
JUST SAID. RIGHT I UNDERSTAND
AND WE ARE LIMITED AS YOU'VE
NOTED BASED ON THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS. I HAVE A VERY
LIMITED FUNDING WE ARE
PROPOSING ONE HUNDRED ITEMS.
EIGHT SO I AYE APOLOGIES AYE WE
ARE PROPOSED TO FOCUS ON EQUITY
PROGRAMS AND ON AND HAVE THE
DUTY EAT THE APPLES AND
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS MY
AIRPORT COLLEAGUES ARE
AVAILABLE TO SPEAK MORE TO HOW
THOSE PROGRAM SUPPORT ACT
BETTER OVERALL ZERO EMISSION.
AND CLEAN TRANSPORTATION BILLS
ONE OF THAT THAT'S FINE I JUST
I JUST WANNA KNOW SO THE LAST
YEAR OR TWO YEARS AGO WE
APPROPRIATE ABOUT WITH A TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION. SO WHERE
WHERE IS THAT. TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION BEING APPROPRIATE
TO. CAN YOU WALK ME THROUGH IN
DETAIL. PLEASE. I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR
OFFICE ON THE SPECIFIC QUESTION
WAIT UNTIL YOUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU CAN'T WALK ME
THROUGH. WHERE THE
ADMINISTRATION PLANS ON
SPENDING TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. HOW HOW IS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HI
GOOD MORNING I AM GOOD MORNING
YES WE ARE AND- WORKING ACTING
TWENTY ONE TWO PLAN THAT
INTENDS THAT THOSE LIES MONEY
OVER BILL IN TRAINING ON MY
COLLEAGUE WITH HEARING- OKAY
BAND- PUBLIC HEALTH ESPECIALLY
PARKING HELPING TO PREVENT CAN.
YEAH IF WE CAN TO COMPARE KIND
OF FROM YEAR TO THIS. WE DO
THAT AND PROVIDE IT TO THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO AT THE UP-
THE SHOW THAT ALLOCATION THAT
WERE IN PLACE- TWENTY TWENTY
ONE COMPARED TO THE CAN. AND
ALSO WITH MY- COLLEAGUES ON THE
APPEARING WE OFFER AN UPDATE
COVENTRY PLANS WE'RE NOT WE'RE
AND APPROPRIATE- DEATH OPTION
AVAILABLE. TO AFTER MEMBER CAN
CAN. JUST MENTION ONE THING
WHICH I COME UP YET BUT WE THE
REPORT THAT- THERE. FOR LOW
CARBON STANDARD IS GOING TO BE
FROM FOR A VEHICLE IN. AND-
UNLIKE THEIR KEYBOARD YOU HAVE
TO LIKE A LOT OF FARM AND IT.
THIS IS A CASH THE HOOD CENTER
AND DATA IN THAT THESE ARE MUCH
MORE ACTIVE INTER OF DRIVING
THE MARKET THAT- AT YOU'RE
HAVING WHEN YOU SEE THE- ME
WALKING OF ZERO ANYTHING ON THE
FIFTEEN DOLLARS. THE VEHICLE
DOESN'T THAT'S THE MATH MASSIVE
SENATE VIA BY THE SO JUST IT
JUST HIGHLIGHT THERE IS A-
VEHICLE THAT. WRAPPED UP THAT I
ARE SOME ADVANTAGES OVER WHAT
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW WITH YOU DEAR.
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT IT'S BEEN
COMPLETELY ADOPTED BY ALL. FROM
ALL MANUFACTURERS WERE AS THE
QUEEN VEHICLE REPAIR PROGRAM
HOUSE- I WOULD JUST READ
REITERATE TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WITH THIS THIS IS. THIS
IS BUDGET COMMITTEE IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT IF YOU'RE
THERE'S- YOU KNOW NINE PEOPLE
LISTED TO TESTIFY IF THERE'S
NOBODY HERE WHO CAN ANSWER.
QUESTIONS REGARDING NUMBERS I
THINK IT'S NOT REALLY THE BEST
USE OF THIS COMMITTEES TIME- SO
I WOULD JUST ASK THAT- YOU KNOW
THAT THAT. IN THE FUTURE THAT
THE THAT THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
COME BETTER PREPARED WITH
SPECIFIC NUMBERS. ARMED GOING
BACK TO THE DISCUSSION AROUND-
SORT OF THAT THE MOVEMENT
TOWARD- LOW INCOME OUR LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS- DO YOU DO YOU
HAVE NUMBERS IN TERMS OF SORT
OF HOW MANY LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS YOU HAPPEN TO BE- HOW
MANY LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS
COMING FAMILIES YOU PUT YOU
PLAN ON OF ASSISTING WITH EACH
YEAR PROGRAMS. THREE THOUSAND
AGAIN WITH THE PART IN THE
FINANCE I DON'T HAVE THAT.
NUMBER OF PERSONS SERVING FOR
PROGRAMS AND- I CAN DEFERRED
IRRESISTIBLE. BECAUSE IT WILL
HAVE TO GET TO THE COMMITTEE.
IF THAT'S AVAILABLE ON THAT'S
MY AVAILABLE. EVERY TRANSPORT
PLEASE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE QUESTION- I'M HAPPY TO
CHIME IN WITH- SOME HISTORICAL
NUMBERS BUT IF THAT'S NOT
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
WERE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOUR
OFFICE TO GET YOU EXACTLY WHAT
YOU NEED- ONE OF THE PROGRAMS-
THAT IT WILL POINT TO AS IT'S
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET IS STAY CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL SCRAP AND REPLACE
PROGRAM. SO THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT- TARGETED AT LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS AND IS INTENDED TO
HELP ACCELERATE GETTING-
POLLUTING PASSENGER VEHICLES
OFF THE ROAD IN GETTING FOLKS
INTO CLEANER MODES OF MOBILITY
SO THE NUMBERS I HAVE ON THAT
IS THAT THERE'S OVER ELEVEN
THOUSAND CARS THAT HAVE BEEN
REPLACED DUE TO THIS PROGRAM
OVER TIME. OVER OVER HOW MANY
YEARS APPROXIMATELY. BUT LET ME
DOUBLE CHECK ON THAT FOR YOU
I'M SO SORRY GIVE A ROUGH
ESTIMATE HOW MANY YEARS WE'RE
TALKING. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
DECADE. IT'S ABOUT FIVE YEARS
AGO. IT ANY OTHER. SO THAT'S
THAT'S ONE OF A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS LISTED DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER INFORMATION ON THE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT YOU'VE-
HIGHLIGHTED FOR PLAN TO SPEND
MONEY ON. SURE I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ONE THING WE CAN FOLLOW UP WITH
YOUR OFFICE WITH WE ARE ALSO
HAPPY TO PROVIDE AND NUMBERS IN
TERMS OF THAT NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS WHO PARTICIPATED
IN THE FINANCING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. OF COURSE ANY DATING
YOU DON'T SEE IF YOU'RE KEY AND
IF THERE'S OTHER PROGRAMS
YOU'RE INTERESTED IN AS WELL.
HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT TO YOU.
ONE INTERESTED IN ALL OF THEM
SO YOU'RE YOU'RE I MEAN. THIS
THIS IS THE HEARING THE HEARING
IS LISTING- YOU KNOW OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS OF EXPENDITURE
ON PROGRAMS AND YOU'RE ONLY
PREPARED TO TALK ABOUT ONE
PROGRAM. YOU KNOW I COULD SPEAK
A LITTLE BIT AT THE TOP ON THE
CLINTON PROTECTION PROGRAM
ABSOLUTELY NOT RIGHT WHO EQUITY
INVESTMENT. YEAH SO
APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRD RUN
BACK TO DATE HAS BEEN PRETTY
GOOD BANDS IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. AND GOING FORWARD
OUR TARGET IS AT LEAST 50% ON A
PORTFOLIO BASIS POTENTIALLY
EVEN HIGHER. BONTA PROGRAMS
SUCH A MEETING COULD BE HEAVY
DUTY. WHERE WE KNOW THAT WOULD
BE CONCERNED EVEN. MORE ACUTE
FROM DIESEL EMISSION. AREA THAT
WE'RE REALLY TALKING ON AND
EVEN HAVE PRINCIPLES HEALTH OF
GOD THAT. HELLO OKAY BUT THAT
DOESN'T GIVE ME A SENSE OF- AND
I UNDERSTAND WITH THE HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES WITH A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT BECAUSE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT MOBILE SOURCES
ARE A BIT IN TERMS OF THE OTHER
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE DIRECT. OF
APPROPRIATIONS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOUR ACHIEVING THE
GOAL WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW MANY. FAMILIES WHO ARE.
ASSISTING SO. DO YOU HAVE ANY
MORE INFORMATION THAN WHAT YOU
JUST GAVE. YEAH WE'D BE HAPPY
TO PULL TOGETHER TO NUMBERS ON
A PROGRAM BY PROGRAM BASIS WITH
PORTFOLIO IF WE CAN DO IT ON A
FAMILY BASIS AS WELL WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT WE
OFTEN LOOK AT WHERE WE LOCATE.
TEMPERATURE WHICH QUITE
CANDIDLY IT'S SOMETHING WE WANT
TO GET EVEN BETTER AT KNOWING
THAT ACCESS DOESN'T NECESSARILY
NEED WHERE HYDROGEN STATION OR-
ELECTRIC CHARGING STATIONS
LOCATED BUT REALLY YOU KNOW WHO
HAS ACCESS TO THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN OUR
INAUGURAL SENATE BILL ONE
THOUSAND REPORT WE STARTED TO
LAY OUT THE INFORMATION WE DO
HAVE AND WE DO SO THE WERE
ACTUALLY LAGGING A LITTLE BIT
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES SO WE
WANT TO SHARPEN THAT TARGET-
ABSOLUTELY BUT ALSO LOOK AT
WHAT ACCESS REALLY MEANS SAID
THAT'LL BE SOMETHING- THAT WE
DEFINITELY COULD ON OUR NEXT
REPORT. SOMETHING WE'LL DO
EVERY. YEAR BUT- WHAT WILL COME
BACK YOU WHAT SOME MORE
GRANULAR INTERNET. ON SPECIFIC
PROGRAM BUT YOU FIND A-
WONDERSTRUCK UNDERSTAND A MAJOR
COMING FORWARD TO THIS
COMMITTEE FOR OVER BILLION
DOLLARS APPROPRIATION AND I'M-
HEARING A LOT OF VERY LOFTY
GOALS BUT NO DETAILED
INFORMATION. SO COULD COULD
ANYBODY HELP ME. WITH MORE
DETAIL I'M NOT LIKE WHAT WHAT
WHAT ARE WE GETTING FOR A
BILLION AND A HALF DOLLARS. SO
I'M JUST MAYBE TO BUILD OUT ON
SOME OF THE ORGAN. SPECIFIC
NUMBERS NOT IN WORD FOR ME WITH-
JUSTICE FROM UNDERGROUND THIS
IS BUDGET COMMITTEE SO AND
BUDGET COMMITTEE WE TEND TO
FOCUS ON YOU'RE ASKING FOR
MONEY. MONEY BUYS A CERTAIN
THINGS WITH LIKE THE FIRST
PACIFIC'S OF WHAT THE MONEY IS
BY. YEAH I COULD SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT ON THE BOTTOM OF THE
PACIFIC FROM HISTORICAL PROGRAM.
WHAT WHAT ABOUT HIS MENTOR WHAT
NOTE BOOK OF WHAT ABOUT FROM
THE FUTURE I MEAN YOU'RE ASKING
FOR A BILLION AND A HALF
DOLLARS TO BUY WHAT. YEAH IT
DOES WELL SO- REALLY THE FIRST
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PLEASE. IF THE
CLOTHES THAT TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
LIGHT PIZZA. WHICH IS ABOUT
FIFTY THOUSAND CHARTER WE WANT
TO DO THAT IN A COUPLE
DIFFERENT WAYS. ONE IS TO
EXPAND THE FIFTH US OF THE
ECOLOGY I. P. PROGRAM. WHICH
USES A LOT OF ANALYSIS FIFTY
WHERE THERE'S GAPS. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND THEN WE GO OUT WE
TARGET THOSE GOT. TO MEET FOR
THE ENTIRE STATE HAS A MINIMUM
FLOOR OF ACCESS. AND EVEN
WITHIN THAT WE HAVE EQUITY GOAL
THAT WE MARK IT. UP TRUST
BECAUSE ONE NOT- BUT WE WANT TO
GO EVEN FURTHER THIS IS ONE
CHALLENGE WHERE. WITH A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR WHICH
WE HAVE NOW WHICH IS A LOT OF
MONEY THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT
THAT. IT DOES LIMIT HOW WE MAKE
OUR INVESTMENT. BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE TO TRADE BETWEEN DUTY. AND
MEDIUM DUTY HEAVY DUTY. WHAT IF
I JUST FUNDING ON THE LIGHT
FIVE. WILL BE ABLE TO HOLD. A
MULTI MULTIPLE YOUR DWELLINGS
ARE MODEST. TOOK THE TAPES AND
WHICH WE WANT TO DO WHEN WE'RE
WORKING RIGHT NOW TO MOVE THAT
FORWARD. TO REALLY TARGET THAT
TALK EVERY SEGMENT. IN M. U. D.
WERE RENTERS OFTEN WHAT. WE'RE
ALSO GOING TO LAUNCH THE RURAL
COMMUNITIES. PROGRAM TO FOCUS
ON RURAL COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
AGAIN WE KNOW THAT THE AREA.
WHAT WE CAN DO MORE. AND WE
ALSO LOOK INTO POTENTIALLY WANT
SOMETHING. ON HIGH MILEAGE
VEHICLES LIKE TNCS. AND REALLY
IT'S A PORTFOLIO APPROACH TO
TAKE WHAT WORKING BUT THAT ALSO
TARGET AREAS WHERE WE NEED MORE
WORK- SO KNOW THAT THAT'S A LOT
MORE I THINK THE GRANULAR
THING. HOPEFUL THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR. UNLIKE YOU DECIDE
ALL. HYDROGEN FIVE WHICH SHOW
THE GAPS. I'M SORRY NO GO AHEAD
PLEASE. A THIRD ON THE HUNDRED
SIDE WITH TO GO ABOUT TWO ONE-
STATION FOR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND- WE THE JUST FUNDING WOULD
BE UPLOAD THAT GAP WE ISSUED A
NOTICE PROPOSED AND NOVA WHICH
INDICATES- STATIONED YOU MEET
OUR CRITERIA THAT WE COULD
CONTINUE TO FUND DOWN. AND
DEPLOY MORE THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
OVER TIME. AND THEN ALSO SEE.
THEM MEAT IN DUE TO HAVE DUTY
MARK. AND WHAT I MEAN BY THAT
IS THAT THE AREA THAT AGAIN
YEAH I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT
IT'S ALREADY BEEN SAID. BUT FOR
A LOT OF THE DIESEL EMISSIONS
COME FROM THAT'S WHERE YOU HAVE
A CUTE EQUITY ISSUES AND
FRANKLY. PEOPLE DIE FROM THAT
RIGHT THIS CAUSES CANCER THIS
BECAUSE OF THE HOUSE NOT THIS
IS AN AREA. THAT WE DEFINITELY
WANT TO TARGET AND THE MARKET
IS COMING DOWN. TO A PLACE
WHERE FIFTY DIFFERENT AND WE
CAN BE RISKY. YEAH ONE THING
THAT WE'VE LEARNED IS THAT A
LOT OF TIMES THE BUSINESSES.
AND LARGER COMPANIES THEY HAVE
MANDATE RIGHT AND THEY'LL DO
THEM BUT THEY MIGHT WAIT UNTIL
LATER IN THE GAME TO ACHIEVE
THE TARGET BECAUSE- THEY'RE
WORRIED THEY HAVE AGGRESSIVE IN
MAKING SOME DISCOMFORT THAT.
YOU KNOW IF YOUR UPS DELIVERY
VEHICLE OR TRANSPORTATION THE
PRIMARY PURPOSE IS. TO DELIVER
PACKAGES. LAURENT GIVE
INVESTMENT CAN REALLY HELP REST.
OF THEM. THAT HELP THEM ADOPT
YOU KNOW CAN'T PULL AND THEN
MORE AND MORE. VEHICLES BOTH A
LOT. AND HYDROGEN. TO THE POINT
WHERE THEY COMP. THAT ONE IT
WILL FOR THE ROCK. THANK THANK
YOU. THE ONLY NUMBER. THIRTY
NUMBER HEARD WAS THOUSAND
CHARGER. SO DOING DOLLARS FOR
FIFTY THOUSAND CHARGERS WORKS
OUT TO BE WHAT ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A CHARGER. IS
THAT IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
ANTICIPATING SUBSIDIZING SARDIS
ALL LEVEL. THREE CHARGERS THAT
YOU'RE PLANNING TO SUBSIDIZE. I
THINK YOU'VE GOT A GREAT
QUESTION- SO KELLY THE I. P. WE
IS OUR PRIMARY LIGHT DUTY-
PROGRAM WHICH DOES BOTH LEVEL
TWO AND DC I THINK. AND IN THE
PAST IT WAS ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR INVESTMENT ON
LEVEL TWO THE PUBLIC DOLLAR THE
PRIVATE SECTOR PICKED UP ABOUT.
WE'VE GONE DOWN TO FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR LEVEL TWO
CHARGER AND WE'RE GONNA
PROPOSED EVEN GO FURTHER DOWN
THE CARE. SHOWN TO TRANSITION
FOR MORE MORE PRIVATE FUNDING
ABOUT 66% OF THE LEVEL TWO
CHARGER IT PAID WORK FOR
SOMETHING IF FOUR. OUTSIDE THE
MARKET HE WON WE FUNDING SO.
ARE WE GETTING MORE THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND CHARGERS. SO THAT THE
WAY WE DID THE ANALYSIS TO LOOK
AT HOW WE COVER THAT FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND. GAP WITH A THREE
HUNDRED MILLION AT THE
PORTSMOUTH FOR LEVEL TWO PORT A
PRETTY FAIR ENOUGH FOR THE FOUR
HUNDRED M. AND WE TOOK AN
APPROPRIATE SAID. IF WE WERE TO
KEEP OUR FUNDING. FOR THE WORK
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW. LONG BUT
WORTHY OF THE NINE HUNDRED
MILLION GOING. SO THE- OTHER
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION. THREE
HUNDRED MILLION. WILL GO TO A
LIGHTED AFTER TRUCKERS THAT
THREE HUNDRED. FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND CHARTERED IN TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED. AND THEN THE
MEDIUM DUTY HEAVY DUTY MARKET.
THAT VARY QUITE A BIT OF
COMMERCE SUPERCHARGER TO COULD
YOU CAN OPERATE WITHIN SO THE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION FOR LIGHT
DUTY INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT'S WITH
THAT WHAT IS A- FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND. CHARGERS ON THE EAST
SIDE AND TWENTY ONE HUNDRED AND-
YOU BECAUSE THE SECOND THAT YOU
TALK ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND
ARTISTS ANNOUNCED SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND CHARGERS ANSWER. I
APOLOGIZE ABOUT THAT FIFTY AYE
YEAH MISSPOKE FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND THE GOT THAT RESPECT.
FOR THE LIKE EIGHTY FIVE FOR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE BUT THAT'S
FOR THREE HUNDRED MILLION RIGHT.
FOR BOTH ELECTRIC AND HYBRID
INSIDE FOR ABOUT FOR LIGHT DUTY
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
GOALS. OKAY- HE- SO THREE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION. OKAY DIVIDED
BY WHAT YOU SAID FORTY TWO
HUNDRED OR FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE AND OR TALK ABOUT.
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED FOR THE
LEVEL TWO. FIFTY THOUSAND FOR
THE DEFEAT OF THE- AND I WOULD
NEED TO LOOK BUT I BELIEVE ONE
POINT THREE MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED AND FISHING. AND THAT'S
ASSUMING A CONSTANT WE ACTUALLY
WANT TO LIVE UPON ONE POINT
THREE MILLION YEAR HER YEARS OF
THE STATION TO THE COME WITH
THE COME WITH THE POWER PLANT
TO. I WILL SAY THIS WHICH IS
REALLY ENCOURAGING HOW QUICKLY
IN THE PAST WE PAY 430% I'M
SORRY 5070% OF THE HUNDRED
STATES AND WE'RE NOT FIFTY
FIFTY AND THOSE ARE ACTUALLY
TAKING THAT HAVE EVEN MORE
CAPACITY THAN THEY DID IN THE
PAST WHAT WE'RE SEEING AT
HIGHER CAPACITY STATION. WITH
YOUR PUBLIC DOLLARS. OKAY OKAY
SO. WHEN I SAY LOOK I AM. A BIG
FAN OF THE IDEA THAT WE NEED TO
AFFRONT TO UPFRONT INVESTMENTS.
ON AND THAT I THINK THE TIME IS
DEFINITELY NOW SOME DEGREE FROM
MY COLLEAGUE FROM- IN A
GLENDALE THAT THE TIME IS
DEFINITELY NOW TO BE INVESTING
IN. THIS INFRASTRUCTURE HOWEVER
I'M NOT CLEAR WHAT WE'RE
INVESTING IN AND IT'S NOT CLEAR
WHAT WERE. SPENDING THIS MONEY
ON. SEOUL IF WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE'RE GETTING FOR A BILLION
DOLLARS AND THE ANSWER SEEMS TO
HAVE CHANGED BY THE MINUTE- I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE COULD
APPROVE THAT SO LET ME LET ME
JUST GO TO- THE TWO BUCKETS-
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM VENTURA
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER. IN TERMS
OF. THE THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
MILLION OVER TWO YEARS FOR
HEAVY VEHICLES AND A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR TWO YEARS
OVER THE TRANSPORTATION EQUITY
PROGRAMS. ON OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW
THAT THE WORD EQUITY'S BEEN
MENTIONED QUITE A BIT AND FOR
ME OBVIOUSLY IT MYSELF A LOT OF
OUR COLLEAGUES. THE VERY
SENSITIVE POINT THE THINK A LOT
OF OUR COMMUNITIES FEEL LIKE
THEY THEY HAVEN'T GOT ANY ANY
BENEFIT FROM THESE PROGRAMS SO
WE DO APPRECIATE THAT THERE IS.
A KNOWLEDGE MENT OF THAT. WELL
I'M HAVING SAID THAT- WHY IS
THERE NO- DIRECT- APPROPRIATION
FOR THESE PARTICULAR PROGRAMS.
WE'VE GONE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
SIDE OF THAT HELPFUL- EITHER
QUIT TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
INVESTMENT PLAN TO DO A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND
GOVERNOR INPUT FROM MARKET AND
EQUITY COMMUNITIES THAT
COMMUNITIES CAN HELP NOT ABOUT
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE WITH THE
PLAN- YEAH THIS YEAR WE'RE
LOOKING AT MORE ON MY TV AFTER
TRUCKER WITH THE SHIP TO. MEET
IF YOU HAVE A DUTY AND THEN WE
ALSO DO WORKSHOPS THROUGH A
PUBLIC PROCESS TO PROPOSED PUT
THE TAPE IN SUCH A TREND THAT
OUR GREAT TRUCK THINGS OF THAT
NATURE AND GET INPUT TO REACT
TO THE MARKET IF YOU WERE. TO
COVER AND THEN DEPLOY THAT. SO
WHY WHY YOU DOING THE PROP
FIRST AND THEN COMING TO US.
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S A
COMBINATION OF BOTH RIGHT I
THINK SOMETIMES THE MARKET DOES
NOT TAKE US SERIOUSLY IF WE
DON'T HAVE MONEY TO BACK IT UP.
YOU KNOW THEY HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT CALLED SPECIAL WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE WORK IN
DIFFERENT STATES. AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
FUNDING TO SHOW THEM THAT IT'S
REAL AND THEN ENGAGE WITH THEM
TO DO IT- A LOT OF THE
PARAMETERS WHICH HELP GUIDE OUR
DECISIONS NOW. WHAT THEY DID
LEGISLATION. WHAT'S RCGP
INVESTMENT PLAN AS WELL AS WITH
REALLY GREAT TOOLS WHICH WE
HAVE. WITH AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN AND SENATE BILL ONE
THOUSAND. AND ALSO AB EIGHT
HUNDRED FIVE. THE WHAT WE DO-
ALL THE CLEAN VEHICLE- FUNDING
PROGRAMS THAT WAY THE. SO THIS
IS A NEIGHBOR JUST WITH THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD I'LL JUST JUMP
IN THAT THE PROCESS ON THE
CURBSIDE IS VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT WAS DESCRIBED ON THE CDC
SIDE WE TAKE OUR CUES FROM THE
ANNUAL APPROPRIATIONS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE. RAN THROUGH- BROAD
BUCKETS OF FUNDING THAT WE
OFTEN GET TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT SPECIFIC PROGRAMS SHOULD
RECEIVE FUNDING AND WHETHER OR
NOT WE SHOULD BE MAKING ANY
KIND OF PROGRAM CHANGES- I
UNDERTAND YOU WERE IN TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT MAYBE SOME RULES
OF THUMB EARLIER FOR HOW TO
THINK ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET SO- WHAT YOU'LL
SEE IN. THE GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET
IS BASICALLY BINS OF DIFFERENT
TYPES OF FUNDING LIKE EQUITY
AND HEAVY DUTY BUT THEN INSIDE
EACH OF THOSE BUCKETS OR ARE
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS. AT LEAST
FROM THE CAR PERSPECTIVE. SO IF
YOU LOOK AT A PROGRAM LIKE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL.
PRESCRIPTION REPLACE PROGRAM.
ON AVERAGE- EIGHT AVERAGE
INCENTIVE DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT IS
ABOUT EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR FINANCING ASSISTANCE IT'S
ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
GRANT PER VEHICLE. SO USING
THESE AVERAGES MAYBE CAN HELP
YOU BALLPARK YOU KNOW THINKING
ABOUT THESE VARIOUS BUCKETS. I
DON'T REALLY FEEL PARKS IN THIS
COMMITTEE WE DO SPECIFIC
NUMBERS SO WHAT'S THE SPECIFIC
NUMBER. SURE WELL GIVEN. THE
BALLPARK YOUR BUDGET WITHOUT BE
HELPFUL. MAYBE LESS SO YES
RIGHT RIGHT I AGREE. WITH THAT
WE CAN BOTH AGREE ON THAT. SO I
THINK THE THING THAT- WE'RE
BOTH TRYING TO CONVEY IS THAT
THERE'S A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE BURIED IN
THESE BUCKETS AND SO SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE MOVE FORWARD. WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
AND FOR THOSE DIFFERENT BUCKETS
WE WOULD THEN USE THE PUBLIC
PROCESS OVER THE SUMMER TO
REFINE THOSE ALLOCATIONS ON A
PER PROGRAM- A PER PROGRAM
AMOUNT FOR EACH OF THOSE
BUCKETS. I WHICH WOULD THEN
TAKE TO REPORT EVERY YEAR AT
OCTOBER FOR A FINAL DECISION
LEGISLATURE OF COURSE. YOU KNOW
IT'S YOUR PREROGATIVE IF YOU IF
YOU WOULD WANT TO PUT
APPROPRIATE PER LINE ITEM
THAT'S JUST NOT HOW THE
EXISTING GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET DOES. IS SET UP. THE WAY
YOU SEE IT TODAY. OKAY THANK I
WANT TO ADD. JUST ONE POINT TWO
IS WHAT CITY. WHAT CITY AN
ANTENNA WERE SAYING TO. BUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL- ALSO I
DON'T. REALLY FOCUS ON ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. SO ONE OF THE I
MEAN WE NEED TO BUILD THAT
SEVEN CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE OF
THE MAJOR BARRIER TO THAT THE
PLANET BUT WE ALSO NEED. TO
CREATE JOBS AND TO STIMULATE
THE ECONOMY IN THIS TIME SO.
THAT IS ANOTHER IMPORTANT
BENEFIT OF THE GOVERNOR URGED
FOCUS ON BUILDING OUT THEIR
MISSION VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE.
IS BECAUSE THESE ARE SHOVEL
READY PROJECT WE HAVE. TEN WITH
SAYING THE PROGRAM THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT WHICH WE
CAN DEFINE ONE IN THERE. AND WE
CAN DEPLOY IT. CHARGERS VERY
RAPIDLY. TO HELP CREATE GOOD
JOBS. IN YOU KNOW IN AN
INDUSTRY THAT WE KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO NEED FOR THE FUTURE
YOU KNOW YOU WANT THIS YEAR
MISSION VEHICLE INDUSTRY.
SUGGEST GROWING CRIED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO KEEP
BEING THAT. SHE AND- GLOBALLY
ON ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION. AND SO YOU KNOW
THE BIG INVESTMENT NOW SHOWED
THE WORLD THAT WE'RE COMMITTED.
AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO
OVERCOMING WHAT IS. ONE OF THE
BIGGEST BARRIERS AND I WAS AND
STILL. THE BIGGEST BARRIER
WHICH IS A LACK OF A
CONVENIENCE. THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN OTHER AND I
COMPLETELY WITH YOU BURKE
COMMISSIONER I THINK THAT I
THINK THE- IS. ON THE- ONLY
WORKS IF YOU HAVE. TO FUEL. THE
THIS POINT AS AS YOU KNOW
SWITCHED HAVE UNDER A MILLION
VEHICLES WERE WELL SHORT OF R.
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION VEHICLE
GOAL BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
WELL SHORT OF OUR FIVE MILLION
VEHICLE GOAL BY TWENTY THIRTY.
AND SO WHAT WE DON'T WANT IS TO
HAVE- A LOT OF CHARGING
STATIONS WITH NO VEHICLES
CHARGING AT THE- I THINK THAT
IS THE- THE- I THINK. THE MAJOR
QUESTION BECAUSE THERE ISN'T-
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE PROPOSAL
THAT REALLY HELPS DRIVE AT THE
OVERALL GOAL OF GETTING TO THE
FIVE MILLION VEHICLES BY TWENTY
THIRTY UNLESS IT'S THE
ADMINISTRATION'S. VIEWPOINT
THAT THE THAT WE'VE DONE ENOUGH
IN THE MARKET WILL GET US TO
FIVE MILLION VEHICLES BY TWENTY
THIRD. I'LL TRY TO VOTE THE LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. FOR THE
CHICKEN AND EGG PROBLEM SOUNDS
AND I ACTUALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU WITH EVERYTHING FOR AT
LEADING THE CHARGE TO HUNT AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN BECAUSE
IT REALLY HAS BEEN A GREAT TOOL
FOR US. IN TERMS OF ASSESSING
WHERE THE MARKET IS AND WHERE
IT'S GOING AND HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE WE'RE WE'RE BEING
STRATEGIC IN OUR STATE
INVESTMENT- ATTACK AND I
COMPLETELY AGREE I THINK I
THINK YOU PUT TOGETHER A GREAT
REPORT AND I WAS- IN ORDER TO.
CARRY THAT BILL I THINK YOU'VE
DONE A GREAT JOB IN IDENTIFYING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. BUT I
THINK THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
OBVIOUSLY. BUT INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS ARE BASED ON ASSUMPTIONS.
OF GREATER ALECTRA VEHICLE
ADOPTION. AND SO I GUESS IS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
POSITION THAT WE NO LONGER NEED
TO- PROVIDE ANY INCENTIVE FOR.
PASSENGER VEHICLES AND THAT
NATURALLY THE MARKET WILL JUST.
GET US TO WHERE WE NEED TO GO
OUTSIDE OF. AGAIN THE EQUITY
COMMUNITIES WHICH IS WHERE THE
BUDGET HAS IDENTIFIED SOME
NEEDS. RIGHT I DO THINK WE ARE
SEEING TREMENDOUS PROGRESS
GLOBALLY I MEAN THE QUESTION
YOU ASK IS IT TIME TO TAKE
THEIR HANDS OFF THE WHEEL WHEN
IT COMES TO THE APPLIANCE AND
IT IS A COMPLICATED ONE AT.
THAT YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH SUCH AS THE
MARKET ACCELERATE AS WE GET
MORE VEHICLE OPTIONS AT EVERY
PRICE ITS FAULT. BUT NO MATTER
WHAT. THE COMMITTEES. I'M SORRY
I'M NOT APOLOGIZE FOR
INTERRUPTING YOU BUT THE IT IS
A COMPLICATED ONE. BUT YOU'VE
ANSWERED IT IN YOUR BUDGET.
PROPOSAL SO. IS THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL REFLECTIVE OF YOU KNOW.
YOU'RE THINKING WHICH IS THE
LIKE AGAIN BUDGETS ARE
STATEMENTS OF ALEX IN THIS
BUDGET STATES THAT THEY'RE NO
LONGER NEEDS TO BE INCENTIVES
FOR PASSENGER. VEHICLES AB SIDE%
OF CERTAIN LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES. I THINK THAT THE
THAT'S CORRECT THE FRAMING IS
REALLY THAT WE NEED TO SUPPORT
LOW INCOME FAMILIES MAKE SURE
THAT THE TO THE TRANSITION THAT
WORKS FOR EVERYONE- THAT WE
NEED TO PRIORITIZE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE INCENTIVES
WHERE THE MARKET IS NASCENT BUT
GROWING- AND THAT'S ACTUALLY
WHERE I HAVE A LOT OF OPTIMISM
THAT IF WE CAN JUST SET THE
RIGHT. BUSINESS SIGNALED.%
INDUSTRY ONE BASS BUT IT'S TOO
EARLY WE NEED TO DO BRACKET-
YOU'RE GOING TO SIGN. A NIGHT
OF FUN I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT
YOU HAVE ANSWERED MY QUESTION.
WELL PLATE THAT I THINK THE
AFTERMATH IN CENTER IS A IS A
BET ABOUT STRUCTURE AND THE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLAR CASH ON
THE HOOD AND SEND IT THROUGH
THE LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD I.
THINK WE NEED TO GO BACK THE
QUESTION THAT YOU RAISE NOT ALL
AUTOMAKERS HAVE. HAS TAKEN IT
THAT'S THAT'S NEW. FOR ME AND I
DON'T KNOW SYDNEY IF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD ON THAT. THE
DESIGN OF THE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLAR. CHECK ANOTHER INCENTIVE.
IN TERMS OF THE OVERALL IT
BUDGET STRUCTURE AND WHAT'S
BEING PROPOSED THERE ARE I
WOULD JUST SIMPLY PUT A TICKET
TO MY COLLEAGUES AT DELOS-
THERE ARE AS YOU'VE NOTED ON A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS THAT AREN'T
NECESSARILY SET UP THE SAME WAY
SEE EUROPEANS BUT IS INTENDED
TO HELP INSURE THAT FOLKS ARE
GETTING INTO. LOLOISH AND ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. THE CARD
FINANCING AND YES WE WOULD SAY
THAT THAT DOWNTOWN PROPOSAL
FOR. HELPING TRADE BETTER
REFLECT THE PRIORITY ARE
DENOTED OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESPECIALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND THE PROPOSAL
FOR YOU ALL TODAY COMPUTERS AND
ALSO REALLY TRY TO PARKING
STRUCTURE WITHIN. HE HAS. A
BARRIER. TO THE BIGGER- ALECTRA
VOEPEL IT IS OF A FACTOR PARTY
AGAINST WITH YOU ARE CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS AND ON HOW CAN
THREE. NO NO WE'RE WE'RE WITH
THE THAT WHICH ON MAKE SURE THE
THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE NO. WE
HAVE NO- DISK THAT WE DON'T
WANT THE MONEY TO GO TO A LARGE
COMMITTEES DO WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE IT'S GETTING THERE A
QUICK QUESTION REGARDING THE-
PLUS UP SO THERE IS A LOW
INCOME PLUS UP THROUGH C. V. R.
P. WITH THE BRP GOING WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THAT POPOFF UP FOR
LOW INCOME FAMILIES WHO ARE.
INTERESTED IN. FRANKLIN CARS.
THERE ARE HAPPY HAPPY TO FILL
IN THEIR ABILITIES CAPITA
REPLACE PROGRAMON ITS OWN FOR
A LOW INCOME PERCENT OFFERS
NINETY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
SCRAPPING AND THEN REPLACING
WITHOUT YOUR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE- UNDER CURRENT
CONDITIONS THAT IS A PROGRAM
THAT IS STACKABLE WITH CVR PETE
WITHOUT C. B. R. P. ON THAT
PROGRAM THE STOCK'S CAPITAL
BASED PROGRAM WOULD CONTINUE
ALL ALONG THAT LOWER AMOUNT OF
NINETY FIVE HUNDRED GODDESSES
SO LOW INCOME FAMILIES WOULD
LOSE THAT FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. SO GOING BACK TO CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL ON YOU CAN
PURCHASE A NEW OR USED
CONVENTIONAL GAS VEHICLES
HYBRID PLUG IN ELECTRIC-
BATTERY ELECTRIC SERVICE IS
THERE A REASON WHY YOUR ARMY-
SUBSIDIZING. ANYTHING BUT CLEAN
CARS. IN THE CLEAN CARS FALL
PROGRAM. ANYTHING I'M SORRY I'M
NOT ACTUALLY CHECKING THE
QUESTION IS THE QUESTION. IN
THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM
SOMEONE CAN CAN GET RID OF
THEIR OLD CAR BUY A NEW CAR BUT
THERE'S A WIDE VARIETY OF NEW
CARS THEY CAN BUY THEIR REASON.
WHY THAT'S NOT RESTRICTED ONLY
TO- CLEAN CARS. NEW CLEAN CARS.
OR USE CLEAN CARS SURE SURE SO
WITH THE STRUCTURE OF THE
PROGRAM THE IDEA HERE IS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO OUTREACH AND
PROVIDE AS MANY CLEAN OPTIONS
TO LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
CONSUMERS AS WE POSSIBLY CAN
WITH THE GOAL OF COURSE OF
CLEANING UP TRANSPORTATION
BROKER THE ACCELERATION OF
THROUGH THE RETIREMENT OF OLDER
DIRTIER CARS BUT ALSO REPLACING
WITH CLEANER CARS SO YOU'RE
RIGHT THE PROGRAM DOES OFFER
YOU KNOW A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
TYPES FROM FROM HYBRID TO PURE.
JEFF YOUR ZERO MISSION WE- AS
PART OF THE STRUCTURE THE
PROGRAM BASED ON THE INPUT WE
ARE GETTING THROUGH THE PUBLIC
PROCESS WE DID NOT WANT TO
DICTATE WHICH YOU KNOW OPTIONS
WERE AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT DIFFERENT
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS
WHEN IT COMES TO MOBILITY AND
SO WE'RE TRYING TO STRIKE THAT
BALANCE OF GETTING FOLKS INTO A
CLEANER VEHICLE BUT HELPING
THEM GET INTO A CLEANER VEHICLE
THAT THAT MEETS THEIR
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS. I THINK
JUST COME BACK TO MY M.
MCAULIFFE INVENTORS COMMENTS.
PART PART THE REASON WHY I
THINK THERE'S- THERE THERE'S NO
SUPPORT. TO GIVE- CARB THE
AUTHORITY- TO SPEND THE MONEY
OVER TO YOUR PERRY WITHOUT
SPECIFICALLY- LINE LINE ITEM-
APPROPRIATING DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS. IS BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S A FEELING INCLUDING ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF. THAT THE
AGENCY. LISTENS TO CERTAIN.
STAKEHOLDERS BUT DOESN'T WITH
INTO THE LEGISLATURE. I FOR ONE
DO NOT FEEL THE AGENCIES VERY
RESPONSIVE TO THE LEGISLATURE
OF LEGISLATURES. IMPORT OR- YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT WE HAVE TO SAY.
I THINK. HIS HIS EXAMPLE WAS
ILLUSTRATIVE OF. THE TYPICAL
CARBON ACTION WHICH IS CARP
TELLS US WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO.
WE GIVE FEEDBACK AND THEN CARP
CONTINUES TO DO WHAT THEY WERE
GONNA DO. SO I REALLY DO HOPE
WITH- NEW LEADERSHIP COMING IN
THAT THERE WILL BE A CHANGE IN
THAT RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE PUBLIC. ARE
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
NEEDS AND WE DO HAVE- YOU KNOW
VERY LOFTY GOALS THAT WE WANT
TO ALL THE CHIEF AND WE'RE ALL
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF. PUBLIC LAST
QUESTION ON A FIT I KNOW THE-
SHIFT FROM. PASSENGER VEHICLES
TO HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES MEDIUM
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES. I JUST
WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHY THAT
TIME IS NOW TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION AND WHETHER. ON THE
REALLY ARE MARKET OPTIONS
OUTSIDE OF BUT I'M I'M WELL
AWARE OF THE BUS MARKET BUT-
OUTSIDE OF THAT IF THIS IS
REALLY THE TIME TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION. SHARE WITH RESPECT
TO THE OVERALL STATE OF THE
ZERO EMISSION HEAVY DUTY MARKET
NOW IS REALLY A VERY EXCITING
TIME. THERE'S OVER A HUNDRED
MODELS OF ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO BE SOLD
TODAY AND OVER SIX MAJOR OEMS.
THAT ARE PRODUCING IN THE HEAVY
DUTY CLASS EIGHT SPACE RIGHT
NOW. THERE ARE SEVERAL THINGS
ON THE HORIZON- TO HELP THEM
CONTINUE CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP MODEL WHEN IT COMES
TO. IN MANUFACTURING AND THE
PURCHASE OF THESE ZERO EMISSION%
TRUCKS- ONE OF THE ADVANCE
CLEAN TRUCKS REGULATION AND
THIS WILL FEES AND STARTING IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. WHICH WILL
REQUIRE MANUFACTURERS TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEY ARE SELLING.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
INCREASING NUMBERS OF ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS TO MARKET. AND
THAT THAT REDUCE REQUIREMENTS
RANGE ALL THE WAY FROM CLASS TO
BE ALL THE WAY UP TO CLASS
EIGHT. THE H. BUT PROGRAM WHICH
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED A LITTLE BIT
TODAY. OFFICERS AS ANY WILL
SERVE AS A COMPLEMENT TO THAT-
REQUIREMENT WHICH WILL HELP TO
IMMERSE. IT INTO AND MAKE THIS
PURCHASE DECISIONS FOR THOSE-ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS SO- THE
FUTURE REALLY IS NOW WHEN IT
COMES TO ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKING. GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO JUST JUST TO REITERATE
I REALLY DO HOPE THAT THE
AGENCY WILL BECOME AGAIN MORE
RESPONSIVE TO. I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE AND FRANKLY THE
PUBLIC'S INPUT I THINK IT'S
BEEN. LACKING UNFORTUNATELY IN
THE PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT. AND IT
I DO LOOKED FORWARD TO THE
FOLLOW UP FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION TO GET GREATER
DETAIL ABOUT WHERE THIS. IS
GOING. BUT I WOULD JUST SAY I
CAN'T SUPPORT. D. THREE POINT
THIRTY THREE TO FIFTEEN MILLION
OVER TWO YEARS FOR HEAVY
VEHICLES IN THE HUNDRED. FIFTY
MILLION OVER TWO YEARS FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAMS
WITHOUT- LINE BY LINE DETAIL.
ABOUT WHERE THE MONEY IS GOING.
THANK YOU. MISS FRIEDMAN DID
YOU OF ALL OF A TO FOLLOW UP
AND NOT TO GET TOO DEEP INTO
THE WOODS BUT I AM WONDERING
WITH THE EQUITY PROGRAM AND- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
BROUGHT UP THAT THE LAST THING
WE WANT IS TO SPEND A LOT OF
MONEY ON CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HAVE NO WHEN
YOU SAID I'M WONDERING IF THE
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED IN SUCH A
WAY TO LOOK AT THOSE CHARGERS
AS THE ROLLING OUT TO SEE
WHETHER THEY ARE ACTUALLY
BEING. UTILIZED BECAUSE THERE
ARE A LOT OF BARRIERS OUTSIDE
OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE- IN
PARTICULARLY IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES TO PURCHASING AND
OPERATING VEHICLES AND IT MIGHT
EVEN BE JUST- PEOPLE'S
IMPRESSIONS YOU KNOW COULD BE A
BARRIER THERE'S ALL KINDS OF
THINGS THAT COULD STOP PEOPLE
FROM BEING EARLY ADOPTERS OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY SO IS A PROGRAM
DESIGNED TO EVALUATE IS IT GOES
ALONG WITH THE- THE CHARGES ARE
ACTUALLY BEING USED AND HOW
THEY'RE BEING USED AND BY WHOM.
AND TO PIVOT. IF NEED BE. ARE
THEY AT. THE START AND THEN AND
THEN IF YOU WANT TO- EMBELLISH
AT ALL. SO AT RIGHT NOW YOU
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE. THE BIG
DATA ON HOW MANY. PEOPLE ARE
USING THE CHARGERS AND YOU KNOW
WHAT HOW LONG ARE USING THEM
FOR BUT ACTUALLY PLANNING TO DO
A PILOT PROJECT TO EVALUATE
THAT BECAUSE IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT QUESTION- SIX. ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE IS
PACKED WE GET AS I SAID WE HAVE
A CHICKEN EGG PROBLEM SO WE
WANT TO HAVE THE CHARGERS OUT.
BEFORE THEY'RE BEING USED. AND
WE KNOW THAT. THE CHARGING
MARKET ISN'T CURRENTLY SELF
SUSTAINING. YOU KNOW THEY'RE
NOT MAKING MONEY- AND WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS. IS
STAGGER THE INVESTMENT SO THAT
WE GET- THE CHARGERS OUT THERE
BEFORE. THEY ARE AND YEARS THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE OUT THERE BEFORE
IT'S NEEDED. THEN AS THE MARKET
STARTS TO TAKE OFF AND WE'LL
SEE. GREATER UTILIZATION OF
EACH CHARGER. THEN THE AMOUNT
THAT WE'RE GONNA FUNDS PER
CHARGE WILL GO DOWN I MEAN OUR
GOAL IS TO THEIR OUT MOST
INVESTMENT OVER OVER YOU KNOW
CHIMED. IN IT IN A KIND OF.
LOGICAL TRANSPARENT WAY FOR THE
MARKET ISN'T. FOR HERKY JERKY
BUT THEY SEE THAT THE HORIZON.
AND THEY'RE MAKING INVESTMENTS
TO TAKE TO GET THERE. I THINK
ON THE TRADING SIDE WE MAY
ALWAYS NEED SOME CHARGERS. THAT
ARE. ARE FUNDED BY THE STATE IN
PLACES WHERE THE INSURGENTS
WILL GO TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
IS. SEVEN FOR STRUCTURE THAT
WORKS FOR EVERYBODY YEAH I
THOUGHT I JUST HIGHLY YOU KNOW
I THINK WE REALLY NEED TO BUILD
THIS PROGRAM IN SUCH A WAY THAT
YOU DO HAVE. A LOT OF
EVALUATION ON THE GROUND
BECAUSE YOU KNOW I'VE HEARD
JUST ANECDOTALLY THAT FOR
INSTANCE. EVEN IN MULTI FAMILY
BUILDINGS THAT HAVE CHARGING
STATIONS. THE LANDLORDS WANT TO
CHARGE RESIDENTS TO USE THEM
BECAUSE OF THE COST OF THE
ELECTRICITY WHICH RIGHT NOW IS
NOT BORNE BY THE INDIVIDUAL-
TENANTS. SO YOU KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS THAT CAN HAPPEN
ON THE GROUND THAT REALLY.
BECOME HUGE BARRIERS SO JUST
HAVING A CHARGER IN A LOCATION.
REALLY DOESN'T GIVE US ANY DATA
AT ALL ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
LIKE YOU SAID TO BE UTILIZED
AND HOW AND BY WHOM. SO PUTTING
A CHARGER FOR INSTANCE IN A
MULTI FAMILY BUILDING AND THEN
FINDING OUT IT'S ONLY BEING
USED BY THE BUILDING OWNER WHEN
THEY VISIT THE BUILDING. AND
NOT THE TENANTS IS NOT THE
INTENTION EITHER. SO I THINK
THIS PROGRAM HAS TO HAVE
EXTREMELY STRONG- OVERSIGHT AND
METRICS AND GUARDRAILS BECAUSE
IT'S A LOT OF MONEY THAT. WILL
BE PUT UP. AND A GREAT
INTENTIONS BUT IT WOULD BE
AWFUL TO FIND OUT. LATER THAT
THE MONEY WAS SPENT AND IT'S
NOT HELP. THE CA. THAT IT'S
INTENDED TO HELP. SO I WOULD TO
SEE AT SOME POINT DETAILS ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO. EVALUATE
THE CHARGERS AND THE INVESTMENT
THAT WE'RE MAKING. THANKS SO
MUCH. I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE INSURANCE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW DO WE DO THIS IN A WAY
THAT IS BEST FOR THE PUBLIC
DOLLARS BACK FOR THE MARKET AND
THAT'S FOR AN EQUITABLE
SOLUTION FOR CALIFORNIA. YES I
CERTAINLY AGREE AND- I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
SUFFERING FROM HERE AT TODAY IF
IT HASN'T. BEEN EVIDENT. AS OF
A LACKOF ANALYSIS SHOWING.
THAT THE PROPOSALS THAT ARE
BEING MADE- SUPPORT THE GOALS
THAT THAT THAT THAT WE ALL
SHARE. AND SO MORE INFORMATION-
DEMONSTRATING THAT WOULD BE-
VERY VERY WELCOME AS WE- HAVE
CONTINUED TO ANALYZE. THE
BUDGET PROPOSALS THAT ARE MADE
STEP BY A YEAR AGENCIES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
THAT'S THE- UNSPENT TO- FUNDING
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
INITIATIVE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I M
NATALIE LEE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE RENEWABLE ENERGY DIVISION
AT THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION I HAVE A BRIEF
REMARKS FOR THE COMMITTEE ON
THIS ITEM. I REQUEST FUNDING
PREVIOUSLY ENCUMBERED UNDER THE
NEW SOLAR HOMES PARTNERSHIP OR
AN S. H. P. PROGRAM. TO BE RE
APPROPRIATED FOR NEW PURPOSES
PROPOSED BY ADVOCATE. I'D LIKE
TO FIRST ADDRESS THE SOURCING
AVAILABILITY OF THE FUNDS
IDENTIFIED FOR REALLOCATION.
THE N. S. H. P. PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BYTHE ENERGY
COMMISSION IS PART OF THE
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL CALIFORNIA
SOLAR INITIATIVE WHICH LAUNCHED
IN JANUARY OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN. AND IS NOW NEARING
COMPLETION. THE N. S. H. P.
PROGRAM PROVIDES INCENTIVES FOR
THE INTEGRATION OF SOLAR ENERGY
SYSTEMS THE NEW HOMES. THE
PROGRAM IS NO LONGER APPROVING
NEW PARTICIPATION. BUT WILL
CONTINUE TO COMPLETE PAYMENT OF
CLAIMS THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR. A SEVENTY
TWO POINT OH THREE MILLION
DOLLARS BEING REQUESTED FOR
REALLOCATION. OUR MONEY IS
PROVIDED TO THE M. S. H. P.
PROGRAM FROM THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES. ENCUMBERED THROUGH
PROJECT PRESERVATION. PRIOR TO
THE INCUMBENTS DEADLINE WHICH
WAS JUNE FIRST OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. ALTHOUGH RESERVATIONS
IDENTIFIED THE FUNDS WOULD BE
NEEDED FOR APPROVED PROJECTS.
DUE TO A NUMBER OF FACTORS
PAYMENT CLAIMS ASSOCIATED WITH
THESE PROJECTS HAVE
SUBSTANTIALLY DECLINED. AND
FIFTY STAFF NOW ANTICIPATE THAT
THEY ANTICIPATE THAT THE
IDENTIFIED FUNDS. WILL REMAIN
UNSPENT BY THE DISBURSEMENT
DEADLINE WHICH AGAIN IS
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE PROPOSED
REALLOCATION WOULD ALLOW THE
FUNDS TO BE USED TO ADDRESS
ADDITIONAL NEEDS PROPOSED BY
ADVOCATES INTO A NEW PROGRAM.
IN I. O. U. TERRITORY. AS WE
UNDERSTAND THE OTHER KIDS
PROPOSAL THE FIRST PROGRAM
WHICH WOULD RECEIVE 72% OF THE
FUNDS WOULD PROVIDE INCENTIVES
FOR GREEN SMART NEW HOMES.
INCLUDING EITHER COMES BUILT
WITH SOLAR AND STORAGE. OR
ALTERNATIVELY AN ALL ELECTRIC
HOME BUILT WITH SOLAR AND AT
LEAST ONE GREAT RESPONSIVE
TECHNOLOGIES. THE SECOND
PROPOSED PROGRAM RECEIVING 28%
OF THE FUND. WOULD PROVIDE
EDUCATION GRANTS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
EFFORTS TO ADOPT AUTOMATED
SOLAR AND STORAGE PERMITTING
SYSTEM. IMPLEMENT REMOTE
INSPECTION AND UNDERTAKE OTHER
EX AND OTHER EXPENDITURES THAT
SUPPORT THE REDUCTION OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
HOMES. BUILDING ON A STRONG
HISTORY OF SUCCESSFUL INCENTIVE
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION. THE
ENERGY COMMISSION IS WELL
POSITIONED TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAMS THAT PROPOSED. AND
WOULD BE INEFFICIENT
ADMINISTRATOR FOR THESE NEW
PROGRAMS SHOULD THE FUNDING
ALLOCATION BE APPROVED. IT'S
COMPLETE BY REMARKS AND I'M
HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS.
L. A. R. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
MISTER CHIRAC BROWN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THIS IS IN A PROPOSAL THAT WE
HAVE FIVE SPENT MUCH TIME
ANALYZING BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF IF IT'S AN
ISSUE THAT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPLORE GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU A FINANCE
SIDE ASSUME IS PROBABLY NOT A
REPORT. CORRECT HI THANK YOU WE
HAVEN'T SEEN INTO A POSITION AT
THIS TIME SO- IF I UNDERSTAND
IT CORRECTLY- THERE IS AN
INTEREST IN DISCUSSING THIS
THERE SIR THERE'S- NO
COMMITMENT TO- AGREEMENT- AND
THE SO I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
REITERATE WE CAN'T TAKE AN
ACTION ON THIS TODAY BUT I'D
LIKE TO REITERATE THAT- WE HAVE
AN INTEREST IN- EVERYONE
WORKING TOGETHER WITH THE
ADVOCATES TO SEE IF THERE'S
SOMETHING HERE THAT COULD BE
FLUSHED OUT. THAT'S WORKABLE TO
USE THE CELL SEVENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN UNSPENT
FUNDS. AND I THINK UP A WITH
THAT WE CAN NOW MOVE ON. TO OUR
NEXT ISSUE WHICH WILL BE. ISSUE
NINE IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN- LOCAL
STREETS AND ROADS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE I THINK WE'LL BE ABLE
TO MOVE THROUGH THE REST OF OUR
AGENDA RELATIVELY QUICKLY NOW.
THANK HEAR. FOR GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR BLOOMING MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY I AM
PLEASED TO TAYLOR CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. AS
BRIEF BACKGROUND THE COMMISSION
ISN'T INDEPENDENT STATE AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALLOCATING
FUNDS TO TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS WE HAVE TWELVE
COMMISSIONERS AND TWO NON
VOTING LEGISLATIVE EXHIBITION
COMMISSIONERS ONE OF WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN IT'S
GOOD TO SEE IT SAYING WE HOPE
YOU CAN JOIN US. AT OUR MEETING
NEXT WEEK. LET'S NOT THE
COMMISSION IS. TRAILER LANGUAGE
TO ADDRESS THE MAINTENANCE OF
EFFORT REQUIREMENT IN THE LOCAL
STREETS AND ROADS PROGRAM TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPACTS THAT THE
COPING NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
HAD ON CITY AND COUNTY GENERAL
FUNDS. AS BACKGROUND THE LOCAL
STREETS AROUND PROGRAM STATUS
BY SB ONE THE ROAD REPAIR AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. PROVIDES
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT ONE
BILLION ANNUALLY TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES FOR BASIC ROAD
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR REYES
STATUTORY FORMULA. ONE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO RECEIVE FUNDING IS
TO MAINTAIN THEIR GENERAL FUND
SPENDING A LOCAL STREETS AND
ROADS TO AT LEAST THE AVERAGE
THEY SPEND DURING THE FISCAL
YEAR NINE TEN. TEN ELEVEN
ELEVEN TWELVE SCHOOL YEARS. AT
THE START OF THE PANDEMIC IN
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY THE
COMMISSION BEGAN RECEIVING
FEEDBACK FROM CITIES AND
COUNTIES REGARDING THEIR
POTENTIAL AND ABILITY TO MEET
THE MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT
REQUIREMENTS. BECAUSE THEIR
GENERAL FUND REVENUES WERE
DECLINING AND THEY NEEDED TO
DEDICATE RENT. RESOURCES TO
ADDRESSING. THE NINETEEN
IMPACTS IN THE MONTH AFTERWARD
COMMISSION STAFF THE
FACILITATED NUMEROUS MEETINGS
WITH THE WORKGROUP CONSISTING
OF STAKEHOLDERS AND INDUSTRY
GROUPS TO DISCUSS THE EFFORT.
CONCLUDED THAT SUSPENDING THE
MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT
REQUIREMENT FOR THE NINETEEN
TWENTY FISCAL YEAR WAS
APPROPRIATE SINCE THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN SUDDENLY AND LEGISLATOR.
WAS ALREADY OVER. FURTHER
INCLUDING THAT FOR THE TWELVE
TWENTY AND ONE TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEARS THAT MAKE THEM SO
THAT REQUIREMENTS SHOULD BE
ADJUSTED EACH. AND PROPORTION
THE LAS ACCIONES BRAND SIX.
THIS APPROACH THAT CITIES AND
COUNTIES DO NOT LOSE CRITICAL
STATE FUNDS FOR THEIR ROADS
THROUGH NO TURNED AROUND. WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AS WE PREACH THAT
FINDING A GENDER. THANK YOU L.
A. O. OR- AND- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WARNING MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
MINUTES WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- THE PROPOSAL
RAISED NO CONCERNS FOR OFFICE
WE FIND IT REASONABLE TO
PROVIDE MAINTENANCE AFTER-
REDUCTIONS FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT HAVE SEEN REVENUE
LOSSES DUE TO THE PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE-
STEVE WELLS THE DEPARTMENTOF
FINANCE- WE AGREE THAT THIS-
THIS LANGUAGE IS NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE TEMPORARY RELIEF TO
LOCAL AGENCIES THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING A DISPROPORTIONATE
FISCAL ISSUES DURING A
PANDEMIC- WE ALL THINK THIS
LINE WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
CONTINUE TO DELIVER SB ONE
PROJECTS. AND SB ONE
MAINTENANCE WITHOUT
INTERRUPTION. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THE REPORTS IF
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS WILL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE TEN NOT SAYING ANY
QUESTION SO LET SILVA- MOVE ON
TO TEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
WE HAVE- OF THIS- ITEM ALSO IS
THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. THIS
IS THE- TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
WHAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
CHAIRMAN BLOOM AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS. THE RESPONSE OF
COMMONSENSE ADDISON CHIEF
DEPUTY SECRETARY OF BALANCE
THAT'S IT. IF THREE. EXCEPT
ABOUT THIS A BILL LANGUAGE THAT.
YOU KEEP BOTH A PERSPECTIVE ALL
IT STANDS OF THE IT REALLY
RELIEF MEASURES CONTAINED IN
BOSTON IF NINETY IN EIGHTY OF
SEVEN FOR ONE OCCASION PIECE
YEAR APPARENTLY WAITING
PENALTIES THAT ARE OF TO BE
ALLOCATED BOND FOR TO ACHIEVE
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO
OFFERING BECAUSE IN RECOVERING.
SECOND BILL REQUIRES THAT A
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION PROVIDER
REPORTS BY. IDENTIFYING HOW. TO
STREAMLINE THAT THEY SUBMIT
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE. WITH
REPORTING PERFORMANCE
MANAGEMENT REQUIREMENTS. THIRD
THE BILL SPECIFICALLY
SIMPLIFIES ALEX DEBILITY TASKS
RELATED TO AGENCIES SPENDING
STATE FUNDING OPERATIONS FOR
THOSE AGENCIES TO PROVIDE LOCAL
FUNDING LEVELS AT OR ABOVE
THOSE PROVIDED IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. THIS
OPENS THE DOOR TO MORE FUNDING
CERTAINTY AND FLEXIBILITY IN
HOW TO PROVIDE SERVICE TO ALL
PARTS NEED TO BE SORT OF A
TRANSIT OPERATOR. IN ADDITION
COURAGE BY THIS PROVISION MAY
NOT HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE UNDER
CURRENT DRAWBACKS RECOVERY
REQUIREMENTS. THE OUTCOMES OF
THESE PROVISIONS WILL BE
EVALUATED FOR EFFECTIVENESS
AFTER FIVE YEARS. FINALLY THE
BILL EXCLUDES WITH THE
CALCULATION OF FAREBOX RECOVERY
AND HAPPENING COST PER HOUR.
ACOSTA REQUIRING MANDATED
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITY ACT
SERVICE THE PROVISIONS OF THE
SERVICES DID NOT DOES NOT
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE ABILITY
TO PROVIDE FIXED ROUTE BUS
SERVICE. EXTRA SERVICES. IT
ALSO EXCLUDES MISCALCULATIONS
THE COST OF FLEXIBLE ROUTE
SERVICES SO THAT THERE IS MORE
OF A LIKE A CANDIDATE IN THE
EXPANSION OF SERVICE INTO NEW
AREAS OF THE COMMUNITY. I
CANNOT SUPPORT A FULL FIXED
ROUTE BUS SERVICE. IN SUMMARY
THIS BILL REDUCES THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT NEED TO BE
MAPPED FOR LOCAL TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
ALL OF THEIR FORMULA BASED
FUNDING. BY HAVING MORE
CERTAINTY THAT FUNDS CAN BE
SPENT ON OPERATIONS IN THE
COMING YEARS AGENCIES WILL BE
ABLE TO COMMIT TO FUNDING
CHOICES. THAT WILL REDUCE THE
PRESSURE TO FELLOW WORKERS AND
REDUCE SERVICES. AND ALSO
PROGRESSIVE INNOVATIVE WAYS OF
SERVING OUR ENTIRE COMMUNITY
WITH LOTS OF ALL SERVICE TYPE
FOR FIXED BROADBAND SERVICE. IS
NOT EFFECTIVE OR EFFICIENT THAT
SUMMARY. I'D BE GLAD TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU L. L.
ANY. THANK YOU CHAIR- WE DO NOT
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL THE LANGUAGE SEEMS
CONSISTENT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ACTION TAKEN LAST YEAR- ADS
COMMITTEE STAFF NOTED AN AGENDA
SOME OF THE REGULATORY RELIEF
THAT'S EXTEND FOR SEVERAL YEARS
SO THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
CONSIDER WHETHER SUCH DURATION
OF REGULATORY RELIEF ALLIANCE
AND WHAT THE IMPACTS IN
RECOVERY AFTER TRANSIT AGENCIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. I'LL BE CLEAR THAT
THIS PROPOSALS PRUDENT AND-
NECESSARY I WILL DRESS THE
CURRENT CONVICTED MOBILE OUT
FOR A- AND ADJUSTMENTS STORY
THAT ARE LIKELY TO OCCUR POST
THIS AMERICAN GRANT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY QUESTIONS SEEING
NONE. PER SHARE THE REPORT WE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE- THIRD
ISSUE WITH- DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION ISSUE ELEVEN A
HAZARDOUS MATERIAL REMOVAL AT
AND CAMP MONTHS. GOOD MORNING
CARE COLOGNE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS STEVEN
CHECK I'M THE CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
BETTER KNOWN TO MOST FOLKS IF
CALTRANS FROM OUR REQUEST TODAY
ON THIS ITEM IS FOR TWENTY
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
OPERATING EXPENSES FIND THIS
MATERIAL REMOVAL CONTRACTS.
CALTRANS ROLE USE THESE
CONTRACT RESOURCES AT
ENCAMPMENTS TO AID IN THE STATE
REMOVAL OF HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
WITHIN THE STATE RIGHT OF WAY-
AND THIS OCCURS PARTICULARLY
AND HEAVY HEAVILY. POPULATED
URBAN AREAS- ENCAMPMENTS POSE
QUITE SIGNIFICANT HEALTH AND
SAFETY RISKS TO CALTRANS
EMPLOYEE EASE TO OUR
CONTRACTORS OPERATING WITHIN
THE RIGHT AWAY AND ALSO TO THE
TRAVELING UP. SO REALLY THESE
RESOURCES WOULD BE USED ALONG
SIDE OF OUR OWN CREWS TO GO OUT
TO CLEAN UP ENCAMPMENTS AND
THEY WOULD BE REMOVING
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS- AND
DISPOSING OF IT IN A SAFE AND
LEGAL WAY- THESE CONTRACTORS IT
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT HAVE. THE
APPROPRIATE TRAINING OF
LICENSING- AND THE ABILITY TO
DO WHAT FRANKLY THE DEPARTMENT
CANNOT DO WHICH IS TO DEAL WITH
THE- MATERIALS APPROPRIATELY- I
RECOGNIZE THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE HAS-
RECOMMENDED THAT WARRANTED
REQUEST.
GRAHAM PERHAPS A DAY
WHEN WE NO LONGER NEED THESE
RESOURCES AND THE HOMELESS
ISSUE- IS LESS PROMINENT IN
WHAT WHERE DO. NECK INCLUDES BY
PRESENTATION ON THIS. THANK YOU
LMAO I THINK PART OF YOUR
REPORT WAS JUST MADE. YES SO-
INCREASING NUMBER OF THAT
CUSTOMER SERVICE REQUEST AS
WELL AS GROWING EXPENDITURES
INDICATES THAT THAT NEED FOR
HAZARDOUS MATERIAL REMOVAL HAS
RISEN SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE
PAST- SEVERAL YEARS RESULTING
IN THE ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD AND
THAT MR CACAS AND INDICATED
HOWEVER THE ESTIMATE OF THE
ANNUAL COST OF THAT HAZARDOUS
MATERIAL REMOVAL IS BASED ON
THE EXPENDITURES OF ABOUT
TWENTY WEEKS OF CONTRACT
SERVICES FROM- NOVEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN TWO FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY. I AM IN DEPARTMENT USED
EXPENDITURE RATE FROM A LIMITED
PERIOD OF TIME BECAUSE THE
PANDEMIC HAS LIMITED CLEAN UP
ACTIVITY AT IN THE MONTHS
FOLLOWING FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY AND SO HOWEVER
INCOMPLETE- ANNUAL EXPENDITURE
DATA MIGHT IN ACCURATELY
CAPTURE THE COST OF SERVICES
FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR SO FOR
EXAMPLE AN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THE LAST YEAR FOR WHICH WE HAVE
COMPLETE ANNUAL DATA HOW
TRANSPLANT ABOUT FOURTEEN POINT
NINE MILLION ON IN CAMEROON
FALL WHICH IS STILL LESS THAN
THE AMOUNT REQUESTED IN THE
PROPOSAL BY SEVERAL MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS SANTA FE RENDON
CERTAINTY AROUND THE ON GOING
COSTS OF HAZARDOUS MATERIAL
REMOVAL WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED- TWO YEAR
LIMITED TERM FUNDING. FOR THANK
YOU FIND. BENJAMIN PAUL
PARTMINER FINANCE- I WOULD ECHO
THE MADE WE DO SEE THE RESOURCE
THE NEEDED FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE- BUT WE CAN DEFINITELY
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
MONITOR EXPENDITURE LEVELS AND
DISCUSS IN TWO YEARS. THANK
YOU- I WOULD LIKE TO REITERATE.
THAT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S CERTAINLY AN
ISSUE IN MY DISTRICT WHERE I
GET CALLS ON A FAIRLY REGULAR
BASIS- FOR HELP AND- SOMETIMES
IT TAKES A LONG LONG TIME
BEFORE THAT HEALTH IS HELP IS.
FORTHCOMING SO I SINCERELY HOPE
THAT THIS FUNDING HELPS ADDRESS
THAT- SPECIFIC ISSUE WHICH SHOT
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK IS GOING
TO BE WITH US FOR LONGER THAN
TWO YEARS- BUT- THAT SAID THAT
THAT JUST POINTS OUT THAT
THERE'S- SO MUCH MORE WORK TO
BE DONE ON THE ISSUE OF-
ADDRESSING- OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING. HOMELESSNESS WITH
THAT- A COMMENT FROM MEMBERS
RIVAS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
YOU KNOW IN MY DISTRICT TO IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY OF LOS
ANGELES- THIS IS ONE OF THE
MAJOR ISSUES AND ONE OF THE
NUMBER ONE REASONS I GET CALLS
IN MY DISTRICT OFFICE- THEY ARE
YOU KNOW CONSTITUENTS- WORKING
TO. OUR IRAQ SUBMIT A CUSTOMER
SERVICE REQUEST ABOUT- YOU KNOW
THESE HAZARDOUS MATERIAL ALONG
OUR HIGHWAYS IN THE DISTRICT OF
AND SO MY QUESTION AND YOU KNOW
I'VE I'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH CALTRANS
DISTRICT SEVEN- AND OTHERS HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AND A LOT OF
TIMES I HEAR WHAT WE DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES- TO CLEAN UP
THESE AREAS- SO WHAT DOES THIS
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS COVER IS
THIS. FOR THE CURRENT- CSR
REQUEST THAT YOU MENTION THAT-
YOU HAVE SEVENTY FOUR HUNDRED
I'M I'M JUST NOT CLEAR IF THESE
ARE OPEN REQUESTS OR THAT'S
JUST HOW MANY RECEIVED IN THAT.
YEAR. THANK YOU A MEMBER OF
THIS SO THE- THE SHORT ANSWER
TO THAT QUESTION THE SEVENTY
FOUR HUNDRED IS AN ANNUAL
NUMBER HOW MANY SERVICE
REQUESTS RECEIVED ABOUT
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS. WHAT THIS
SPECIFIC FUNDING DOES IT ALLOWS
US TO FULLY FIND ANY HAZARDOUS
WASTE REMOVAL THAT WE NEED
DONE. ARE AND WHAT WE HAVE DONE
UP UNTIL THIS POINT IS HAD TO
RE DIRECT OUR OWN- OTHER
RESOURCES WITHIN THE
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM YOU HAD TO
RE DIRECTED TOWARDS HAZMAT
REMOVAL. SO WHAT WITH THIS NEW
RESOURCE WE WILL NO LONGER HAVE
TO DO THAT AND WE CAN BRING
THOSE RESOURCES BACK TO THE
BASICS OF- ENCAMPMENT CLEAN UP
THE WORK THAT OUR EMPLOYEES
GENERALLY DO. SO REALLY THIS
WILL PROVIDE THOSE HAS MET
SERVICES AND ALLOW US TO RE
DIRECTOR FUNDING BACK TOWARDS
OF THE WORK THAT WE DO WITH IT
WITH THE CAP. OKAY WHY HOPE
THEN THAT I WILL HEAR THAT-
FROM MY LOCAL CALTRANS
MAINTENANCE. THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES YOU KNOW
ONCE WE APPROVE THIS FUNDING-
BECAUSE THAT'S BEEN THE BIGGEST
ISSUE AND- YOU KNOW THEY HAVE.
RESPONDED TO ME THAT THEY DON'T
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE IN THE
BUSINESS. OF CLEANING UP-
THESE- HAZARDOUS MATERIAL ALONG
OUR HIGHWAYS. AND SO THIS IS
WHAT THEN I WILL BE EXPECTING
IS WE HAVE PROVIDED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES- SO THEREFORE OURS.
CS OURS SHOULD BE RESPONDED TO
IN A- IN A TIMELY MANNER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I DO WANT TO BE
SURE THAT- THAT THE SPENDING IS
GOING TO BE EQUITABLY AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT THE- THE STATE- NOT
JUST IN CERTAIN AREAS OF THE
STATE CAN YOU. ASSURE US OF
THAT. CERTAINLY YEAH CARE
BERMAN THIS RESOURCE WILL BE-
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS THE STATE IN
EVERY DISTRICT- IT WILL NOT BE
DISTRIBUTED EVENLY ACROSS
DISTRICTS OF COURSE BECAUSE THE
NEED IS NOT THE SAME. BUT WE
WILL- DISTRIBUTE THE FUNDING IN
IN ALL AREAS OF THE STATE OR
HAZARDOUS WASTE MATERIAL
REMOVAL WHERE IT IS NECESSARY-
WE ENVISION- TO NEW HAZMAT
CONTRACTS FOR EACH DISTRICTS TO
ALLOW US TO MEET THE DEMANDS-
AS UP. AT US STRIKES ME THAT
THERE'S- PROBABLY- A BACKLOG
OF- OF REQUESTS IN THIS REGARD
SO- THIS FUNDING IS INTENDED TO
HELP CLEAR UP THE BACKLOG OR
JUST KIND OF A YOU KNOW-
MAINTAIN A BASIC LEVEL OF
SERVICE. ORGANICALLY THANK.
THAT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION SO
THE REQUEST IS BASED ON AS WITH
GEN BY THE LEGISLATIVE
BASED ON A PRE CODED PERIOD
THAT WE HAD FROM THE TIME WHEN
WE STARTED USING HAS MATT
CONTRACTS TO DEAL WITH THIS
ISSUE- AND WIN THE COVETED
ENDEMIC STARTED IN FEBRUARY OF
LAST YEAR. SO- WILL NOT BE A
BIG BACKLOG WHEN WE GET BACK
INTO. THE CAMPS IN AND BEGIN
THIS WORK MORE IN EARNEST AFTER
THE AFTER THE PANDEMIC THERE
THERE MAY BE. BUT THE REQUEST
ITSELF IS BASED ON. AS WAS
MENTIONED THE LIMITED DATA THAT
WE HAD FROM BEFORE THE KOBE
PERIOD. SO IT REMAINS TO BE
SEEN HOW MUCH OF A BACKLOG AND
WHAT WHAT CHALLENGES WE WILL
FACE AGAIN ANOTHER- ANOTHER
BANDIT. IT LIMITED TERM
APPROPRIATIONS THAT WILL HAVE A
CHANCE TO REASSESS THAT- AT THE
END OF THE TWO YEAR PERIOD WELL
A TH WAITING TWO YEARS TO
FIGURE THIS OUT AS AS- NOT
WERE. FRANKLY ACCEPTABLE AT IN
MY VIEW THERE MUST BE A WAY- F.
AM I UNDERSTANDING CORRECTLY
THAT THE WORK ON. THE WORK THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WILL NOT
COMMENCE UNTIL- EIGHT. CERTAIN
MATRIKAS MAN MATT WITH RESPECT
TO THE PANDEMIC. NO SIR WHAT I
WAS TRYING TO INDICATE IS THAT
WE HAVE IN AND MANY ARE- AREAS
CURTAILED- THE NUMBER OF CAMPS
THAT WE'RE ABLE TO CLEAR
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC FOR THE
SAFETY OF OUR OWN CREWS AND FOR
A BI- ALMOST INDIVIDUALS THAT
LIVE THERE SO YOU MUST HAVE AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE- CURRENT.
NUMBER OF REQUESTS AND
ENCAMPMENTS THAT TO NEED YOUR
ATTENTION. OF IS THE FUNDING
SUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS THOSE AND
THEN ALSO KEEP UP WITH THE
ANTICIPATED WORKLOAD BEYOND.
BECAUSE OF AN ART LET ME JUST
SAY IF IT'S NOT I WILL ADVOCATE
FOR PUTTING MORE MONEY IN THE
POT FOR YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT AND I WILL
I WILL SAY THIS IN RESPONSE. WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET BACK OUT
INTO THE ENCAMPMENTS AND DO
THAT KIND OF ASSESSMENT THAT
DETAILED ASSESSMENT OF THE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO GET DONE. OKAY
TRANSACTION LET ME- I GOTTA
MOVE THIS MEETING ALONG AND
WE'RE NOT TAKING ACTION TODAY.
THIS IS GOING TO COME BACK
AFTER MAY REVISE. PLEASE DO
THAT ASSESSMENT IN THE INTERIM
COME BACK WITH THAT INFORMATION
I WILL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN- WHATEVER AMOUNT IT
TAKES. DOESN'T YOU KNOW GIVEN
THE FUNDING LEVEL HERE IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT'S GOING TO
BE AN OUTRAGEOUS AMOUNT OF
ADDITIONAL MONEY. BUT IF IT
DOES TAKE MORE MONEY. THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE. WANTS TO
ENTERTAIN THAT. AS A
POSSIBILITY. FOR FUNDING.
UNDERSTOOD OKAY THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I DON'T MEAN TO BE
SHORT WITH YOU BUT I DO WANNA
GET PROTECTED WELL ENOUGH WE
CAN GET BACK ON TRACK HERE BUT-
LET'S MOVE FORWARD- WITH THE
ISSUE TWELVE. THANK YOU AGAIN.
CERTAINLY IT'S ALL RE INTRODUCE
MYSELF FOR THE RECORD- I'M
STEVEN TACT CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION- AND OUR SECOND
ITEM TODAY IS A OF REQUEST FOR
A ONE TIME INCREASE AT SEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS-
AND NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION. ON GOING. FOR
OFFICE SPACE MODIFICATIONS AND
FOR MOBILE WORKFORCE
TECHNOLOGY. A TURN HAND
SYMBILITY OF CALTRANS TO
TELEWORK AND TO FURTHER EXPLORE
INNOVATIONS RELATED TO HOUSING
EMPLOYEES- OUTSIDE OF OUR
CURRENT OFFICE BUILDINGS. THIS
REQUEST IS THE SECOND AND FINAL
REQUEST RELATED HOUSING
ADDITIONAL EMPLOYEES THAT WERE-
THAT WERE HIRED AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE HIRED. TO
PROVIDE- BUT WORK NECESSARY TO
CARRY OUT THE GOALS OF SENATE
BILL ONE. SO WE STARTED THIS
JOURNEY- LOOKING ON HOW TO BEST
MAXIMIZE OUR SPACE PRIOR TO THE
CUPBOARD PANDEMIC. AND REALLY
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO
UTILIZE OUR EXISTING FOOTPRINT
OF THE BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE
TO HOUSE MORE EMPLOYEES BY
EXPLORING OPTIONS OF A
TELEWORKING. AND TELLING AND
OTHER- INNOVATIVE IDEA. AND
WHEN KOBE CAME ALONG- QUITE
UNEXPECTEDLY DESPITE ALL THE
CHALLENGES WE'VE HAD TO FACE
IT'S ALSO BEEN AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR L. TRAINS. AND REALLY LOTS
OF DEPARTMENTS TO DEMONSTRATE
PH<c.cyan>ARKING A LARGE SCALE CAN</c>
WORK. IF WE WEREN'T QUITE
PREPARED TO TAKE ON SUCH A TASK
QUITE SO QUICKLY BUT WE'VE
PROVEN THAT IT CAN WORK- SO.
APPROACHING. OFFICE SPACE
MODIFICATIONS AND WORKFORCE
MOBILITY REALLY HELPS US TO
KEEP DOWN OUR OVERALL CAPITAL
OUTLAY CONSTANT FACTOR OR OR-
R. COSTA RELEASING NEW
FACILITIES. AND SERVICE THE
RELATIVELY SMALL INVESTMENT
WILL ACTUALLY KEEP US FOR HELP
KEEP US FROM HAVING TO DO MORE
EXPENSIVE- DISABILITIES UPDATES
IN THE FUTURE THE HOUSE MORE
PLEASE. GREAT NO CAN YOU CAN
YOU WRAP UP PLEASE. ALL RIGHT
UP RIGHT THERE PERFECT THANK
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING MY
CUE OF- DO WE AVE A- IMPORTANT
REPORT FROM THE- ALEJO. HELLO
YOU MISTER ODELL OUT WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY CONCERNS OF THIS
PARTICULAR EVERY EVERYTHING YOU
TELL US IS IMPORTANT TO FORGIVE
ME FOR IMPLYING OTHERWISE- AND-
FINANCE. J. WAS MORE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AS A
STATED EARLIER WE'VE BEEN
WORKING FOR A COUPLE YEARS WITH
CALTRANS ON THIS ISSUE- AND
THIS PROPOSAL ALIGNS ABOUT WORK
AND- WE FEEL IT'S A PRUDENT
STEP THE ROLLOUT EXPANDED
TELEWORK AND OTHER INNOVATIVE
OFFICE SPACE SOLUTIONS. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL TAKE
A- THAT ITEM UNDER ADVISEMENT
ALONG WITH EVERYTHING ELSE ON
THIS AGENDA AND MOVE ON TO. OUR
HIGHWAY PATROL ITEM- THAT IS
ACTUALLY A COUPLE OF THEM MAYBE
WE CAN COMBINE THEM- INTO- THE
SAME ITEM LET'S DO ISSUES
THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN. TOGETHER
WILL THAT WORK FOR YOU MISTER
ALVAREZ DO WE HAVE YOUR. YES
YOU HAVE HOME RIGHT NOW REYES
WHO IS OVER MY OFFICE THE
SPECIAL NOTES AND I'M
COMMISSIONER MANDRAKE SO YES WE
CAN DEFINITELY. COMBINED
IDENTIFYING DO WHATEVER YOU
LIKE THANK YOU YOUR VOICE IS A
LITTLE BIT FAINT IF YOU COULD
SPEAK UP BY THAT WILL HELP US.
HEY DON'T YELL AT US OKAY BUT A
LITTLE HARD TO HEAR YOU READY.
YEAH THAT'S BETTER MUCH BETTER
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. OKAY HI
GOOD AFTERNOON JEREMY BLOOM THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AS I
STATED ON COMMISSIONERATE. AND
I APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
DISCUSS THE C. H. P. BUDGET-
ALSO WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFFER HELPING TO
PREPARE FOR THIS HEARING TODAY.
WE HAVE THREE OPEN BUDGETARY
PROPOSALS THAT I HOPE YOU WILL
SUPPORT. EACH ONE IS VERY
CRITICAL TO OUR MISSION OF
PROVIDING SAFETY SERVICE AND
SECURITY TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
SO I'M GOING TO BEGIN WITH- HE
P. ISSUE THIRTEEN. WHICH IS
OUR- RADIO. CONSOLE REPLACEMENT
PROJECT. IF YOU CAN USE. A MODE
YEAR BY OFFICE. FROM THE MORE
VEHICLE. TO ADDRESS BECAUSE
THINK ASSOCIATED WITH THE RADIO
CONSOLE REPLACING PROJECT. THE
FIVE WAS APPROVED FISCAL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY NINETEEN.
THE RADIO CONSOLE REPLACEMENT
WORK IS BEING COMPLETED BY THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS OR PSE. THIS
CURRENTLY THINKING REQUEST AN
ARGUMENT BECOME TWO POINT TWO
SEVEN ONE MILLION. IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
TWENTY TWO AND AUGMENTATION OF
TWO POINT TWO TWO THREE MILLION
I FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE- THIS IS YOU KNOW THE
SAFETY WE OPERATE TWENTY FIVE
EMERGENCY COMMUNICATIONS
CENTERS. INTO TRAINING CENTERS.
ALL COMMUNICATIONS CENTERS ARE
EQUIPPED WITH RADIO COUNCIL
SYSTEMS WHICH PROVIDE MISSION
CRITICAL VOICE COMMUNICATION.
BETWEEN THE CHP DISPATCHERS
FIELD OFFICES IT OFFICERS. AND
OUR ALLIES AGENCY PARTNERS. THE
EIGHTEEN EXIST RADIO CALL BY
ACT. THERE WILL BE SIR LIFE.
AND THERE ARE SOME. SOME OF OUR
ACCOUNTS SYSTEM FOR OVER SEVEN
YEARS AGO AND INSTALL BETWEEN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR AND TWENTY
THOUSAND TO. AND MOST HAVE BEEN
IN SERVICE FOR WELL OVER TWENTY
YEARS. THE RADIO CONSOLE
REPLACEMENT FRIDAY HE BEGAN
WITH THE STATE HE WE DEVELOPED
AND ADOPT A SET OF SPECIFIC
AGENTS IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE PSE. AND INNER TALK WITH
THE EQUIPMENT VENDOR. AWARDED
THE CONTRACT AFTER A
COMPETITIVE BID PROCESS.
FOLLOWING THE SUCCESSFUL
COUNCIL PILOT PROJECT WITH THE
EIGHT PM PST ENDEAVOR TO ROLL
OUT THE NEW INTERTOTO SYSTEM
STATEWIDE. THE NEW RADIO
CONSOLES THEY'RE INTERCONNECTED
BETWEEN THIS CENTERS TO ALLOW
CHANNEL IN WORKFLOW SHARING.
THIS FUNCTION BUT NOT EXIST AND
ANTIQUATED SYSTEMS THERE WILL
BE THAT WE WANT TO REPLACE. WE
HAVE SEVENTEEN REMAINING
COMMUNICATIONS CENTER IS
SCHEDULED FOR INSTALLATION. WE
WILL BE INSTALLING THIS NEW
SYSTEM AT THE GOLDEN GATE
COMMUNICATION SYSTEM WHICH IS
OUR SECOND LARGEST LOCATION IN
APRIL OF THIS YEAR. WE
ANTICIPATE COMPLETION OF THE
REMAINING INSTALLATION OF THE
RING VIDEO CONSOLES IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
THE CRITICAL NEED FOR THE RADIO
CONSOLE REPLACEMENT PROJECT TO
CONTINUE EVERYTHING YOU'D
ADEQUATE FUNDING CANNOT BE
UNDERSTATED. AS FIFTY WE
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
FAILURES THE END OF THE SYSTEM.
WHEN RADIO CONSOLES BAIL
PROSPEROUS RECEIVER NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEM CANNOT BE PROPERLY
COMMUNICATED TO FILL PATROL
OFFICER. BY DISPATCHERS IN THIS
SCENARIO REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
DISPLACING OR SPEAK UP THE
EXTRA CALL VOLUME. ADDITIONALLY
A LARGE BENEFIT TO THIS NEW
SYSTEM IS THE ENHANCE
COMMUNICATIONS WHAT OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY PARTNERS WITH FIFTY
HELLO YES AND CALTRANS FOR
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY. WITH A
NEW INNER TALK SYSTEMS. THE C.
A. T. S. ADDED NEW CAN RADIO
TO. AS SEVERAL COMMUNITY CENTER
TO AND RAY COMMITTEE. DURING
EMERGENCY INCIDENTS THIS
UNIFORMITY AND QUICKNESS
STANDARDIZATION BETWEEN THE
AGENCIES ELEVATES THE CHP'S
ABILITY. STEP PROVIDE MORE
EFFICIENT SUPPORT DURING
EMERGENCIES AND DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS SO THANK YOU- SEARCH
FOR PROVIDING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE
INTRODUCE OUR THAT OUR RADIO
CONSOLE THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU KNOW COMMISSIONER IF
YOU COULD JUST ROLL RIGHT INTO
ISSUE FOURTEEN AND- AS WELL
ISSUE- FIFTEEN- THAT WOULD BE
GREAT ANALYTICA. OF THE OTHERS
TO CHIME IN AS NEEDED ON THE
THREE ITEMS. OKAY THANK YOU SIR
HEY SO- NUMBER FOURTEEN IS OUR
REPLACEMENT OF OUR PORTABLE
RADIOS. AND IF YOU CAN REQUEST
A PERMANENT AUGMENTATION OF
EIGHT POINT SIX ZERO FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FROM
THE MOTOR VEHICLE OUT. OF THESE
PORTABLE RADIOS AND ACCESSORIES
THAT HAVE EXCEEDED THEIR LIFE
EXPECTANCY ARE OUT OF WARRANTY
OR UNSERVICEABLE. AND PORTABLE
RADIO IS VITAL TO OUR MISSION
AND A CRITICAL LINK BETWEEN
OFFICERS IN THE FIELD AND
DISPATCHERS ANNA ALLEN AGENCY
PARTNERS. IN FISCAL YEAR
FIFTEENTH TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. HELLO WE PURCHASE EACH
CAN BE PURCHASED EIGHT THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
MOTOROLA. AT EXPORTABLE MULTI
BAND RADIOS AS WELL AS
SUFFICIENT ACCESSORIES TO
DEPLOY TWO UNIFORMED STAFF. THE
MOTOROLA ATRIX LIKE HAVE A LIFE
EXPECTANCY OF FIVE TO SEVEN
YEARS. DEPENDING ON. THE MOLD
OF OPERATIONAL ENVIRONMENT. THE
MOTOROLA IS TO GET AS PER TO BE
A RELY AND DURABLE POWER RATE.
HOWEVER THE PORT RADIO HAVE
BEEN IN THE FIELD SINCE EARLY
TWENTY FIFTH HE AND ARE
STARTING TO SHOW SIGNS OF WEAR
DUE TO THEIR TWENTY FOUR SEVEN.
USED IN A WIDE VARIETY OF
OPERATIONAL ENVIRONMENTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE SAFETY
EXISTING STOCK EXCESSIVE
RESPECT HIS BATTERY THAN TENNIS.
IN THE PALE MICROPHONES OR IS
IT. WELL THE SUPPORT CONTINUING
TERRORIST NEEDS. ALSO SIX TO
REPLACE ONE THOUSAND HUNDRED
THIRTY PORTABLE RADIO ON AN
ANNUAL. AND IT'S FIGURE EQUATES
TO A THIRTY REPLACEMENT
APPROXIMATELY 20% OF THE
DEPARTMENT INITIAL INVENTORY
BUT IT'S A PRO FINDING SIXTY
SIX TO ESTABLISH A FIVE YEAR
REPLACEMENT STUDY TO MEET BOTH
SNL AND ONGOING REPLACEMENT
NEEDS AS WELL AS HAVING A
READILY AVAILABLE REPLACEMENT
SUPPLY GREAT I THINK IT'S-
PROBABLY. NOT DOES THAT ABOUT
COVER IT. PRETTY MUCH BUT WE
HAVE TO DO FACTOR OVER WHEN IT
THEIR ACT AXLE THAT WOULD NEED
TO AND WE YOU A WHAT. THANK YOU
SACRAMENTO. WHAT IS YOUR
FIFTEEN. OKAY NUMBER OKAY IS
FOR OUR WAY IN CAR CAN SYSTEM
THE MAIN AND OPERATION SUPPORT
AND C. H. P. IS REQUESTING A
PERMANENT AUGMENTATION OF
FOURTEEN POINT TWO TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE MOTOR VEHICLE
COUNT FOR THE ONGOING
MAINTENANCE NOT RACES OF OUR
WIRELESS IN CAR CAMERA SYSTEM
ALSO KNOWN AS WARRANTED M.
BARTH ARE JUST IN W. M. BARS
WITH A LOCAL FROM HERE. SO THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AUTHORIZED GROUP POSITIONS IN
FIFTY TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO ADDRESS A THREE YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION OF CAT'S
WIRELESS IN CAR CAMERA SYSTEM
IS CURRENTLY SEEKING. IT
INTENDED TO FIND THE ONGOING
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION OF
THE STEADY THEY ALREADY
APPROVED W. OF OURS AS WELL AS
COVER YOUNG GOING BECAUSE OF
THE TWELVE PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
POSITIONS- IT W. M. ARE THREE
PLACES ARE CURRENT DVD THE CARD
SYSTEM WHAT THE MARKET IS IN
HER SYSTEM WHICH ELIMINATES THE
ANTIQUATED USE OF COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH DVD RECORDINGS.
AND THE W. M. R. ALLOWS FOR-
HIGHER QUALITY RECORDINGS IN
AUTOMATIC WIRELESS DATA
TRANSFER USING CELLULAR MODEL
MODEMS AND WIFI CONNECTIVITY
SO- AND A NICE BY PRODUCT OF
THE W. INVITED THAT IT ALSO HAS
THE ABILITY TO INTEGRATE MY
BODY WORN CAMERA SYSTEMS IN THE
FUTURE. SO I THINK THAT'S
PRETTY MUCH IT IS BASICALLY THE
ONGOING PROCESS OF THE ATM
MARKET WE HAVE. MOVING INTO
WIRELESS SYSTEM. GREAT YOU VERY
MUCH DOES. LMAO ANYTHING. THAT
MEANS YEAH. YES HI THAT IS
EUNICE ROUTE WITHOUT A- AT WE
DON'T- CONCERNED WITH THESE
PROPOSALS WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO
NOTE THAT YET- ALTHOUGH THAT
RADIO CONSOLE- REPLACING
PROJECT DOES NOT HAVE AN
ONGOING IMPACT TO THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT AND THAT
PORTABLE RADIOS AND THAT HAVE
IN CAR CAMERA SYSTEMS DO- BUT
GIVEN YOU KNOW THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE PORTABLE RADIOS IN
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNICATION AND
IMPORTANCE OF PROPER AND
EFFICIENT DOCUMENTATION OF DATA
FOR ANYTHING CAR CAMERA SYSTEMS
ONGOING COSTS- SEEM JUSTIFIED.
THANK YOU BERMAN IF. CATHY
MCLEOD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
NOTE YOURCONCERNS WITH THE MBA
AND WANT TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
CONTINUALLY MONITORING THE
STATUS OF THE MBA AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON SOLUTIONS GREAT
THANK YOU FOR THAT-
APPRECIATED- COMMISSIONER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SORRY TO- BE
MOVING THINGS ALONG BUT WE'RE
RUNNING WAY BEHIND SCHEDULE
HERE SO- I- AGAIN APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON NOW
TO CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY- WE HAVE. TWO ITEMS-
I THINK- THE CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER BRIAN ANNIS IS GOING TO
PRESENT ON BOTH OF THOSE. AND
IT A- TO HAVE ONE OR TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR WE HAVE TO THANK
YOU MISTER ADAMS WELCOME IF YOU
COULD CONSOLIDATE DAY REPORT
KEEP IT SHORT- THIS MAY BE THE
ONLY HEARING EVER ON HIGH SPEED
RAIL WHERE THERE'S NOBODY
WAITING IN THE ROOM HERE TO.
ASK YOU QUESTIONS- OR TALK
ABOUT THE PROJECT I WILL I WILL
ENJOY IT WILL IMPACT GRAVITY
THANK YOU MR HERE- AGAIN MY
NAME'S BRIAN ANNIS AND THE
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY. AS THE STAFF AGENDA
NOTES THE PROPERTY FUND IS
ESTABLISHED IN STATE LAW FOR
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL THAT YOU
DEPOSIT REVENUES RECEIVED
THROUGH THE AUTHORITIES
OWNERSHIP OF PROPERTY. STATUE
ALSO DIRECTS EXPENDITURES OF
THESE REVENUES FOR USE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT IMPROVEMENT AND
MAINTENANCE OF THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL SYSTEM CONSISTENT WITH THE
APPROPRIATE USES FOR EACH
FUNDING SOURCE NOW WITH HIS
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL THE
AUTHORITY REQUEST TO INCREASE
THE ANNUAL BUDGET AFTER
CORPORATION FROM THIS FUND FROM
SEVEN HUNDRED AND. FIFTY
THOUSAND TO FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS. QUESTIONS DUE TO FRONT
BALLOTS GO TO TEN DOLLAR. IN
THE AUTHORITY FUTURE EXPENSES
RELATED TO PROPERTY AT OR
EXCEEDING FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR. MCCARTY HAS
HISTORICALLY USED THESE BONDS
FOR COST RELATED TO PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO PRIORITIZE THESE
EXPENDITURES FOR THAT PURPOSE.
I CAN GO ON TO THE SECOND.
AREA
TO THE ON GOING SUCCESS OF THE
PROGRAM. THIS IS THE THIRD AND
FINAL. OF I. T. TRANSITION FROM
CONSOLES TO A STATE STAFF AND
OF COURSE LAST YEAR WE HAD A
BROADER DEPARTMENT WIDE
TRANSITION. OF FROM. CONSOLES
TO STATE STAFF AS WELL WE
CALLED OUR FORM TO FUNCTION
PROPOSAL. AND WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE REVIEW OF THESE
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
L. A. COM. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRYAN
BROWN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DIDN'T HAVE
ANY CONCERN WITH EITHER OF
THESE TWO PROPOSAL I WITH IRAQ
TO THE PROPERTY FIND TO FIND
OUT HAVE A SUFFICIENT FUND
BALANCE TO. HANDLE THE
INCREASED APPROPRIATION REQUEST
BOTH IN THE NEAR TERM AND I'M
GOING IN WITH REGARD TO THE
OFFICE TRANSITION
ADMINISTRATION AS NOTED THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH BOTH
LEGISLATIVE ACTION EACH OF THE
LAST FEW YEARS AS WELL AS WITH
THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS- MAGNITUDE OF
THE PROBLEM FINANCE IN REGARD
TO THE- PROPERTY FUND PROPOSAL-
THESE ARE COSTS THAT HIGH SPEED
ROAD HAVE WILL COME TO HAVE-
AND THEREFORE. AFTER APPROVAL
THIS FOR HIGH STREET RAIL.
WOULD LIKE USE THEIR OTHER
SOURCES INCLUDING PROPER ABLE-
IN REGARDS THE I. T. PROPOSAL
IT IS CONSERVE WITH THE-
ACCOUNT STATE OUT OF DIRECT. TO
LESS ON COUNTRY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS- AND SO THAT BRINGS
US TO THE CONCLUSION OF THE-
PRESENTATIONS BEFORE US TODAY
WE HAVE AHEAD OF US PUBLIC
COMMENT AND OTHERS NOBODY IN
THE ROOM WHO IS WAITING TO GET
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE ROOM SO
WE WILL MOVE TO THE- PHONE
LINES. AGAIN IF YOU DO- WANT TO
ADD YOUR COMMENTS TO- THIS
AFTERNOON TO OUR HEARING THE A
TOLL FREE NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE THAT YOU NEED TO
USE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN IF YOU HAVE ANY
PROBLEM AT ALL PLEASE CALL NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
209-991-6319 TWO ZERO NINE NINE
IF YOU'D LIKE TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY. THAT SHOULD
GO TO- IN EMAIL FORM TO BUDGET
SUB THREE NUMERAL THREE BUDGET
SUB THREE ASKED. ASM DOT CA DOT
GOV. AND THE OPERATOR- ARE YOU
THERE. IS MISTER CHAIR GREAT-
HOW MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE
WAITING TO TESTIFY. CURRENTLY
WE HAVE SEVENTEEN. LET'S HAVE
AT IT. YOU AS A REMINDER IF YOU
HAVE NOT ALREADY DONE SO ME
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE LET ME PLACE YOU IN CUE
ALL REMOVE YOU. FROM Q. AND
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND
PLEASE REMEMBER OUT OF LONDON
LIMIT TO A PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE'RE GONNA LINE THIRTEEN ONE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ST THE COOK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION
OUR MEMBERS CAN TESTIFY FUEL
PROVIDERS HYDROGEN STATION
DEVELOPERS AND BE ACCOMPANIED.
EACH HEAVILY INVESTING IN
HYDROGEN MOBILITY WE SUPPORTER
RE AUTHORIZATION OF THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM BUT IT
TODAY'S COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THE PLAN PROPOSES A
SHIFT TOWARDS CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. ALL OF WHICH
FUELING AND RECEIVED ONLY PER
OF DAHLE. BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
THE ONLY PRO OUTSIDE OF THE
THAT THE TO DEVELOP OF TIGER
FUELING AND PRESSURE. NOW MORE
THAN EVER BEFORE THAT THE NEEDS
TO APPROACH OUR BACK INTO
TECHNO NEUTRAL WAY TO BUT AN
ACT AND CONVENE FEELING ACCESS
IN A CRAFT CONSCIOUS WAY. I
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBER FOR
THE TODAY ABOUT TIGER VEHICLE.
BECAUSE OF THE DECISION LIKE
THAT ONE RIGHT NOW THAT SIGNAL
TO ALL. WHAT KIND OF OWN
MISSION VEHICLES THE STATE ONE
TO BE ABOUT BLACKS ABOUT AND WE
ARE REQUEST FIVE HOW MILLION OF
THE ONE BEGAN BE DEDICATED TO.
ALLOW US TO DO THINGS FIRST
PROVIDING KEVIN HOW LIKE TO GET
STATION ONE HUNDRED THREE AND
YOUR CARD HAVE YOU DO STATION.
AND CORRUPT NOT FIND. NINE ONE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI BILL
MCGAVIN WITH THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR ALSO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF OUR PARTNERS IN THE
CHARGE HAD CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN
COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
BUDGET PROPOSAL WE AGREED WITH
THE PRIORITY IT PLACES ON
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY. AND I'M
CLEANING UP HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
WE NEED TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
CLEAN MOBILITY TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND THE EQUITY
PROJECTS LIKE CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL IN CLEAN VEHICLE- FINANCING
AND CREAM ABILITY OPTIONS ARE
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND IN NEED OF
MORE FUNDING. WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE RE AUTHORIZATION THE QUEEN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION'S
ASKED ME TO ADD THEIR SUPPORT
THAT INCLUDES THE AIR QUALITY
INCENTIVE FUNDING LIKE THE CARL
MOYER AND AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAMS. AS WELL
AS THE CRUCIAL INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR- ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
WHICH WE NEED TO MAKE SURE IS
AVAILABLE TO ALL COMMUNITIES
AND I WILL. JUST CONCLUDE WITH
ONE POINT WHICH RESPONSE IN
PART TO SOMETHING MR CHANG SAID
WE WOULD SUPPORT A POLICY
CHANGES TO RESTRICT THE ENHANCE
WEED MODERNIZATION PROGRAM TO
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES ONLY WE
THINK IT'S TIME TO MAKE THAT
UPDATE THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWENTY TWO ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL EXACTLY DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING EIGHTY
FIVE TRANSIT AND RAIL AGENCIES
STATEWIDE. SPEAKING TODAY ON
THE ISSUE CRITICS CONTEND WHAT
IF YOU FIX WITH A PORSCHE
PROPOSED ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS FUNDING
LEVEL IS CRITICAL FOR TRANSIT
AGENCIES THAT THEY LOOK TO MAKE
CONTINUED PROGRESS ON THEIR
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES AMID THEIR
PANDEMIC INDUCED FUNDING
SHORTFALLS. IF YOU CONSIDER
THIS INVESTMENT WE WOULD URGE
YOU TO CREATE A FUNDING SET
ASIDE OF AT LEAST EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS PORTRAIT THAT
AGENCIES WITHIN THE PREMIUM
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS OUTLINE
FOR YOUR MACHINE TRUCKS BUSES
AND OFF ROAD FREIGHT. THAT SET
ASIDE WOULD GUARANTEE TRANSLATE
INTO THE FACT THAT THE FUNDING
NECESSARY TO DEPLOY AT LEAST
FOUR HUNDRED USER A MISSION
BOXES IN CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WHICH WOULD BE
CONSISTENT WITH REQUIREMENTS
UNDER CURRENT REGULATIONS ON IF
YOU CAN WE SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF THE STATURE
RELIEF MEASURES INCLUDING
EIGHTY NINETY IN EIGHTY ONE OF
SEVEN OF LAST YEAR IN ORDER TO
EXPAND THAT RELIEF. BEYOND WHAT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED UNTIL
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AT THE END IT'S INDUSTRY
AND TO THE PEOPLE TAKE UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY THREE PER
RIDERSHIP TO FULLY REBOUND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. ALL GOING OUT
HELLO TWENTY FIVE TWO FIVE
AIRLINE A- MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BRANDON TO A COMBI HALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL EXTENDING CLEAN AIR
PROGRAM FUNDING THAT WAS RE
AUTHORIZED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
BY AB EIGHT AUTHORED BY THEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS PEREIRA. AND
SKINNER THESE PROGRAMS WHICH
INCLUDE THE CARL MOYER MEMORIAL
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS
ATTAINMENT PROGRAM AND EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY THREE LOCAL
INCENTIVES PROGRAM ARE CRITICAL
TO MEETING CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN
AIR GOALS AND WE SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THAT RECOGNITION AND
COMMITMENT. AND COOPERATION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD AIR DISTRICTS
DID MINISTER THE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL CARL MOYER PROGRAM.
WHICH PROVIDES INCENTIVES TO
PRIVATE BUSINESSES AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO VOLUNTARILY CLEAN
UP OLDER DIRTIER VEHICLES AND
MOBILE OFF ROAD ENGINES SINCE
ITS INCEPTION IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT THEM WHERE PROGRAM
HAS ENABLED THE REPLACEMENT
SCRAPPAGE OF THE POWER OF OVER
SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND ENGINES.
RESULTING IN REDUCTION OF MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED NINETY FOUR
THOUSAND TONS OF NITROGEN
OXIDES AND REACTIVE ORGANIC
GASES WHICH CONTRIBUTE TO SMOG
FORMATION AND REDUCTION OF OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
TIMES A PARTICULAR MATTER WHICH
IS AN AIR TOXIC THE LOCAL AB
NINE TWENTY THREE INCENTIVES
PROGRAM. PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
SCHOOL BUS REPLACEMENT
AGRICULTURAL EQUIPMENT LIKE
RAPID BECAUSE SCRAPPING
PROGRAMS. YES SIR AND WHERE
BENEFIT SO THESE PROGRAMS ARE
ARE CRITICAL FOR MEETING OUR
OUR HEALTH BASED STANDARDS AND
WE URGE YOUR- YOUR SUPPORT OF
EXTENDING FUNDING. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE THREE THREE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAPLAIN MEMBERS ALEXANDER HERE
ON BEHALF OF CAL STAR HERE AT
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION NONPROFIT
WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MEMBERS. MIGHT EXPRESS
PORT FOR GOVERNOR INSTANCE
PROPOSED BUDGET AND THE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS ON
IMMEDIATE BANG FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INCLUDING TWO
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION FOR WHAT
HE DESIGNATED AS EARLY ACTION
FUNDING FOR THE G. CARE ACT.
WHICH IS ACTUALLY. OUR ALSO
SUPPORTED OF THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO
SECURITIZE THE BILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDING WE THINK THE NEED
FOR THAT INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING
PARTICULARLY IN THE NEXT FIVE
TO TEN YEARS WILL BE A MAN. AND
OUTWEIGHS THE NEED FUNDING HER
LATER YEARS AND WHILE WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROPOSED
BUDGET WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PLANNING CHIANG AND URGE THAT
THE TV RPD RESTORED INTO THE
BUDGET. I THAT IS THE CRITICAL
PROGRAM THAT INCREASES MEDIUM
AND LOW INCOME FAMILIES-
ACCEPTABILITY THE VERA MISSION
VEHICLES AS WELL AS WEEK. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM NINE THIRTY SEVEN THREE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU TRYING NUMBERS NIKITA
CROWDY WITH NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ON ISSUE NUMBER
SIX OF THAT PROPOSAL IS LIKE
IT'S A SEAT MY COMMENTS BUT
THOSE THE BILL GABBARD WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR. AND
THE CHARGER HEAD COALITION I
DON'T LIKE TO CONVEY ENERGY T.
STRONG SUPPORT FOR ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN WHICH REDIRECTS AND
INVOLVED ALREADY COLLECTED BUT
UNSPENT FUNDING UNUSABLE FROM
OUR NATIONAL PROGRAM. THE
PROPOSAL WILL PROVIDE
INCENTIVES TO ASSIST IN THE
DEPLOYMENT OF CLEAN
TECHNOLOGIES AND THE NEW HOMES
MARKET. THAT MAXIMIZE AND
BETTER UTILIZE THE BUILDING
SOLAR GENERATION AND PROVIDE A
CLEAN AND FLEXIBLE RESOURCE TO
THE ELECTRIC GRID IT ALSO WILL
HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
STREAMLINE THE PERMITTING AND
INSPECTION PROPERTIES FOR
TECHNOLOGIES THAT REDUCE
EMISSIONS AND BUILDING. WE LIKE
TO THINK ABOUT WHATEVER TANK
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE
AND URGE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
LEGISLATURE TO APPROVE THE
PROPOSAL. THIS YEAR
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU. WE'LL
GO TO ALLOW THREE SIX THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CHRISTIAN GOMEZ ON
BEHALF OF HYUNDAI MOTOR NORTH
AMERICA HYUNDAI SPEAKING TO
THAT PLAN AND WE'RE CONCERNED
WITH A LACK OF FUNDING FOR THE
T. V. R. P. WE LIMIT OUR
COMMENTS TODAY TO THREE ISSUES
THE LACK OF FUEL CELL VEHICLE
CONSUMER IN TENNIS. AND THE
GREEN CARDS FOR ALL AND CLEAN
FUEL REWARDS PROGRAM WE WILL
ALSO ASK THE STATE TO RESTORE
THE FEAR P. AT A MINIMUM OF TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR. FIRST WE
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT DROPPING
THE SEEDIER KENYANS THERE ARE
CONSUMER INCENTIVES FOR FUEL
CELL VEHICLES. FUEL CELL
VEHICLES ARE NOT ELIGIBLE UNDER
THE CLEAN FUEL REWARDS PROGRAM
AND EVEN IF THE QUEEN CORPORAL.
FUNDING COULD BE USED FOR THE
VEHICLE THAT PROGRAM CUSTOMER
BASE IS. NOT BUYING THEM
BECAUSE THEY'RE EXPENSIVE. YEAH
HUNDRED THE GOVERNOR FUNDING
FOR PART ALL BUT LET'S NOT
MISSING. AB R. P. AS A NON ECHO
PRO. GETTING EQUITY
CONSIDERATIONS WITH INCOME
REQUIREMENTS IN BOTH A STANDARD
REBATE AND INCREASED REBATE
PROGRAM. THE PROGRAM ALSO
ALLOWS FOR ALLOCATION
FLEXIBILITY BETWEEN THE
STANDARD AND INCREASED REBATE
PROGRAMS AS NEEDED TO ADDRESS
EQUITY PRIORITY BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. IN ADDITION WE
THINK IT'S A MISTAKE TO
CONFLATE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
FUNDING AT THE FACT THAT YOU
PERCEIVE YOUR P. THE
PROGRAMMATIC DESIGN OF THE PINK
CARD FOR ALL PROGRAMS LIMITED
TO REACH. IT'S AVAILABLE AND
JUST FOUR FIFTY THIRTY FIVE
YEAR DISTRICT. AND JUST LAST
MONTH THE CLEAN PARTS FOR ALL
PROGRAM REGION IMPORTANT
MILESTONE IT'S TEN THOUSAND
CUSTOMER. SINCE ITS FOUNDING IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN. BY CONTRAST
THE BRP REBATES ARE AVAILABLE
STATE WIDE AND HELP PUT MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT
THE CALIFORNIA ROADS. SINCE
TWENTY TEN IN SHORT BOTH THE
GOVERNOR AND THE REST OF NEED.
TO TAKE THEIR QUALITY COAL. I
YES THANK YOU I DO NEED. TO
WRAP UP BUT IF- I AM INTO. IN
KIND OF SIDE BY SIDE IN. OF
WHAT- IS BEING LOST- IF WE
DON'T MOVE FORWARD WITH C. B.
R. P. IF YOU COULD TO. PROVIDE
THAT TO ME I WOULD TO. LOOK
FORWARD TO READING IT. WE'RE
HAPPY TO DO SO THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT COMMUNISM LINE THIRTY NINE
THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAPLAIN THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LILLIAN MARKETS WITH
THE CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE
ENERGY AND I'M CALLING TODAY A
PART OF IT YOU THINK THE
GOVERNOR. ON THEIR MACHINE
VEHICLES IN THE PROPOSED
PROJECT. WHAT WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED ONE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN ELECTRIC VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE WANT TO
REITERATE CHAIR CHIANG AND
TERRIBLE AND POINTS THAT WE
CANNOT SUPPORT INFRASTRUCTURE
WITHOUT COMPLIMENTS YET WITH
THE ECONOMY AND THAT. KIND AND
AIR QUALITY GOALS CALIFORNIA.
GROW WITHOUT OR IS BY PROVIDING
PROVIDING INVESTMENT IN CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION AT TEN O'CLOCK.
AND INFRASTRUCTURE. CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY RECOMMEND
RESTORING FUNDS IN THE CLEAN
VEHICLE. REBATE PROJECT THE R.
P. GRAMINIS ACT I'M FAT
REPUBLICAN TO STAIN THE TERM
FOR TO GET IN FOR. TO
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM THANK
YOUNG. THANK YOU. NEXT APPLY
FORTY ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SH MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ALAN ABS FROM THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT I'M
COMMENTING ON ISSUE SIX ZERO
MISSION VEHICLE PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
FOLLOWING PROGRAMS. EXTENSION
OF AB EIGHT INCLUDING THE
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL CARL MOYER
PROGRAM RUN BY LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS AS DESCRIBED BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CAPCO UP THE
CLEAN CARDS FOR ALL PROGRAM
WHICH IS A NEW PROGRAM IN THE
BAY AREA ONLY HAVE BEEN BEEN
STARTED DEL- LESS THAN TWO
YEARS AGO ALREADY
OVERSUBSCRIBED IN HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN REPLACING OLDER
POLLUTING VEHICLES WITH
ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN OUR MOST
BURDEN COMMUNITIES. AND FINALLY
THE MULTIPLE HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
IN OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT
INVESTMENT PROGRAMS WHICH CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY CUT KNOCKED
EMISSIONS AND HIGHLY TOXIC
DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER IN
OUR CARGO AND FREIGHT CORRIDORS
IN THE BAY AREA WHICH ALSO
OVERLAP WITH COMMUNITIES WE'RE
TARGETING MOST TO ACHIEVING
THAT MISSION REDUCTIONS I
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL AND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. CONNECT COMENT COMES FROM
LINE SEVENTEEN ONE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU KIM
STONE OF STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM SEVEN REPURPOSE
THINGS NEW HOMES SO OUR
PARTNERSHIP FUND THAT SUPPORTS
AUTOMATED PERMITTING FOR
ROUTINE SOLAR INSTALLATIONS AND
ALSO TO SUPPORT ENERGY
EFFICIENCIES. INCLUDING BATTERY
FOR SOLAR PANELS AND NEW HOME
CONSTRUCTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO THE COMMITTEE AND
WITHIN THE NUMBER KING FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE ELEVEN ONE ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS INJURED ANTOLINI ITALY-
ON JULY INSTITUTE OF TECHNICAL
CLIENTS ARE STARTING WITH I
DIDN'T TEN- EDUCATION
DEVELOPMENT ACT BUILT. ON
BEHALF OF THE MUSTANG COUNTY
METROPOLITAN. AUTHORITY JAKE
THIS PROPOSAL- TO EXTEND
COMMONSENSE ENGINE. SPENDING
THAT THEY WILL PUBLIC TRYING
AGENCIES TO MAKE THEIR WAY
BACK- INTO- PAVING THE WAY OF
PROVIDING ALTERNATIVES TO
DRIVING AND INTEGRATED TRANSIT
THROUGHOUT THE ONLY REASON FOR
THE TRAVELING PUBLIC. AND FOR
THE I AM A CLIENT THE ADVANCED
ENERGY ECONOMY A GROUP ISSUE
NUMBER SIX- WE SUPPORT- THE
GOVERNOR'S ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR AN HOUR PHOTO OF
THE DOWN PAYMENT- I HAD TO
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. AND
COMMITMENTS IT'S FAR MARKET
TRANSPORTATION AND ATTRACT
PRIVATE CAPITAL WE APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION AS WE TURN TO
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN
WHICH THIS GROUP WAS PASSED THE
SPONSOR. AND ALBERT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE THEIR TO THE
THINKING ABOUT WHAT WE DO FOR
THE FUTURE WITH RESPECT MAKING
AN ASSESSMENT. REPORT DOLLAR
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION EEVEE
CHARGER AHEAD OF THE STATE'S
GOALS INCLUDING THE GOALS THEY
WERE LAID OUT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER. TODAY IT'LL
WORK OUT IN A WRAP UP THAT WE
NEED ONE POINT FIVE YEAH CAN
YOU ONLY HAD SIXTY SEVEN
THOUSAND TARGET SO WE HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO. WE APPRECIATE-
CHERUB LONGER FOCUSED ON THIS
AND THEN IT QUESTIONS FROM ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LOOK OUR TO A CONTRACT MISTER
ADVICE AND- THROWN MY NAME
AROUND I'M GOING TO HELP YOU
TODAY. OKAY AFTER MINUTE OVER
THE LIMIT AND I GOT. TO CUT YOU
OFF. THANK YOU. BACKSTROKE ALLY
THIRTY EIGHT THREE EIGHT A LOT
OF THE- I. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS DEFAULT YEAH CALIFORNIA.
RECORDED TRANSIT KALECKI SCOTT
I'M SPEAKING ABOUT THE
CALCULATED. NUMBER TEN ON THE
ABOUT KNACK- TROUBLING. WOULD
YOU ORDER SOME FOR DOT THANK WE
WILL BE THAT WRITTEN COMMENTS
AS WELL THAT CONSIDER OPTIONS
CHANGES TO LIKE REGARDING. THE
MESSAGE AFTER AND WE A NEW KIND
OF LONGER TERM ABOUT. FROM A
DAHLE AMOUNT TO EIGHTEEN NINETY
NINE SPENT TO RATE CHRIS AMOUNT.
BECAUSE LOCAL FROM THE ALSO
OKAY THE TERM ENDEMIC SO WE'VE
ACCORDING WITH YOU ON THAT I
THANKS THANK YOU MUCH. WELL I
AM ONE THREE NEARLY IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JOHN MY ON THE OF THE
ALLY FOR AUTOMOTIVE INNOVATION
THE- TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
AUTOMAKERS WANTED TO ADDRESS
THE CHAIRMAN'S- QUESTION-
DIRECTLY- AND ASSOCIATED MYSELF
WITH ONE OF OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES IN THE COMMENTS MADE
BY HYUNDAI WE ABSOLUTELY NEED
THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROGRAM MOVING FORWARD.
AUTOMAKERS SUBSIDIZE THE COST
OF THE EVERY SENSE SOLD BY IT
TO THE TUNE OF TEN TO FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER VEHICLE
EVEN SO THOSE IF THE CALLS ARE
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN THEIR
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE
COUNTERPARTS. THE C. B. A. R.
P. HELPS CLOSE THAT GAP AND
PROVIDE TO THE IMPORTANT
CONSUMER INCENTIVE- WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT TWO HUNDRED MILLIONDOLLARS FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND- IS AN
APPROPRIATE FUNDING SOURCE AN
AMOUNT FOR THAT THE PROGRAM
MOVING FORWARD- IN ADDITION WE
ALSO DO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL EQUITY
PROGRAM WE BELIEVE WE NEED. TO
GET SAYS- IN ALL HOUSEHOLDS AND
ALL COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE IF
WE ARE GOING. TO REACH OUR
GOALS MOVING INTO THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU MUCH. NEXT WE HAVE A
COMMENT FROM LINE FORTY THREE
FOUR THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PRAYER ON
BEHALF OF CHARGE POINT IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON SEPT FUNDING AND
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION. PROGRAMS
ISSUE NUMBER SIX. FOUNDED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN CHARGE
POINTS BASED IN CAMPBELL
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADING
PROVIDER OF VB CHARGING.
STATION HARDWARE AND SOFTWARE
IN NORTH AMERICA. CHARGEPOINT
SUPPORTS THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
THAT WILL CREATE JOBS AND
ECONOMIC GROWTH WHILE REDUCING
AIR POLLUTION. AND WILL PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS TO PURCHASE
CLEANER VEHICLES BY SECURITIZE
IN EVEY REGISTRATION FEES. AND
THAT THE STATE CAN INCENTIVIZE
AND ACCELERATE THE BUILD OUT
IT'S EASY CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. CHARGEPOINT
LOOKS FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT
FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS SUPPORTED
BY THIS BUDGET RESULT IN THE
QUICK AND EFFICIENT DEPLOYMENT
IF HE BE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS ARE MET AND THAT
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS ARE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR DISADVANTAGED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. AND
THAT THE STATE MEETS ITS
AMBITIOUS GOALS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU. WE'LL
GO TO LINE FORTY FOUR ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MARGARET CLANCY ON THE
BEHALF OF CRUZ THE ALL ELECTRIC
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE COMPANIES
THAT WILL OFFER RIDE SHARING
DELIVERY SERVICES WE ENCOURAGE
THE ADOPTION AT ON I. D. ON
ISSUE SIX THREE KURDS DEDUCTION
OF LANGUAGE TO ALLOW ENTITIES
THAT PROVIDE PUBLIC ACCESS FOR
PUBLIC BENEFIT TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR FUNDING FOR. THE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WE APPRECIATE
THE LEGISLATURE OVERALL FOCUS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S FOCUS ON
EXPANDING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ACCESS TO EAT THESE ACROSS THE
STATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO TO THE COMMON ONLINE
FORTY TWO FOUR TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
BLOOM AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
LET'S SEE THAT APARTMENT ON
BEHALF OF BURKE A POLICY
RESEARCH AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION PROMOTING
SUSTAINABILITY EQUITY AND
PROSPERITY IN THE BAY AREA. WE
ARE IN FRONT SUPPORT OF ITEM
SEVEN REPURPOSE THING INSULAR
HOME PARTNERSHIP FUNDING TO
SUPPORT AUTOMATED PERMITTING
FOR ROUTINE SOLAR INSTALLATIONS
AND SUPPORT ENERGY EFFICIENCY
TECHNOLOGIES AND NEW HOME
CONSTRUCTION. WE SUPPORT THIS
REPURPOSE THING TO ADDRESS IN
PARTICULAR THE PERMITTING AND
INSPECTION CHALLENGES THAT
PREVENT EXPANSION OF SOLAR FOR
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE
WHICH IS URGENTLY NEEDED TO
BUILD RESILIENCE AGAINST
WILDFIRES AND PS PS EVENTS. AND
TO MEET OUR STATE'S RENEWABLE
ENERGY TARGETS WE ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL AND THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KING FOR HIS LEADERSHIP.
ON THAT THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY SIX
FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
DILLON **** ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATION IN MY COMMENTS ON ISSUE
SIX. WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL TO RE
AUTHORIZE EXPANDED SECURITIZED
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM TOOK TWENTY FORTY SIX
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT DID YOUR
TOTAL AND THE AT THE END BUT
THAT THE PLACE ON EQUITY WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THE
CONCERN THAT THE PROPOSAL FALLS
SHORT OF DIRECTING TV
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING TO
INVEST LOW INCOME. OR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
WILL BENEFIT FROM THIS PROGRAM
ADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION
FOR DTS TO PUT CHARGING.
STATIONS IF THEY ON FACILITIES.
THE PROPOSAL PLAY CRITICAL ROLE
IN JUMP STARTING THE- VEHICLE
CHU MARKET AND REMAIN CRITICAL
TO HELPING INDUSTRY CHIEF
ECONOMY THAT KILLED NEEDED.
ADDITIONALLY WHERE
CONSERVATIVES DID MINISTRATION
NO LONGER PURSUING THE PROPOSAL
TO DELAY PROPERTY TAX
ASSESSMENT ON THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE COMPLETED BY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AT THIS
STAGE OF THE MARKET. ONE OF THE
MOST CRITICAL BARRIERS TO
DEPLOYMENT OR CAPITAL COSTS.
AND INCREASING TAXES YOU
PROPERTY TAX ASSESSMENT.
EXACERBATE THE ISSUE AT A TIME
WHEN INDUSTRY. PRIOR TITLE
SOLUTION TO DO THE OPPOSITE. WE
WOULD REQUEST OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
REVISIT THIS PROPOSAL. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH BOTH
THE LEGISLATURE AND MINISTRIES.
WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE PROPOSAL
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LINE FORTY FIVE FOUR FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS NATALIE
MAKARA ON BEHALF OF THAT WE
CAN'T AND CAL GRANT IN SUPPORT
OF ITEM SIX. BALLOT CAN HELP
OPERATE CLEAN CAR FROM THE
SENATE CAN VALLEY WHILE
CALTRANS FOR BY OUR CULTURAL
BAND CALLED SERVICES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S COMMENTS ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF EQUITY IN THE IN
THE STATE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
GOAL. FOR GOVERNOR SPECTACLE
WHAT IS CRITICAL ESPECIALLY THE
SEVENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
EARLY ALLOCATION TO CLEAN CARDS
FOR ALL AND OTHER EQUITY
PROGRAM. THE EARLY ACTION
ALLOCATION REFLECTS THE URGENT
NEED FOR IMMEDIATE FUNDING.
MANY EQUITY PROGRAM WHICH ARE
COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED
IMPACTED BY COURT OR QUALITY OF
NOT WORKING FUNDING IN NEARLY
TWO YEARS ARE CURRENTLY BEING
FORCED TO WIND DOWN AND WILL BE
FORCED TO SHUT DOWN IF ACTION.
IS NOT TAKEN IMMEDIATELY. THE
REASON WE ARE SO COMMITTEE TO
OPEN SUPPORT THAT BUDGET FOR.
ESPECIALLY AS IT PERTAINS TO
MEDIA FUNDING EQUITY PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT A
COMMON FROM LINE. FIVES YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AFTER THIS IS
JULIE NOW AND I BOTTLE OF THE
OF THAT. ELECTRIC COALITION
SEEKING TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX-
ITEM NUMBER SIX. WE BELIEVE
THAT COMMISSIONER MONAGHAN MADE
THE COST. FOR THIS PROGRAM FOR
THE RE AUTHORIZATION OF THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
AND SHE MAY BE- YOU KNOW THE
CASE THAT THIS GOES A LONG WAY
TO CLOSING THE INFRASTRUCTURE
GAP ANY ECONOMIC STIMULUS THAT
PROVIDE. REGARDING YOUR APP WE
WANT YOU TO JOIN THE CHORUS OF
CONCERN OVER THE HEARING OUT OF
THE C. B. R. P. IF YOU WANT TO
POINT OUT IT HAS BEEN BROUGHT
UP YET CARB APPROVED IT CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING PLAN.
JUST IN DECEMBER AND NOWHERE IN
THAT PLANTED IT IN JEST THAT CD
R. P. WAS NO LONGER NEEDED SO
WE HOPE. THAT THIS IS REVISITED
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. NEXEO FROM LINE FORTY FOUR
FOUR FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TURN MEMBERS
OBVIOUSLY CHAU ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
CALLING ON ON ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
THE DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE FARM THE FUNDING
DEDICATED TO THE FARMER PROGRAM
WE ARE ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S OVERALL STAFF
TO PUZZLE THE TYPICAL EITHER RE
AUTHORIZATION AT THE EIGHTY
EIGHT PROGRAMS. AS WELL AS THE
FUNDING FOR THE CLEAN TRUCK AND
BUS REPLACEMENTS CLEAN CARDS
FOR ALL AND OTHER EQUITY
PROGRAMS. AND THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF TALK ABOUT EQUITY IN
THIS COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY WE
WOULD POINT OUT THAT THE TECH
MARKET VALUES FROM TO TWENTY OF
THE THIRTY MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THE BALLOT COULD NOT REACH A
PAYMENT WITHOUT REGULAR
REGULATORY MEASURES ALONE WE
NEED THE THAN CENTER BASED
MEASURES AND THEY ARE NECESSARY
FOR US TO ACHIEVE
EXPEDITIOUSLY- HE MISSION
REDUCTIONS THANK. YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU'RE WELCOME. NEXT TO
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE FIFTH
ONE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE DURING US
DO WE THE WHITE FROM BEHALF OF
ELECTION CAL COMMENT ON JUNE.
THE PERSON ISSUES IS THAT
MOBILE HERE'S THE COMMITTEE TO
ADOPT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
DECEIVE PEOPLE INCREASE. RECENT
CT REPORT FOUND THAT NEW
TRADING STATION APPOINTMENT IS
NOT KEEPING UP WITH THE
SALESMAN AFTER. THIS LACK OF
EACH IN THROWING. TOWARDS EACH
EMISSION REDUCTION GOAL
ADDITIONALLY A REDUCING GHG
EMISSIONS IT'S CRITICAL TO
MEETING OUR STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
SCHOOL. NEXT ALERTING THEM WITH
OPTIONAL LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED MEETING IS THIS
PROPORTIONALLY AFFECTED BY
UNHEALTHY AIR QUALITY PUBLIC
INVESTMENT CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE TARGETS
INCLUDE TO HELP THE
COMMUNITIES. THAT HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY UNDER THE UNDER
REPRESENTATIVES OF INTERSECTION
APPOINTMENT AND SPEEDY ADOPTION
OF INTROVERSION CHIU NEW
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY. ISSUE SEVEN
THE STORAGE OF UNSPENT FUNDS WE
WOULD LIKE THE UNSPENT FUNDS TO
BE DIRECTED TO STREAMLINE THE
FORTY TRUCKS IN PROGRESS
PROCESS. WHICH WILL ENABLE MORE
CALIFORNIANS TO GET THEIR POWER
TO STORE ENERGY ACCELERATOR
STATES CLEAN ENERGY EXPANSION
COMMUTER AMBITIOUS CARBON
NEUTRALITY GOAL. THEY CONSUMERS
MONEY ON THEIR ENERGY BILLS AND
CREATE JOBS PARTICULARLY. IN
THE SMALL BUSINESS SECTOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT COME
FROM FOR SEVEN FOR SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS A- GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE-
FERRARI ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION CALLING IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE ITEMS
SEVEN PERTAIN TO THE REPORT
THING OF THE UNSPENT NEW SOLAR
HOME PARTNERSHIP FUNDS- AND
IT'S H. P. HAS BEEN WITHOUT
QUESTION. THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY HAS EVER
PARTICIPATED IN AND BECAUSE OF
THAT PARTNERSHIP BUILDERS WERE
IN A POSITION BACK IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO SUPPORT A FIRST OF
ITS KIND STATEWIDE SOLAR
MANDATE- AND WITH AND IT'S H.
P. NOW WINDING DOWN. THIS
PROPOSAL WE BELIEVE TAKES THE
NEXT APPROPRIATE STEP IN
INCENTIVIZING EARLY AFTER EARLY
EFFORTS EARLY ACTION TO MOVE
THE CLEANER TECHNOLOGIES AND CB
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH.
ENERGY C. STAKEHOLDERS AND. AND
THE COMMITTEE ON THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OUR FINAL
COMMENT IN Q. AS LINE FIFTY TWO
FIVE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS ROSS BARKLEY ON
BEHALF OF SOUTH HMD WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THROUGHOUT THE ITS KEY
AIR QUALITY FUNDING SOURCES
PREVIOUSLY EXTENDED BY AB
EIGHT. WE ARE CLOSING THESE
QUEEN AIR TECHNOLOGY INVESTMENT
PROGRAMS WILL HELP ADDRESS AIR
POLLUTION IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH
ESPECIALLY IN THIS ADVANCED
COMMUNITY BUCKLEY AT THE STATE
VEHICLE FLEET EXCELLING
DEPLOYMENT OF CLEANER
TECHNOLOGIES. EXTENSION TO
TWENTY FORTY SIX AND THINK WHAT
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
AND CRITICAL CHEATING THE GOAL
THAT WATER. IN PARTICULAR IF
THE CAR MORAL PROGRAM PROVIDES
INCENTIVES TO ASSIST IN
PURCHASE OF CLEAR THE REQUIRED
HEAVY DO YOU THE VEHICLE ENGINE
AND CABIN TECHNOLOGIES. FROM
MORAL COCKERHAM WHERE HAS
RESULT IN OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED POUNDS OF KNOCKED
IN TWO HUNDRED FORTY NINE TONS
OF PARTICULAR MATTER EMISSION
REDUCTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
THROUGHOUT THE. REGION ALONG.
IT REDUCTIONS ARE CRITICAL TO
FUNDING EXPOSURE AIRBORNE. BY
COPA NINETY. MAY INCREASE
THAT'S THE THING THAT'S RIGHT
NAY GET HOW IMPACTS. FURTHER
SOUTH OF THE IN PERIL DEADLINE
REDUCE AIR POLLUTION IF NOT NOT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS SANCTIONS.
RESTRICTIONS ON BUSINESS AND-
HER COULD. THANK YOU ALLOWING
ME TO PACK TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY. OPERATOR THAT WAS LAST.
THAT IS CORRECT MISTER CHAIR NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE- WITH THAT- FINAL
COMMENT. OUR HEARING COMES TO A
CONCLUSION WE ARE ADJOURNED.
UNTIL OUR NEXT HEARING WHICH
WE'RE NOT QUITE SURE WHEN
THAT'S GOING TO BE BUT IT-
MAYBE A FEW WEEKS FROM NOW.
WE'LL SEE EVENT WERE ADJOURNED.